hello everyone and welcome to this
fantastic natural language processing
full course by simply learn before we
begin with the video if you enjoy
watching these kind of videos and find
them interesting then subscribe to our
YouTube channel because we bring the
best videos for you daily also hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn so without any further
delay let's go through the agenda for
this video we'll brief you with a
detailed introduction to natural
language processing after that we'll see
the NLP engineer road map followed by
the salary of an NLP engineer we'll walk
you through some fantastic Concepts like
AI versus machine learning versus deep
learning and after that we'll see text
mining in NLP following that we'll cover
topics like what is generative Ai and
large language models in artificial
intelligence after covering all these
topics we'll see algorithms and projects
like sentiment analysis and email spam
classifiers speaking of interviews we
have covered you along with the most
frequently Asked interview questions to
help you crack the toughest interviews
but before we move on to what NLP is if
you are an aspiring Ai and machine
learning engineer then there's no better
time to train yourself in the exciting
field of artificial intelligence if
you're looking for a course that covers
everything from the fundamentals to
Advanced Techniques then accelerate your
career in Ai and machine learning with a
comprehensive post-graduate program in
Ai and machine learning boost your
career with this Ai and ml course
delivered in collaboration with the puru
university and IBM learn in demand
skills such as machine learning deep
learning NLP computer vision
reinforcement learning generative AI
prompt engineering chat GPT and many
more you'll receive a prestigious
certificate and ask me anything sessions
by IBM with five capstones in different
domains using real data sets you will
gain practical experience master classes
by PD faculty and IBM experts ensure
topnotch education simply learns job
assist help help you get noticed by
Leading companies this program covers
statistics python supervised and
unsupervised learning NLP neural
networks computer vision G scaras
tensorflow and many more search skills
admission to this postgraduate program
in Ai and machine learning requires a
bachelor's degree with an average of 50%
or higher marks along with the basic
understanding of programming Concepts
and Mathematics and candidates with two
plus years of work experience are
preferred to enroll in this school so
roll now and unlock exciting Ai and
machine learning opportunities the link
is mentioned in the description box
below so without any further Ado let's
send over this session to a training
expert hey everyone in this video we'll
be talking about NLP in the next 10
minutes so what can you expect from this
video what's in it for you first we'll
give you a basic understanding of NLP
we'll tell you why we need NLP and we'll
talk about what NLP exactly is next
we'll look at NLP pipeline L NLP
pipelines cover the basic processes
involved in text passing in NLP which
means converting text to a form suitable
for machines to understand as humans
would understand it and finally we'll
talk about some real world applications
of NLP which are all around us and a lot
more common than you might have realized
so let's get started so what exactly is
NLP before we talk about NLP let's talk
about how humans talk and interact with
each other humans communicate with each
other mostly via speech or text to
convey your intent to someone you may
directly talk to them or send them a
message the human way of communicating
is known as natural language around the
globe many languages are spoken and
messages are shared virtually every
single day all these conversations
feedbacks and messages are data in
themselves this data is extremely
valuable as it can give us customer
information and insight into human
sentiment however this data is not
useful to computers as it is not in a
form that can be understood by machines
machines communicate using ones and
zeros and not via words they cannot
understand English French or Spanish
only binary and this is where NLP comes
into the picture NLP stands for natural
language processing natural language
processing is a branch of artificial
intelligence that deals with the
interactions between humans and
computers using the natural language the
ultimate objective of NLP is to read
decipher understand and make sense of
human languages in a manner that is
valuable and to build systems that can
make sense of text and perform tasks
like translation grammar checking or
topic classification NLP basically is
the task of processing written forms of
languages and making a computer
understand them companies are
increasingly using NLP equipped tools to
gain insights from data and to automate
routine tasks a sentiment analyzer for
instance can help Brands detect emotions
in text such as negative comments on
social
media NLP at the end of the day is
nothing more than a cumulation of
artificial intelligence computer science
and the human language the next topic
that we'll be looking at are NLP
pipelines so what exactly are Pipelines
a pipeline is a set of data processing
Elements which are connected in series
where the output of one element is the
input of the next one it basically
represents the various steps which have
to be taken in our computation and the
order in which they
occur in this pipeline we are going to
be parsing our data parsing means
converting our data from one form to
another in this case we are passing our
input Text data to a file which can be
understood by via computer the text is
first broken into segments and the
segments are then converted into even
smaller
tokens the word stems of all of these
tokens are found followed by finding the
root words of these stems in a process
known as
lemmatization we will then recognize
which part of speech the word belongs to
which means if the word is a verb a noun
or a pronoun and finally we will
separate the instances of everyday
popular entities from our words to
better understand what the sentence is
trying to convey the final file that
we'll get will be a file which will be
understood by a computer segmentation
the first process of a pipeline is
segmentation now what exactly is
segmentation sentence segmentation or
text segmentation is basically dividing
the given text into logically
decipherable units of information we
divide this sentence into its
constituent Subs sentences usually along
the punctuations like full stops or
commas or along line breaks and Page
components for HTML files dividing a
document into its constituent sentences
allows us to process it without losing
its Essence and the necessary
information that it contains in this
case let's consider a sentence the
lemonade quenched her thirst but not her
longing after sentence segmentation we
are going to divide this sentence into
two the first sentence is going to be
the lemonade quenched her thirst and the
second one is going to be but not her
longing the next step of our pipeline is
called tokenization tokenization is
nothing but the process of dividing a
sentence into its constituent words the
sentence that is given to us will be
separated and all the words in the
sentence will be stored separately this
is done so we can understand the syntax
IC and semantic information contained in
each sentence thus we decipher the
relevance of a sentence by analyzing it
word by word thereby making sure that no
loss of information occurs the computer
does not understand punctuations and
special characters hence we can remove
any punctuations and special characters
which may occur let's take a part of our
previously segmented sentence over here
let's consider the lemonade quenched her
thirst after toen ization we are going
to separate every single word in this
sentence so after tokenization we are
going to get five different tokens the
lemonade quenched her and thirst all of
these are going to be treated as
separate entities after tokenization we
perform stemming stemming is a process
of obtaining the word stems of a word
word stems are also known as the base
form of a word and we can create new
words by attaching a fixes to them in a
process known as inflection stemming is
a process of recognizing the word stems
of individual words this is done by
removing affixes such as in s ed etc for
example consider our sentence jump jump
is the word stem of various different
words like
jumping jumped and jumps if we remove
all of these affixes we will get our
basic word stem which is Jump this is
basically what we want at the end of
stemming the next process in our
pipeline is called lemmatization
lemmatization is the process of figuring
out the root form or root word which is
nothing but the most basic form also
known as the Lemma of each word in the
sentence lemmatization is very similar
to stemming where we remove word affixes
to get the base form of a word the
difference is that the root word is
always a word which is present in the
dictionary but the root stem may not be
so
lemmatization uses a knowledge Base
called word net let's consider three
different words went going and gone at
the end of the day all of these words
have originated from a single word which
is go in this case go is our Lemma all
the other words which are derived from
go can be traced back to it the next
part of a pipeline is called part of
speech tagging part of speech tagging is
a process of converting a sentence to
different forms it can be a list of
words or a list of
tuples the tag in case of is a part of
speech tag and signifies whether the
word is a noun adjective verb and so on
we are basically splitting our verbs
into the grammatical components to
understand the meaning of any sentence
or to extract relationships and to build
a Knowledge Graph part of speech tagging
is a very important step as the same
word can have different part of speeches
in different sent sentences for example
let's consider the sentence give me your
answer in this sentence answer is a noun
but if we consider another sentence
answer the question over here answer
will be a verb using part of speech
tagging we can take our different tokens
and find the different part of speech
that it belongs to in this case the is a
determiner lemonade is a noun quenched
is a verb her is a pronoun and thirst is
a noun the final step in our NLP
pipeline that we are looking at here is
nothing but named entity recognition
named entity recognition also known as
named entity
identification entity chunking and
entity extraction is a subtask of
information extraction that seeks to
locate and classify named entities which
are mentioned in unstructured text into
predefined categories extracting the
main entities in a text helps us sort
unstructured data and detect important
information which is crucial if you have
to deal with large data sets the
subcategories that we are considering
are person whether the named entity is a
person whether it's a quantity like
kilogram a
location an
organization the name of a movie or
whether it's a monetary value like
dollars or
Euros so far we've looked at what NLP is
and how we can perform natural language
processing but what are some
applications of it and where is it used
in the real
world one of the applications of NLP is
in chatbots chat Bots can help you solve
issues while performing natural language
generation in other words they can hold
a conversation in plain English a
chatbot is nothing but a software
application which can be used to conduct
an online chat conversation either
through text or speech in place of
providing direct contact with a life
human agent you might have seen those
talk to one of our agents section on
websites those are usually chat Bots a
lot of companies also use WhatsApp chat
Bots to make the process seem less
mechanical another application of NLP is
speech recognition probably the most
popular example of NLP in action are
virtual assistants like Google assist
Siri and Alexa natural language
processing understands and translates
the human language like Hey Siri where
is the nearest gas station into numbers
making it easy for machines to
understand they recognize when you are
talking converting speech to text and
understand what you requested over the
years virtual assistants have become
streamlined enough to be able to emulate
human speech patterns almost flawlessly
another application of NLP is autoc
correction autocorrection also known as
text replacement replace as you type or
simply autoc correct is an automatic
data validation function commonly found
in word processors and text editing
interfaces for smartphones and tablet
computers it acts as a spell check and
corrects any spellings or grammar
mistakes which may arise as you are
typing some language check softwares
like grammarly paper r
reverso and others can even check how
unique and engaging your articles are
and all of this is done using NLP hello
everyone welcome to this video on the
natural language processing engineer NLP
engineer road map by simply learn to
stay updated with our content make sure
to subscribe to our YouTube channel and
hit the Bell icon so in this video we
will Begin by examining the role of NLP
engineer progressing further our Focus
will shift toward the Essential
Knowledge and Skills required to excel
as an NLP engineer having
comprehensively explored these subjects
we will then proceed to explore the Ines
and consing of a professional career
road map tailored specifically for
individual aspiring to become
accomplished NLP Engineers on that note
if you are an expiring AIML engineer
then there is no better time to train
yourself in the exciting field of
machine learning if you are looking for
course that covers everything from the
fundamentals to Advanced Techniques like
machine learning algorithm development
and unsupervised learning look no
further than our ctech program
partnership with IBM this AIML boot camp
in collaboration with keltech will help
you advance your career as AIML
specialist the AIML boot camp includes
live classes delivered by industry
expert handson L industry relevant
projects and master classes by ctech
Professor key features of this amazing
machine learning course includes earn up
to 22 cus from Kelch ctme online
convocation by Kelch ctm program
director simply career service helps you
get noticed by top hiring companies on a
boot camp certificate get from CeX ctm
industry relevant project in three
domains CeX ctm Circle membership 25
plus Hands-On project across industry
verticals with integrated Labs so why
wait join now seats are filling fast
find the course link from the
description box below so without any
further to do let's get started so what
is NLP engineer an assure language
processing NLP engineer is a
professional responsible for crafting
and cening computer system that can
process asss and produce humanik
language NLP bres out into numerous
captivating domains including semantic
analysis sentiment analysis face
recognition machine translation and
speech recognition the reach of NLP
extend across a diverse spectrum of
application notably featuring virtual
assistant chat boards sentiment analysis
customer service interaction and
language translation the task of NLP
engineer involves ER acting these
Innovative application and seemingly
embedding them into the existing
framework the the average salary for NLP
engineer in India is 10 lakh per year
and in the US average annual salary for
NLP engineer is
$120,000 so moving forward let's see
skills required as an NLP engineer so
becoming an NLP engineer entails
acquisition of a diverse set of
application and knowledge some of these
encompasses first one is Proficiency in
programming Mastery of at least one
programming language such as python Java
or C++ coupled with the solid graphs of
data structure algor and principle of
software engineering the second one is
grasp of machine learning building a
strong foundation in machine learning
algorithm and compassing both supervised
and unsupervised learning familiarity
with Advanced Techniques like CNN and
RNN is vital the third one is NLP
techniques cultivating a deep
understanding of NLP techniques which
encompasses facets like text
pre-processing centic and semantic
analysis and the ingrate domain of
sentiment analysis the fourth one is NLP
libraries and Frameworks navigate easily
through NLP libraries and Frameworks
such as natural language toolkit nltk
spy Stanford code NLP and genim
harnessing their capabilities to
streamline your NLP and davors the fifth
one is data science acuma developing a
sound gaps of data science principles
and compassing facets such as data
visualization statical analysis and the
Art of data manipulation armed with
these multiac skill set you will be
primed to embark on a journey as an
accomplished NLP engineer ready to
navigate the complexity of natural
languages processing and contribute to
the exciting world of NLP Innovation
moving forward let's see the
professional NLP engineer road map here
is a comprehensive professional
trajectory for those aspiring to become
NLP Engineers the first one is
Educational Foundation embark on your
journey by pursuing a degree in
compitent fields such as computer
science Linguistics or artificial
intelligence many accomplish NLP
Engineers hold Advanced degrees either a
master or PhD in these domains the
second one is internship or entry-level
Venture considering immersing yourself
in Practical experience through
internship or entry-level job within the
industry these opportunities not only
equ with the Hands-On expertise but also
Aid in constructing a robust portfolio
the third one on the list is skills and
knowledge acquisition develop a
comprehensive grasp of essential
proficiency request of NLP engineer this
encompasses programming processes and
machine learning and NLP techniques and
data science the fourth one is portfolio
development curate a diverse portfolio
teaming with projects that illuminate
your capabilities and expertise projects
like suffocated chatboard a sentiment
analysis tool or a language model can
sustain your aptitude for solving real
world NLP challenges and validate your
skill set for potential employers the
fifth one is networking endears engage
in conference meetups and industries
even to forge connection with fellow NLP
professionals the sixth one is
specialization consideration p under the
prospect of specialization in specific
NLP realm be it machine translation
speech recognition or conversational
agent this specialization not only
differentiate you in the job market but
also enables you to attain expertise
within a particular need in summation
the part toward becoming an NLP engineer
entails a fusion of educational
attainment hands-on experience and the
Mastery of electric area of skills and
knowledge domains hello everyone and
welcome to this new video on NLP
engineer salary with the world advancing
towards a more informed and databased
future learning skills that help us to
be relevant in the job market is crucial
one such skill in the field of data and
AI is natural language processing let us
start by understanding what NLP is
natural language processing or NLP is a
branch of artificial intelligence or AI
that deals with understanding and
manipulating human language it seeks to
develop algorithms and systems that can
understand and process both structured
and unstructured language data to
support decision making processes LLP is
a field that has been gaining momentum
in recent years thanks to advance in
machine learning algorithms and the
availability of large data sets such as
social media conversations customer
reviews and medical records NLP is used
in various applications such as language
translation sentiment analysis text
summarization and text generation if you
want to master NLP and become an expert
NLP engineer then you should enroll an
amazing Ai and machine learning program
by CTIC ctme you will gain skills like
machine learning deep learning
reinforcement learning NLP generative AI
prompt engineering chat GPT and more
this Ai and machine learning boot camp
includes live classes delivered by
industry experts Hands-On Labs industry
relevant projects and master classes by
calch instructor s so hurry up what are
you waiting for enroll the course now
find the course Link in the description
box so before we move ahead consider
subscribing to Simply learn and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
us so let's move ahead by knowing what
does NLP include at its score NLP
involves a series of steps number one is
pre-processing the first step in NLP is
to prepare the language data for
analysis this involves activities such
as cleaning tokenizing ation and
normalization of the text Data step two
involves feature extraction the next
step is to extract relevant features
from the prepared data this involves
identifying keywords stems and parts of
speech tags that are important for the
task at hand step three involves model
training the extracted features are then
used to train a machine learning model
such as neural networks or a support
Vector machine to predict the target
variable and the last step is model
evaluation once the model is trained it
needs to be evaluated to ensure it
performs well on new data now let's move
ahead by knowing NLP job roles and
responsibilities several job roles that
involve NLP and each role is focused on
different aspects of NLP here are some
most common NLP job roles the number one
is NLP engineer this role involves
developing and implementing NLP
Solutions including building machine
learning models designing pipelines and
developing apis NLP Engineers typically
have a background in engineering or
computer science and have knowledge of
machine learning algorithms software
development and data structures the next
we have is text analytics specialist
this role involves analyzing large
amount of Text data to extract useful
information text analytics specialist
typically have a background in data
analysis statistics and machine Lear
learning and they use NLP tools and
techniques to process and analyze text
Data language model engineer this role
involves developing and improving
natural language processing models such
as language models and machine
translation models language model
Engineers typically have a background in
computer science machine learning and
natural language processing on number
four we have NLP researcher this role
involves conducting Research into new
NLP methods and techniques NLP
researchers typically have a background
in computer science machine learning and
natural language processing and they
publish their research in various
academic journals and conferences and
the most awaited let's start with salary
of NLP Engineers let us now discuss the
salary of NLP engineers in India and USA
for the sake of better understanding we
will split up the salary ranges based on
the experience level of a professional
so let's start with entry level NLP
engineers in India the salary ranges
from 2.5 million rupees to 5 million
rupees however in us the salary ranges
between $60,000 to $90,000 per year
enter level NLP Engineers typically have
background in computer science
engineering or a related field and have
some experience with NLP but may not
have yet worked on large scale
Enterprise projects moving towards
midlevel NLP Engineers these Engineers
earn 5 million to 8 million rupees per
year however in United States they earn
between $90,000 to
$120,000 per year mid-level NLP
Engineers have few years of experience
working on NLP projects and are
typically comfortable working on both
Technical and business related aspects
of NLP projects they may have some
leadership responsibilities and are
often responsible for ensuring that NLP
projects are completed on time and to
speec next we have a senior level NLP
Engineers these Engineers earn up to 8
million rupees to 15 million rupees in
India per year however in United States
they earn between
$120,000 to
$165,000 per year senior level NLP
Engineers have extensive experience
working on Enterprise level NLP projects
and are often considered authorities in
NLP Technologies methods and tools they
may serve as subject matter experts lead
teams of engineers and other NLP
professionals and be responsible for
ensuring the long-term success of NLP
projects human versus artificial
intelligence humans are amazing let's
just face it we're amazing creatures
we're all over the planet we're
exploring every nii and Nook we've gone
to the Moon uh we've gone into outer
space we're just amazing creatures we're
able to use the available information to
make decisions to communicate at with
other people identify patterns and data
remember what people have said adapt to
new situations so let's take a look at
this so so you can get a picture you're
a human being so you know what it's like
to be human let's take a look at
artificial intelligence versus the human
artificial intelligence develops
computer systems that can accomplish
taxs that require human
intelligence so we're looking at this
one of the things that computers can do
is they can provide more accurate
results this is very important recently
did project on cancer where it's
identifying
markers and as a human being you look at
that and you might be uh looking at all
the different images and the data that
comes off of them and say I like this
person so I want to give them a very
good um Outlook and the next person you
might not like so you want to give him a
bad Outlook well with artificial
intelligence you're going to get a
consistent prediction of what's going to
come out interacts with humans using
their natural language we've seen that
as probably the big biggest development
feature right now that's in the
commercial Market that everybody gets to
use as we saw with the example of Alexa
they learn from their mistakes and adapt
to new environments so we see this
slowly coming in more and more and they
learn from the data and automate
repetitive learning repetitive learning
has a lot to do with the neural networks
you have to program thousands upon
thousands of pictures in there and it's
all automated so as today's computers
evolved it's very quick and easy and
affordable to do this what is machine
learning and deep learning all about
imagine this say you had some time to
waste not that any of us really have a
lot of time anymore to just waste in
today's world and you're sitting by the
road and you have a whole lot of and a
whole lot of time passes by here's a few
hours and suddenly you wonder how many
cars buses trucks and so on passed by in
the 6 hours now chances are you're not
going to sit by the road for 6 hours and
count buses cars and trucks unless
you're working for the city and you're
trying to do City Planning and you want
to know hey do we need to add a new
truck route maybe we need a Bicycle Link
we have a lot of bicyclists here that
kind of thing so maybe City Planning
would be great for this machine learning
well the way machine Learning Works is
we have labeled data with
features okay so you have a truck or a
car a motorcycle a bus or a bicycle and
each one of those are labeled it comes
in and based on those labels and
comparing those features it gives you an
answer it's a bicycle it's a truck it's
a motorcycle this look a little bit more
in depth on this in the model here it
actually the features we're looking at
would be like the tires someone sits
there and figures out what a tire looks
like takes a lot of work if you try to
try to figure the difference between a
car tire a bicycle tire a motorcycle
tire uh so in the machine learning field
this could take a long time if you're
going to do each individual aspect
aspect of a car and try to get a result
on there and that's what they did do
that was a a very this is still used on
smaller amounts of data where you figure
out what those features are and then you
label them deep learning so with deep
learning one of our Solutions is to take
a very large unlabeled data set and we
put that into a training model using
artificial neural networks and then that
goes into the neural network itself when
we create a neural network and you'll
see um the arrows are actually kind of
backward but uh which actually is a nice
point because when we train the neural
network we put the bicycle in and then
it comes back and says if it said truck
it comes back and says well you need to
change that to bicycle and then it
changes all those weights going backward
they call it back propagation and let it
know it's a bicycle and that's how it
learns once you've trained the neural
network you then put the new data in and
they call this testing the model so you
need to have some data you've kept off
to the side where you know the answer to
and you take that and you provide the
required output and you say okay is this
is this neural network working correctly
did it identify a bike as a bike a truck
as a truck a motorcycle as a motorcycle
let's just take a little closer look at
that determining what objects are
present in the data so how does deep
learning do this and here we have the
image of the bike it's 28x 28 pixels
that's a lot of information there um
could you imagine trying to guess that
this is a bicycle image by looking at
each one of those pixels and trying to
figure out what's around it uh and we
actually do that as human beings it's
pretty amazing we know what a bicycle is
and even though it comes in has all this
information and what this looks like is
the image comes in it converts it into a
bunch of different nodes in this case
there's a lot more than what they show
here and it goes through these different
layers and out comes and says okay this
is a
bicycle a lot of times they call this
the magic Black Box why because as we
watch it go across here all these
weights and all all the math behind this
and it's not it's a little complicated
on the math side you really don't need
to know that when you're programming or
doing working with the Deep learning but
it's like magic you you don't know you
really can't figure out what's going to
come out by looking what's in each one
of those dots and each one of those
lines are firing and what's going in
between them so we like to call it the
magic box uh so that's where deep
learning comes in and in the end it
comes up and you have this whole neural
notwork it comes up and it says okay we
fire all these different pixels and we
connects all these different dots and
gives them different Waits and it says
okay this is a bicycle and that's how we
determine what the object is present in
the data with deep learning machine
learning we're going to take a step into
machine learning here and you'll see how
these fit together in a minute the
system is able to make predictions or
take decisions based on past data that's
very important for machine learning is
that we're looking at stuff and based on
what's been there before we're creating
a decision on there we're creating
something out of there we're coloring a
beach ball we're telling you what the
weather is in Chicago what's nice about
machine learning is a very powerful
processing capability it's quick and
accurate outcomes so you get results
right away once you program the system
the results are very fast and the
decisions and predictions are better
they're more accurate they're consistent
you can analyze very large amounts of
data some of these data things that
they're analyzing now are pedabytes and
terabytes of data it would take hundreds
of people hundreds of years to go
through some of this data and do the
same thing that the machine learning can
do in a very short period of time and
it's inexpensive compared to hiring
hundreds of people so it becomes a very
affordable way to move into the future
is to apply the machine learning to
whatever businesses you're working on
and deep Learning Systems think and
learn like humans using artificial
neural networks again it's like a magic
box performance improves with more data
so the the more data the Deep learning
gets the more it gives you better
results it's scalability so you can
scale it up you can scale it down you
can increase what you're looking at
currently you know we're limited by the
amount of computer processing power as
to how big that can get but that
envelope continually gets pushed every
day on what it can do problem solved in
an end to end method so instead of
having to break it apart and you have
the first piece coming in and you
identify tires and the second piece is
identifying uh labeling handlebars and
then you bring that together that if it
has handlebars and tires it's a bicycle
and if it has something that looks like
a large Square it's probably a truck the
neural networks does this all in one
network you don't really know what's
going on in all those weights and all
those little bubbles uh but it does it
pretty much in one package that's why
the neural network systems are so big
nowadays and coming into their own best
features are selected by the system and
it this is important they kind of put it
as it's on a bullet on the side here
it's a subset of machine learning this
is important when we talk about deep
learning it is a form of machine
learning there's lots of other forms of
machine learning data analysis but this
is the newest and biggest thing that
they apply to a lot of different
packages and they use all the other
machine learning tools available to work
with it and it's very fast to test um
you put in your information you then
have your group of uh test and then you
held some aside you see how does it do
it's very quick to test it and see
what's going on with your deep learning
and your neural network are they really
all that
different AI versus machine learning
versus deep learning concepts of AI so
we have a concepts of II you'll see
natural language processing uh machine
learning an approach to create
artificial intelligence so it's one of
the subsets of artificial intelligence
knowledge representation automated
reasoning computer vision
robotics machine learning versus AI
versus deep learning or Ai and machine
learning and deep
learning so when we look at this we have
ai with machine learning and deep
learning and so we're going to put them
all together we find out that AI is a
big picture we have a collection of
books that goes through some deep
learning the Digital Data is analyzed
text mining comes through the particular
book you're looking for maybe it's a
genre books is identified and in this
case uh we have a robot that goes and
gives a book to the patron I have yet to
be at a library that has a robot bring
me a book but that will be cool when it
happens uh so we look at some of the
pieces here this information goes into
uh as far as this example the
translation of the handwritten printed
data to digital form that's pretty hard
to do that's pretty hard to go in there
and translate hundreds and hundreds of
books and understand what they're trying
to say if you've never read them so in
this case we use the Deep learning
because you can already use examples
where they've already classified a lot
of books and then they can compare those
texts and say oh okay this is a book on
automotive repair this is a book on
robotic building the Digital Data is in
analyzed then we have more text mining
using machine learning so maybe we'd use
a different program to do a basic
classify uh what you're looking for and
say oh you're looking for auto repair
and computers so you're looking for
automated cars once it's identified then
of course it brings you the
book so here's a nice summation of what
we were just talking about AI with
machine learning and deep learning deep
learning is a subset of machine learning
which is a subset of artificial
intelligence so you can look at
artificial intelligence as a big picture
how does this compare to The Human
Experience in either uh doing the same
thing as a human we do or it does it
better than us
and machine learning which has a lot of
tools uh is something that learns from
data past experiences it's programmed
it's uh comes in there and it says hey
we already had these five things happen
the sixth one should be about the same
and then uh then there's a lot of tools
in machine learning but deep learning
then is a very specific tool in machine
learning it's the artificial neural
network which handles large amounts of
data and is able to take huge pools of
experiences pictures and ideas and bring
them together real life
examples artificial intelligence news
generation very common nowadays as it
goes through there and finds the news
articles or generates the news based
upon the news feeds or the uh backend
coming in and says okay let's give you
the actual news based on this there's
all the different things Amazon Echo
they have a number of different Prime
music on there of course there's also
the Google command and there's also
Cortana there's tons of smart home
devices now where we can ask it to turn
the TV on or play music for us that's
all artificial intelligence from front
to back you're having a human experience
with these computers and these objects
that are connected to the processing
machine learning uh spam detection very
common machine learning doesn't really
have the human interaction part so this
is the part where it goes and says okay
that's a Spam that's not a Spam and it
puts it in your spam
folder search engine result refining uh
another example of machine learning
whereas it looks at your different
results and it Go and it uh is able to
categorize them as far as this had the
most hits this is the least viewed this
has five stars um you know however they
want to wait it uh all exam good
examples of machine learning and then
the Deep learning uh deep learning
another example is you know because you
have like a exit sign in this case is
translating it into French sorti I hope
I said that right um neural network has
been programmed with all these different
words and images and so it's able to
look at the exit in the middle and it
goes okay we want to know what that is
in French and it's able to push that out
in French French and learn how to do
that and then we have chatbots um I
remember when Microsoft first had their
little paperclip um boy that was like a
long long time ago that came up and you
would type in there and chat with it
these are growing you know it's nice to
just be able to ask a question and it
comes up and gives you the answer and
instead of it being were you're just
doing a search on certain words it's now
able to start linking those words
together and form a sentence in that
chat box types of AI and machine
learning types of artificial
intelligence this in the next few slides
are really important so one of the types
of artificial intelligence is is
reactive machines systems that only
react they don't form memories they
don't have past experiences they have
something that happens to them and they
react to it my washing machine is one of
those if I put a ton of clothes in it
and they had all clumped on one side it
automatically adds a weight to reitter
it so that my washing machine is
actually a reactive machine working with
whatever the load is and keeps it nice
and so when it spins it doesn't go
thumping against the side limited memory
another form of artificial intelligence
systems look into the past information
is added over a period of time and
information is shortlived when we're
talking about this and you look at like
a neural network that's been programmed
to identify cars it doesn't remember all
those pictures it has no memory as far
as the hundreds of pictures you process
through it all it has is this is the
pattern I use to identify cars as the
final output for that neural network we
looked at so when they talk about
limited memory this is what they're
talking about they're talking about I've
created this based on all these things
but I'm not going to remember any one
specifically theory of Mind systems
being able to understand human emotions
and how they affect decision-making to
adjust their behaviors according to
their human understanding this is
important because this is our page mark
this is how we know whether it is an
artificial intelligence or not is it
interacting with humans in a way that we
can understand uh without that
interaction is just an object uh so we
talk about theory of mind we really
understand how it interfaces that whole
if you're in web development user
experience would be the term I would put
in there so a theory of mind would be
user experience how is the whole UI
connected together and one of the final
things is as we get into artificial
intelligence is systems being aware of
themselves understanding their internal
States and predicting other people's
feelings and act appropriately so as
artificial intelligence continues to
progress uh we see ones are trying to
understand well what makes people happy
how would they increase our happiness uh
how would they keep themselves from
breaking down if something's broken
inside they have that self-awareness to
be able to fix it and just based on all
that information predicting which action
would work the best what would help
people uh if I know that you're having a
cup of coffee first thing in the morning
is what makes you happy as a robot I
might make you a cup of coffee every
morning at the same time uh to help your
life and help you grow that'd be the
self-awareness is being able to know all
those different things types of machine
learning and like I said on the last
slide this is very important this is
very important if you decide to go in
and get certified in machine learning or
know more about it these are the three
primary types of machine learning the
first one is supervised learning systems
are able to predict future outcome based
on past data requires both an input and
an output to be given to the model for
for it to be trained so in this case
we're looking at anything where you have
100 images of a bicycle and those 100
images you know are bicycle so it's
they're preset someone already looked at
all 100 images and said these are
pictures of bicycles and so the computer
learns from those and then it's given
another picture and maybe the next
picture is a bicycle and it says oh that
resembles all these other bicycles so
it's a bicycle and the next one's a car
and it says it's not a bicycle that
would be super vised learning CU we had
to train it we had to supervise it
unsupervised learning systems are able
to identify hidden patterns from the
input data provided by making the data
more readable and organized the patterns
similarities or anomalies become more
evident uh you'll heard the term cluster
how do you cluster things together some
of these things go together some of
these don't this is unsupervised where
can look at an image and start pulling
the different pieces of the image out
because they aren't the same the human
all the parts of the human are not the
same as a fuzzy tree behind them CU it's
slightly out of focus which is not the
same as the beach ball it's unsupervised
because we never told it what a beach
ball was we never told it what the human
was and we never told it that those were
trees all we told it was hey separate
this picture by things that don't match
and things that do match and come
together and finally there's
reinforcement learning systems are given
no training it learns on the basis of
the reward punishment it received for
performing its Last Action it helps
increase the efficiency of a tool
function or a program reinforced
learning or reinforcement learning is
kind of you give it a yes or no yes you
gave me the right response no you didn't
and then it looks at that and says oh
okay so based on this data coming in uh
what I gave you was a wrong response so
next time I'll give you a different one
comparing machine learning and deep
learning so remember that deep learning
is a subcategory of machine learning so
it's one of the many tools and so they
we're grouping a ton of machine learning
tools all together linear regression K
means clustering there's all kinds of
cool tools out there you can use in
machine learning enables machines to
take decisions to make decisions on
their own based on past data enables
machines to make decisions with the help
of artificial neural networks so it's
doing the same thing but we're using an
artificial neural network as opposed to
one of the more traditional machine
learning tools needs only a small amount
of training data this is very important
when you're talking about machine
learning
they're usually not talking about huge
amounts of data we're talking about
maybe your spreadsheet from your
business and your totals for the end of
the year when you're talking about
neural networks you usually need a large
amount of data to train the data so
there's a lot of training involved if
you have under 500 points of data that's
probably not going to go into machine
learning or maybe you have like the case
of one of the things 500 points of data
and 30 different fields it starts
getting really confusing there in
artificial intelligence or machine
learning and the Deep learning aspect
really shines when you get to that
larger data that's really
complex works well on a low-end systems
so a lot of the machine learning tools
out there you can run on your laptop
with no problem and do the calculations
there where with the machine learning
usually needs a higher-end system to
work it takes a lot more processing
power to build those neural networks and
to train them it goes through a lot of
data when we're talking about the
general machine learning tools most
features need to be identified in
advanced and manually coded so there's a
lot of human work on here the machine
learns the features from the data it is
provided so again it's like a magic box
you don't have to know what a tire is it
figures it out for you the problem is
divided into parts and solved
individually and then combined so
machine learning you usually have all
these different tools and use different
tools for different parts and the
problem is solved in an endtoend manner
so you only have one neural network or
two neural networks that is bringing the
data in and putting it out it's not
going through a lot of different
processes to get there and remember you
can put machine learning in deep
learning together so you don't always
have just the Deep learning solving the
problem you might have solving one piece
of the puzzle with regular machine
learning and most machine learning tools
out there they they take longer to test
and understand how they work and with
the Deep learning it's pretty quick once
you build that neural network you test
it and you know so we're dealing with
very crisp rules Limited
resources you have to really explain how
the decision was made when you use most
machine learning tools but when you use
the Deep learning tool inside the
machine learning tools the system takes
care of it based on its own logic and
reasoning and again it's like a magic
Black Box you really don't know how it
came up with the answer you just know it
came up with the right answer a glimpse
into the future so a quick glimpse into
the future artificial intelligence be
using it to detecting crimes before they
happen humanoid AI helpers which we
already have a lot of there'll be more
and more maybe it'll actually be
Androids that'd be cool to have an
Android that comes and gets stuff out of
my fridge for me machine learning
increasing efficiency in health care
that's really big in all the forms of
machine learning better marketing
techniques any of these things if we get
into the Sciences it's just off the
scale machine learning and artificial
intelligence go everywhere and then the
subcategory Deep learning increased
personalization so what's really nice
about the Deep learning is going to
start now catering to you that'll be one
of the things we see more and more of
and we'll have more of a hyper
intelligent personal assistant I'm
excited about
that in this lesson you are going to
understand the concept of text
mining by the end of this lesson you
will be able to explain text mining
execute text processing
task so let's go ahead and understand
text mining in detail let's first
understand what what text mining is text
mining is the technique of exploring
large amounts of unstructured Text data
and analyzing it in order to extract
patterns from the text Data it is aided
by software that can identify Concepts
patterns topics keywords and other
attributes in the data it utilizes
computational techniques to extract and
summarize the highquality information
from unstructured textual resources
let's understand the flow of text mind
there are five techniques used in text
mining system information extraction or
text
pre-processing this is used to examine
the unstructured text by searching out
the important words and finding the
relationships between them
categorization or text transformation
attribute generation categorization
technique labels the text document under
one or more categories classification of
Text data is done based on input put
output examples with
categorization clustering or attribute
selection clustering method is used to
group text documents that have similar
content clusters are the partitions and
each cluster will have a number of
documents with similar content
clustering makes sure that no document
will be omitted from the search and it
derives all the documents that have
similar content visualization technique
the process of finding relevant
information is simplified by
visualization technique this technique
uses text Flags to represent a group of
documents or a single document and
compactness is indicated using colors
visualization technique helps to display
textual information in a more attractive
way summarization or interpretation or
evaluation summarization technique will
help to reduce the length of the
document and summarize the details of
the documents it makes the document easy
to read for users and understand the
content at the moment let's understand
the significance of text
mining document clustering document
clustering is an important part of text
mining it has many applications in
Knowledge Management and information
retrieval clustering makes it easy to
group similar documents into meaningful
groups such as in newspapers where
sections are often grouped as business
Sports politics and so on pattern
identification text mining is the
process of automatically searching large
amount of text for text patterns and
recognition of features features such as
telephone numbers and email addresses
can be extracted using pattern matches
product insights text mining helps to
extract large amounts of text for
example customer reviews about the
products mining consumer reviews can
reveal insights like most loved feature
most hated feature improve improvements
required and reviews of competitor
products security monitoring text mining
helps in monitoring and extracting
information from news articles and
reports for national security purposes
text mining makes sure to use all of
your available information it is a more
effective and productive knowledge
discovery that allows you to make better
informed decisions automate information
intensive processes gather business
critical insights and mitigate operation
risk let's look at the applications of
text
mining speech recognition speech
recognition is the recognition and
translation of spoken language into text
and vice versa speech often provides
valuable information about the topics
subjects and concepts of multimedia
content information extraction from
speech is less complicated yet more
accurate and precise than multimedia
content this fact motivates content
based speech analysis for multimedia
Data Mining and retrieval where audio
and speech processing is a key enabling
technology spam filtering spam detection
is an important method in which textual
information contained in an email is
extracted and used for
discrimination text mining is useful in
automatic detection of spam emails based
on the filtering content using text
mining an email service provider such as
Gmail or Yahoo mail checks the content
of an email and if some malicious text
is found in the mail then that email is
marked as spam and sent to the spam
folder sentiment analysis it is done in
order to determine if a given sentence
expresses positive neutral or negative
sentiments sentiment analysis is one of
the most popular applications of text
analytics the primary aspect of
sentiment analysis includes data
analysis of the body of the text for
understanding the opinion expressed by
it and other key factors comprising
modality and mood usually the process of
sentiment analysis works best on text
that has a subjective context than on
that with only in objective context
e-commerce
personalization text mining is used to
suggest products that fit into a user's
profile text mining is increasingly
being used by e-commerce re retailers to
learn more about the consumers as it is
the process of analyzing textual
information in order to identify
patterns and gain insights e-commerce
retailers can Target specific
individuals or segments with
personalized offers and a discounts to
boost sales and increase Customer
Loyalty by identifying customer purchase
patterns and opinions on particular
products let's look at natural language
toolkit library in
detail
natural language toolkit is a set of
open-source python models that are used
to apply statistical natural language
processing on human language data let's
see how you can do environment setup of
nltk go to Windows start and launch
python interpreter from Anaconda prompt
and enter the following commands enter
command python to check the version of
python installed on your system enter
import nltk to link you to the nltk
library available to download then enter
nltk doownload function that will open
the nltk download window check the
download directory select all packages
and click on download this will download
nltk onto your python once you have
downloaded the nltk you must check the
working and functionality of it in order
to test the setup enter the following
command in Python idle
from nltk Doc Corpus import Brown brown.
word parenthesis
parenthesis the brown is an nltk Corpus
that shows the systematic difference
between different genres available words
function will give you the list
available words in the genre the given
output shows that we have successfully
tested the nltk installed on
python let's Now understand how you can
read a specific module from nltk corpora
if you want to import an entire module
from nltk corpora use asterisk symbol
with that module name import command
enter the command from nltk do book
import asterisk it will load all the
items available in NLT K's book module
now in order to explore Brown Corpus
enter the command nltk do Corpus import
Brown
this will import Brown Corpus on the
python enter brown. categories function
to load the different genres available
select a genre and assign that genre to
a variable using the following syntax
variable name is equal to brown. wordss
categories is equal to genre name now in
order to see the available words inside
the selected genre just enter the
defined variable name as a command
let's understand text extraction and
pre-processing in
detail so let's first understand the
concept of
tokenization tokenization is the process
of removing sensitive data and placing
unique symbols of identification in that
place in order to retain all the
essential information concerned with the
data by its security it is a process of
breaking running streams of text into
words and sentences it works by
segregating words using punctuation and
spaces text extraction and
pre-processing
engrams now let's look at what engram is
and how it is helpful in text mining
engram is the simplest model that
assigns these probabilities to sequences
of words or sentences engrams are
combinations of adjacent words or
letters of length and in the source text
so engram is very helpful in text mining
when it is required to extract patterns
from the text as in the given example
this is a sentence all of these words
are considered individual words and thus
represent unigrams a two gr or Byram is
a two-word sequence of words like this
is is a or a sentence and a thre or
trigram is a three-word sequence of
words like this is a or is a
sentence let's Now understand what stop
words are and how you can remove
them stop words are natural language
words that have negligable meanings such
as a n and or the and other similar
words these words also will take up
space in the database or increase the
processing time so it is better to
remove such words by storing a list of
stop words you can find the list of stop
words in the nltk data directory that is
stored in 16 different languages use the
following command to list the stop words
of English language defined in nltk
Corpus importing nltk will import the
nltk Corpus for that instance enter from
nltk Doc Corpus import stopwords will
import Stop wordss from nltk Corpus Now
set the language as English so use set
function as set under braces stop
wordswords set genre as English stop
words are filtered out before processing
of natural language data as they don't
reveal much information so as you can
see in the given example before
filtering the sentence the tokenization
of stop word is processed in order to
remove these stop words and the
filtering is applied in order to filter
the sentence based on some
criteria text extraction and
pre-processing
stemming stemming is used to reduce a
word to stem or base word by removing
suffixes such as helps helping helped
and helper to the root word help the
stemming process or algorithm is
generally called a stemmer there are
various stemming algorithms such as
Porter stemmer Lancaster stemmer
snowball stemmer Etc use any of the
stemmers defined under nltk stem Corpus
in order to perform stemming as shown in
the example here we have used port
stemmer When You observe the output you
will see that all of the words given
have been reduced to their root word or
stem text extraction and pre-processing
lemmatization lemmatization is the
method of grouping the various inflected
types of a word in order that they can
be analyzed as one item it uses
vocabulary list or a morphological
analysis to get the root word it uses
word net database that has English words
linked together by their semantic
relationship as you can observe the
given example the different words have
been extracted to their relevant
morphological word using
lemmatization text extraction and
preprocessing POS
tagging let's now look at different part
of speech tags available in the national
language toolkit Library a POS tag is a
special label assigned to each token or
word in a Text corpus to indicate the
part of speech and often also other
grammatical categories such as tense
number either plural or singular case
Etc POS tags are used in text analysis
tools and algorithms and also in Corpus
searches so look at the given example
here Alice wrote a program is the source
text given the POS tags given our Alice
is a noun wrote is a verb a is an
article and program is an adjective
look at the given example to understand
how POS tags are defined so the given
sentence or paragraph contains different
words that represent different parts of
speech we will first use tokenization
and removal of stop words and then
allocate the different POS tags these
are shown with different words in the
given sentence POS tags are useful for
lemmatization in building named entity
recognition and extracting relationships
between words
text extraction and pre-processing named
entity recognition now let's understand
what named entity recognition is all
about Neer seeks to extract a real world
entity from the text and sorts it into
predefined categories such as names of
people organizations locations Etc many
real world questions can be answered
with the help of name entity recognition
where specified products mentioned in
complaints or reviews
does the Tweet contain the name of a
person does the Tweet contain the
person's address as you can see in the
given example Google America Larry Page
Etc are the names of a person place or
an organization so these are considered
named entities and have different tags
such as person organization gpe or
geopolitical entity
Etc NLP process
workflow now you have an understanding
of all nltk tools so now let's
understand the natural language
processing workflow step one
tokenization it splits text into pieces
tokens or words and removes punctuation
step two stop word removal it removes
commonly used words such as the is R Etc
which are not relevant to the analysis
step three stemming and litiz it reduces
words to base for in order to be
analyzed as a single item step four POS
tagging it tags words to be part of
speech such as noun verb adjective Etc
based on the definition and context step
five information retrieval it extracts
relevant information from the
source1 brown Corpus problem statement
the Brown University standard Corpus of
present-day American English also known
popularly as Brown Corpus was compiled
in the 1960s as a general Corpus in the
field of Corpus Linguistics it contains
500 samples of English language text
totaling roughly 1 million words
compiled from Works published in the
United States in
1961 we will be working on one of the
subset data set and perform text
processing tasks let us import the nltk
library and read the
ca10 Corpus import
nltk we will have to make sure that
there are no slashes in between hence we
will use the replace function within
pandas for the
same let's have a look at the data once
tokenization after performing sentence
tokenization on the data we
obtain similarly after applying sentence
tokenizer the resulting output shows all
individual words
tokens
stop word removal let's import the stop
word library from nltk Doc Corpus import
stopwords we also need to ensure that
the text is in the same case nltk has
its own list of stop wordss we can check
the list of stop wordss using stopwords
do wordss and English inside the
parenthesis map the lowercase string
with our list of word
tokens let's remove the stop words using
the English stop wordss list in
nltk we will be using set checking as it
is faster in Python than a
list by removing all stop wordss from
the text we
obtain often we want to remove the
punctuations from the documents too
since python comes with batteries
included we have string. punctuation
from string import
punctuation combining a punctuation with
the stop wordss from
nltk
removing stop words with
punctuation steming and
lemmatization we will be using stemming
and lemmatization to reduce words to
their root form for example walks
walking walked will be reduced to their
root word walk importing Porter stemmer
as the stemming library from nltk do
stem import Porter
stemmer printing the stem
words
import the word net litier from nltk do
stem printing the root
words
we also need to evaluate the POS tags
for each
token create a new word list and store
the list of word tokens against each of
the sentence tokens in data 2 for I and
tokenized also we will check if there
were any stop words in the recently
created word
list we will now tag the word tokens
accordingly using the POS tags and and
print the tagged
output for our final text processing
task we will be applying named entity
recognition to classify named entities
in text into predefined categories such
as the names of persons organizations
locations expressions of times
quantities monetary values percentages
Etc
now press the tagged sentences under the
chunk parser if we set the parameter
binary equals true then named entities
are just tagged as NE otherwise the
classifier adds category labels such as
person organization and
gpe create a a function named as extract
entity names along with an empty list
named as entity
names we will now extract named entities
from a nltk chunked expression and store
them in the empty created
above
again we will set the entity names list
as an empty list and we'll extract The
Entity names by iterating over each tree
in chunked
sentences
great we have seen how to explore and
examine the Corpus using text processing
techniques let's quickly recap the steps
we've covered so far One Import the nltk
library two perform tokenization three
perform stemming and lemmatization four
remove stop words five perform named
entity
recognition structuring sentences
syntax let's first understand what
syntax is syntax is the grammatical
structure of sentences in the given
example this can be interpreted as
syntax and it is similar to the ones you
use while writing codes knowing a
language includes the power to construct
phrases and sentences out of morphemes
and words the part of the grammar that
represents a speaker's knowledge of
these structures and their formation is
called syntax phrase structure rules are
rules that determine what goes into a
phrase phase that is constituents of a
phrase and how the constituents are
ordered constituent is a word or group
of words that operate as a unit and can
be used to frame larger grammatical
units the given diagram represents that
a noun phrase is determined when a noun
is combined with a determiner and the
determiner can be optional a sentence is
determined when a noun phrase is
combined with a verb phrase a verb
phrase is determined when a verb is
combined optionally with the noun phrase
phrase and prepositional phrase and a
prepositional phrase is determined when
a preposition is combined with a noun
phrase a tree is a representation of
syntactics structure of formulation of
sentences or strings consider the given
sentence the factory employs 12.8% of
Bradford County what can be the Syntax
for pairing the statement let's
understand this a tree is produced that
might help you understand that the
subject of the sentence is the factory
the predicate is employes and the target
is
12.8% which in turn is modified by
Bradford County syntax parses are often
a first step toward deep information
extraction or semantic understanding of
text rendering syntax
trees download the corresponding exe
file to install the ghost script
rendering engine based on your system
configuration in order to render syntax
trees in your notebook let's understand
how you can set up the environment
variable once you have downloaded and
installed the file go to the folder
where it is installed and copy the path
of the file now go to system properties
and under Advanced properties you will
find the environment variable button
click on that to open the popup box tab
of the environment now open the bin
folder and add the path to the bin
folder in your environment
variables now you will have to modify
the path of the environment variable use
the given code to test the working of
syntax tree after the setup is
successfully
installed structuring sentences chunking
and chunk
parsing the process of extraction of
phrases from unstructured text is called
chunking instead of using just simple
tokens which may not represent the
actual meaning of the the text it is
advisable to use phrases such as Indian
team as a single word instead of Indian
and team as separate words the chunking
segmentation refers to identifying
tokens and labeling refers to
identifying the correct tag these chunks
correspond to mixed patterns in some way
to extract patterns from chunks we need
chunk parsing the chunk parsing segment
refers to identifying strings of tokens
and labeling refers to identifying the
correct chunk type let's look at the
given example you can see here that
yellow is an adjective dog is a noun and
the' is the determiner which are chunked
together into a noun phrase similarly
chunk parsing is used to extract
patterns and to process such patterns
from multiple chunks while using
different
parsers let's take an example and try to
understand how chunking is performed in
Python let's consider the sentence the
little mouse ate the fresh cheese
assigned to a variable named scent using
the word tokenize function under nltk
corpora you can find out the different
tags associated with the sentence
provided so as you can see in the output
different tags have been allocated
against each of the words from the given
sentence using
chunking NP chunk and
parser you will now create grammar from
a noun phrase and will mention the tags
you want in your chunk phrase within the
function here you have created a regular
expression matching the string the given
regular expression indicates optional
determiner followed by optional number
of adjective followed by a noun you will
now have to parse the chunk therefore
you will create a chunk parser and pass
your noun phrase string to it the parser
is now ready you will use the parse
parenthesis parenthesis within your
chunk parser to parse your your sentence
the sentence provided is the little
mouse at the fresh cheese this sentence
has been parsed and the tokens that
match the regular expressions are
chunked together into noun phrases
NP create a verb phrase chunk using
regular Expressions the regular
expression has been defined as optional
personal pronoun followed by zero or
more verbs with any of its type followed
by any type of adverb you'll now create
another chunk parser and pass the verb
phrase string to it create another
sentence and tokenize it add POS tags to
it so the new sentence is she is walking
quickly to the mall and the POS tag has
been allocated from nltk corpora now use
the new verb phrase parser to parse the
tokens and run the results you can look
at the given tree diagram which shows a
verb parser where a pronoun followed by
two verbs and an adverb are chunk
together into a verb
parse structuring sentences
chinking chinking is the process of
removing a sequence of tokens from a
chunk how does chunking work the whole
chunk is removed when the sequence of
tokens spans an entire chunk if the
sequence is at the start or the end of
the chunk the tokens are removed from
the start and end and a smaller chunk is
retained if the sequence of tokens
appears in the middle of the chunk these
tokens are removed leaving two chunks
where there was only one before consider
you create a chinking grammar string
containing three things chunk name the
regular expression sequence of a chunk
the regular expression sequence of your
here in the given code we have the
chunk regular expression as optional
personal pronoun followed by zero or
more occurrences of any type of the verb
type followed by zero or more
occurrences es of any of the adverb
types the regular expression says
that it needs to check for the adverb in
the extracted chunk and remove it from
the chunk inside the chinking block with
open curly braces and closing curly
braces you have created one or more
adverbs you will now create a parser
from nltk do
regexp parser and pass the grammar
to it now use the new parser to
parse the tokens sent three and run the
results as you can see the parse tree is
generated while comparing the syntax
tree of the parser with that of
the original chunk you can see that the
token is quickly adverb chin out of the
chunk let's understand how to use
context free
grammar a context free grammar is a four
Tuple sum ntrs where sum is an alphabet
and each character in sum is is called a
terminal NT is a set and each element in
NT is called a non-terminal r the set of
rules is a subset of NT times the set of
sum u n t s the start symbol is one of
the symbols in NT a context free grammar
generates a language L capturing
constituency and ordering in CFG the
start symbol is used to derive the
string you can derive the string by
repeatedly replacing a non-terminal on
the right hand side of the production
until all non-terminals have been
replaced by terminal symbols let's
understand the representation of context
free grammar through an example in
context free grammar a sentence can be
represented as a noun phrase followed by
a verb phrase noun phrase can be a
determiner nominal a nominal can be a
noun VP represents the verb phrase a can
be called a determiner flight can be
called a noun consider the string below
where you have certain rules when you
look at the given context free grammar a
sentence should have a noun phrase
followed by a verb phrase a verb phrase
is a verb followed by a noun a verb can
either be Saul or met noun phrases can
either be John or Jim and a noun can
either be a dog or a cat check the
possible list of sentences that can be
generated using the rules use the join
function to create the Poss list of
sentences you can check the different
rules of grammar for sentence formation
using the production function it will
show you the different tags used and the
defined context free grammar for the
given
sentence demo two structuring sentences
problem statement a company wants to
perform text analysis for one of its
data sets you are provided with this
data set named tweets. CSV which has
tweets of six US Airlines along with
their sentiments positive negative and
neutral the tweets are present in the
text column and sentiments in Airline
sentiment column we will be retrieving
all tags starting with at the rate in
the data set and save the output in a
file called references. txt let us first
import the panda library and read the
tweets data
set
extract the features text and Airline
sentiment we will iterate through the
data set using reg X find the relevant
tweets
now we will import the itertools module
it returns efficient
iterators
the result is stored in a file named
references.
txt
let's extract all noun phrases and save
them in a file named noun phrases for
left Carro Airline sentiment right Carro
review.
txt
here left carrot Airline uncore
sentiment right carrot has three
different values positive negative and
neutral so three files will be
created
now we will iterate all the leaf nodes
and assign them to noun phrases
variable
this means that the functions in iter
tools operate on iterators to produce
more complex
iterators using the map function we will
get all the noun phrases from the
text putting it into
list
creating a file name in the name of
review.
txt
great we have now seen how to explore
and examine the Corpus using text
processing techniques if you're looking
for a course that covers everything from
the fundamentals to Advanced Techniques
then accelerate your career in Ai and
machine learning with a comprehensive
post-graduate program in Ai and machine
learning boost your career with this Ai
and ml course delivered in collaboration
with the perdu university and IBM learn
in demand skills such as machine
learning deep learning NLP computer
vision reinforcement learning generative
AI prompt engineering chat GPT and many
more you'll receive a prestigious
certificate and ask me anything sessions
by IBM with five capstones in different
domains using real data sets you will
gain practical experience master classes
by perd faculty and IBM experts ensure
top-notch education simply learns job
assist help you get noticed by Leading
companies this program covers statistics
python supervised and unsupervised
learning NLP neural networks computer
vision G scas tensorflow and many more
suchar skills admission to this
post-graduate program in Ai and machine
learning requires a bachelor's degree
with an average of 50% or higher marks
along with the basic understanding of
programming Concepts and meth
mathematics and candidates with two plus
years of work experience are preferred
to enroll in this school so enroll now
and unlock exciting Ai and machine
learning opportunities the link is
mentioned in the description box below
the term generative AI has emersed
seemingly out of nowhere in recent
months with a notable search in interest
according to Google Trends even within
the past year the spike in curiosity can
be attributed to the introduction of
generative model such as d 2 B and
chgb however what does generative AI
entail as a part of our introductory
series on generative AI this video will
provide a comprehensive overview of a
subject starting from the basics the
explanation Will C to all levels of
familiarity ensuring that viewers gain a
better understanding of how this
technology operates and its growing
integration to our daily lives
generative AI is after all a tool that
is based on artificial intelligence a
professional who elit seeds to switch
careers with AI by learning from the
experts then try giving a short simply L
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning from perd University in
collaboration with IBM the link in the
description box should navigate to the
homepage where you can find a complete
overview of the program being offered
take action upskill and get ahead what
is generative AI generative AI is a form
of artificial intelligence possesses the
capability of to generate a wide range
of Conta including text visual audio and
synthetic data the recent excitement
surrounding generative AI stems from the
userfriendly interfaces that allow us
users to effortlessly create high
quality text graphics and video within a
seconds now moving forward let's see how
does generative AI Works generative AI
begin a prompt which can take form of
text image video design audio musical
notes or any input that AI system can
process various AI algorithm that
generate new content in response to the
given prompt this content can range from
essay and problem solution to realistic
created using images or audio of a
person in the early stages of generative
AI utilizing the technology involved
submitting data through an API or a
complex process developers need to
acquaints with a specialized tool and
writing application using programming
language like python some of the recent
and fully operational generative AIS are
Google Bart D open AI chgb Microsoft
Bing and many more so now let's discuss
chat GP Dal and B which are the most
popular generative AI interfaces so
first is DAL 2 which was developed using
open as GPT implementation in 2021
exemplify a multimodel AI application it
has been trained on a v data set of
images and their corresponding textual
description Dal is capable of
establishing connection between various
media forms such as Vision text audio it
specifically links the meaning of words
to visual elements open a introduced an
enhanced version called d 2 in 2022
which empowers user to generate imagery
in multiple Styles based on their
prompts and the next one is chat gbt in
November 2022 chat GPT and AI powered
chatboard built on open AI GPD 3.5
implementation gained immense popularity
worldwide open AI enable user to
interact with and fine tune the chatbox
text response through a chat interface
with interactive feedback unlike earlier
version of GPT that was solely
accessible via an API charges GPT
brought a more interactive experience on
March 14 2023 open a released GPT 4 chat
GPT integrated the conversational
history with a user making a genuine
dialogue Microsoft impressed by the
success of new chgb interface announced
a substantial investment in open Ai and
integrated a version of GPT into its
Bing search engine and the next one is
Bard Google bard Google was also an
earlier Fortuner in advancing
Transformer AI technique
for language processing protein analysis
and other content types it made some of
these model open source for researchers
but were not made available through a
public interface in response to
Microsoft integration of GPT into
beinging Google hardly launched a public
facing chat B name Google b b debut was
met by an error when the language model
incorrectly claimed that the web
telescope was the first to discover a
planet in a foreign solar system as a
consequences Google stock price suffered
a significant decline
meanwhile Microsoft implementation of
chat GPT and GPT power system also face
criticism for producing inaccurate
result and displaying ER actic behavior
in their early iritation so moving
forward let's see what are the use cases
of generative AI generative AI has broad
applicability and can be employed across
a wide range of use cases to generate
diverse form of content recent
advancement like GPT have made this
technology more accessible and
customizable for various applications
some notable use cases for generative AI
are as follows chatbot implementation
generative AI can be utilized to develop
chatbots for customer service and
Technical Support enhancing interaction
with users and providing efficient
assistance the second one is language
dubbing enhancement in the real in the
realm of movies and educational
accountant generative AI can contribute
to improving dubbing in different
languages ensuring accurate and high
quality translation and the third one is
content writing generative AI can assist
in writing email responses dating
profiles resumes and term papers
offering valuable support and generating
customized content tailor to specific
requirement and the fourth one is Art
generation leveraging generative AI
artists can create photo realistic
artwork in various Styles enabling the
exploration of new artistic expression
and enhancing creativity the fifth one
is product demonstration videos
generative AI can hun to enhance protect
demonstration video making them more
engaging visually appealing and
effective in showcasing product features
and benefits so generative AI
versatility allow it to employ it in
many other application making it a
valuable tool for Content creation and
enhancing user experience across diverse
domains so after seeing use case of
generative AI let's see what are the
benefits of generative AI so generative
AI offers extensive application across
various business domains simplifying the
interpretation and comprehension of
existing content while also enabling the
automated creation of a new content
content developers are actively
exploring ways to leverage generative AI
in order to enhance the optimize
existing workflows and even to reshave
workflows entirely to harness the
potential of Technology fully
implementing generative AI can bring
numerous benefits including automated
content creation generative AI can
automate the manual process of writing
content saving time and effort by
generating text or other form of content
the next one is efficient email response
responding to emails can be made more
efficient with generative AI reducing
the effort required and improving
response time and the third one is
enhanced technical support generative AI
can improve responses to specific
technical queries providing accurate and
helpful information to users or
customers and the fourth one is
realistic person Generation by
leveraging generative AI it becomes
possible to create realistic
representation of people enabling
applications like virtual characters or
Avatar and the fifth one is coherent
information summarization generative AI
can summarize complex information into a
coherent narrative distilling key points
and making it easier to understand and
communicate complex concept the
implementation of generative AI offers a
range of potential benefits steamingly
processed and enhancing content Creation
in various areas of business operation
so after seeing advantages of generative
AI let's move forward and see what are
the limitations of generative AI early
implementation of generative AI serve as
Vivid examples highlighting the numerous
limitation associated with this
technology several challenges arise from
the specific approaches employed to
implement various use gifts for instance
while a summary of a complex topic May
more reader friendly than explanation
incorporating multiple supporting
sources the ease of readability comes at
the expense of transparent identifying
the information sources so the first one
is when implementing or utilizing a
generative a application if ation it is
important to consider the following
limitation I repeat the first one is
lack of source identification generative
AI does not always provide clear
identification of content Source making
it difficult to trace and verify origin
of the information the second one is
assessment of bias assessing the bias of
original sources used generative AI can
be challenging as it may be difficult to
determine the underlying perspective or
agendas of the data utilized in the
training process the third one is
difficulty in identifying inaccurate
information generative AI can generate
realistic content making identifying
inaccuracy or falsehoods within the
generated output harder and the fourth
one is adaptability to a new
circumstances understanding how to
fine-tune generative AI for a new
circumstances or specific context can be
complex requiring careful consideration
and expertise to achieve desired result
and the fifth one is glossing over bi
Prejudice and hatred generative AI
results May amplify or preate biases
prejudices or hateful content present in
the training data requiring Vigilant
scrutiny to prevent such issues so
awareness of these limitation is crucial
when the implementing of utilizing
generative AI as it helps users and
developers critically evaluate and
mitigate potential risk and challenges
associated with the technology so future
of generative AI furthermore advances in
AI development platforms will contribute
to the accelerated progress of research
and development in the realm of
generative AI the development will
Encompass various domains such as text
images videos 3D contact drugs Supply
chains logistic and business processes
while the current loan tools are
impressive the true transformative
impact generative AI will realize while
these capabilities are seemingly
integrated into the existing tools with
regular use hello everyone and welcome
to the video on large language models
large language models are basically very
very Advanced artificial intelligence
systems that can process and generate
massive amounts of text Data they are
designed to learn from and understand
natural human language and can be used
to perform a wide range of language
related tasks such as translation speech
recognition and automatic summary
generation one of the key advantages of
large language models is their ability
to learn from vast amounts of data which
allows them to generate highly accurate
and realistic responses to complex
natural language prompts additionally
they can be trained on multiple langu
simultaneously which means they can be
used to perform language translation
between different pairs of languages
making them an invaluable tool for
businesses and organizations that work
with people from diverse cultural
backgrounds not just language related
task but llms can also have the
potential to revolutionize Fields such
as research science and Healthcare by
allowing researchers to quickly analyze
and process vast amounts of complex text
Data they can accelerate progress in
areas such as drug Discovery Healthcare
Diagnostics and AI development that
being said large language models also
present some challenges for instance
they require a significant amount of
comput sources which can be
prohibitively expensive for some
organizations additionally because they
are trained on huge amounts of data they
may inadvertently reinforce biased or
discriminate KN patterns in language use
which is something that researchers and
Engineers are continuously working to
address overall large language models
are an exciting and rapidly developing
field with tremendous potential to
transform the way we live work and
communicate so if you want to embark on
a journey of AI and ml then try giving a
sh to our postgraduate program in Ai and
ml that is in partnership with IBM this
artificial intelligence course covers
the latest tools and Technologies from
the AI ecosystem and features master
classes by celtech faculty and IBM
experts hecaton and ask me anything
sessions this program showcases celtech
ctm excellence and IBM's industry
progress the artificial intelligence
course covers key Concepts like stat ICS
data science with python machine
learning deep learning NLP and
reinforcement learning through an
Interactive Learning model with live
sessions enroll now and UNL exciting AI
anml opportunities the link is mentioned
in the description box below and with
that having said hey everyone welcome to
Simply lears YouTube channel but before
we dive into that don't forget to like
subscribe and share in this video we
will cover topics like what are large
language models after that we'll look at
what large language models used for four
and after that we'll cover how are large
language models trained after this we'll
look at how do large language models
work and at the last we'll see some
applications of large language models so
without any further Ado let's get
started so we'll start with what are the
large language models large language
models such as gpt3 generative
pre-trained Transformer 3 Advanced
artificial intelligence systems designed
to understand and generate humanik Tech
text these models are built using deep
learning techniques and have been
trained on vast amounts of text Data
from the internet these models use self
attention mechanisms to analyze the
relationships between words or tokens in
a text enabling them to capture
contextual information and generate Cent
responses these models use self
attention mechanisms to analyze the
relationship between different words or
tokens in a text enabling them to
capture contextual information and
generate coent responses these models
have significant implications for a wide
range of applications including virtual
assistants chat boards content
generation language translation and
aiding in research and decision making
processes their ability to generate
cerent and contextually appropriate text
has led to advancement in natural
language understanding and human
computer interaction now we'll see what
are language models used for so large
language models are utilized in
scenarios where there is limited or no
domain specific data available for
training these scenarios include both
few short and zero short learning
approaches which rely on the model's
strong inductive bias and its capability
to derive meaningful representations
from a small amount of data or even no
data at all now we'll see how are large
language models trained large language
models typically undergo pre-training on
a broad all and compassing data set that
shares statistical similarities with the
data set specific to the Target task the
objective of pre-training is to enable
the model to acquire high level features
that can later be applied during the
fine-tuning phase for specific task and
the training process of a large language
model involves several steps the first
is text pre-processing the textual data
is transformed into a numerical
representation that can be effectively
processed by the model this conversion
may involve techniques like tokenization
encoding and creating input sequences
the next we have we have is random
parameter initialization the model's
parameters are initialized randomly
before the training process begins the
next is inputting numerical data the
numerical representation of Text data is
fed into the model for processing the
models architecture typically based on
Transformers allows it to capture the
contextual relationships between the
words and tokens in the text and the
next is loss function calculation a loss
function is employed to measure the
discrepancy between the model's
predictions and the actual next word or
token in a sentence the model aims to
minimize this loss during training and
the next is parameter optimization the
model's parameters are adjusted through
optimization techniques such as gradient
descent to reduce the loss this involves
calculating gradients and updating the
parameters accordingly gradually
improving the model's performance and
the next is iterative training the
training process is repeated over
multiple iterations or repo until the
models of outputs achieve a satisfactory
level of accuracy on the given task or
data set by following this training
process large language models learn to
capture linguistic patterns understand
context and generate coherent responses
enabling them to excel at a wide range
of language related task and now we'll
see how do large language models work so
large language models leverage deep
neural networks to generate outputs
based on patterns learned from the
training data typically a large language
model adopts a Transformer architecture
which enables the model to identify
relationships between words in a
sentence irrespective of the position in
the sequence in contrast to recent
neural networks that is RNN that rely on
recurence to capture token relationships
Transformer neural networks employ self
attention as their primary mechanism
self attention calculates attention
scores that determines the importance of
each token with respect to other tokens
in the text sequence facil itting the
modeling of intricate relationships
within the data now we'll see
applications of large language models
large language models have wide range of
applications across various domains and
here are some notable applications the
first one is natural language processing
large language models are used to
improve natural language understanding
task such as sentiment analysis named
entity recognition text classification
and language modeling the next is chat
boards and virtual assistants large
language models power conversational
agents chat boards and virtual
assistants providing more interactive
and humanlike interactions with users
and the next is machine translation
large language models have been used for
automatic language translation enabling
the translation of text between
different languages with improved
accuracy and the next we have is
sentiment analysis large language models
can analyze and classify a sentiment or
emotion expressed in a piece of text
which is valuable for market research
brand monitoring and social media
analysis and the next we have is content
recommendation these models can be
employed to provide personalized content
recommendations enhancing user
experience and engagement on platforms
such as news websites or streaming
services these applications highlight
the versatility and potential impact of
large language models in various domains
improving language understanding
Automation and interaction between
humans and computers everyone knows the
algorithm is a step-by-step process to
approach a particular problem there are
numerous examples of algorithm from
figuring out sets of number to finding
Roots through maps to showing data on a
screen let's understand this by using an
example every algorithm is built on
inputs and outputs Google search
algorithm is no different the input is
the search field and the output is the
page of result that appears when you
enter a particular phrase or keyword
also known as sep or search engine
result page Google has a search
algorithm so it can sort results from
various websit and provides the users
the best result when you start a search
you will see the search box you will
attempt to guess what you are looking
for in order to better understand what
the user is looking for the algorithm is
trying to gather as many as suggestions
from them as possible the results from
the search field that best matches the
query will be ranked the choose F
website will Rank and in what position
using more than 200 ranking variables
now let's take an example of coding
program and see how the algorithm
works here we will use a case of
computer program wherein we want to
print the multiplication table of any
number let's take two the algorithm
start here and then it assign a value to
a variable the variable I is having an
initial value of one the system will
read the number the number in case is
two now the system has a condition a
condition can now either be true or
false if the value of I reaches 11 then
the loop will end otherwise value of I
will multiply by the number the initial
value of I is 1 so for the first time
the system output will be two now value
of I will be increased by one according
to the loop condition the system will
then move back and check for the
condition again the new value of I is 2
which is still less than 11 the system
will again print 2 into I which is 2
into 2 on the screen the new output
result will be four the system will keep
following the same procedure repeatedly
until the value of I becomes 11 once the
value of I becomes 11 then only the
algorithm will terminate after
discussing how an algorithm work let's
move forward and see some popular
machine learning algorithms
some popular machine learning algorithms
are first one is linear regression
algorithm second one is logistic
regression algorithm and the third one
is decision tree and the fourth one is
support Vector machine algorithm
svm and the fifth one is KNN K nearest
neighbor algorithm and the sixth one is
K means clustering
algorithms and the seventh one is random
Forest algorithms and the last but not
the least algorithm is aiy algorithms
let's go through them in detail one by
one linear regression is one of the most
famous and straightforward machine
learning algorithms utilized for
predictive analysis linear regression
show the linear connection between the
dependent and the independent factors
the equation of line is y = to mx+b here
y stand for the response variable or a
dependent variable whereas X is for the
Predator variable or an independent
variable it attempts best to fit line
between the dependent and independent
variables and this best fit line is
known as line of regression or
regression
line let's take a real application
example in predicting consumer Behavior
businesses use linear regression to
forecast things like how much a client
is likely to spend things like targeted
marketing and product development May
benefit from this Walmart for instant
use linear regression to forecast which
good would be in high demand across the
N moving forward let's see types of
linear
regression there are two types of linear
regression algorithm the first one is
simple linear regression and the second
one is multiple linear
regression in simple linear regression
if an independent variable is utilized
to forecast the worth of a mathematical
dependent variable then at that point
such a linear regression algorithm is
called Simple linear regression the
equation of line will be y = a0 + A1 X
and the second one is multiple linear
regression if the dependent variables
declines on the Y and the independent
variable on the X then such a
relationship is known as negative linear
relationship the line of equation will
be minus of a 0 + A1 X moving forward
let's see logistic linear
regression logistic regression is the
supervised machine learning algorithm
utilized to anticipate all the
categorical factors or discrete values
it could be very well used for the
grouping issues in machine learning and
the result of the logistic regression
can be either yes or no zero or one men
or women and so on it gives the values
which lies between zero and one for
example a credit card business is
interested in knowing whether the
transaction amount and the credit scope
have an impact on the probability that a
particular transaction would be
fraudulent the business can use logistic
regression to determine how these two
Predator values can relate the
probability that a transaction is
fraudin the response variable in the
model has two possible outcomes first
one is the transaction is fraud and the
second one is the transaction is not
fraudulent in logistic regression rather
than fitting a regression line we fit an
S form logistic capability which
predicts two greatest value zero or one
the logistic regression equation can be
calculated from linear regression
equation the steps to get logistic
regression equations are the equation of
a straight line can be return as y = b 0
+ B1 X1 + b2x 2 till B and xn in
logistic regression y can be between 0
and 1 only so for that let's divide the
above equation by 1 - y then the
equation will be y upon 1 - y that is 0
for y 0 and Infinity for y = 1 but range
between minus infinity to plus infinity
then we have to take the logarithm of
equation and now it will become log of Y
upon 1 - y = b 0 plus B1 X1 plus B2 X2
so on till B and xn let's move forward
and see types of logistic
regression there are three types of
logistic regression that can be
classified first one is binomial in
binomial logistic regression there can
be only two possible types of dependent
variables like yes or no pass or fa men
woman and many more and the second one
is multinomial in multinomial logistic
regression there can be three or more
possible unordered ways of dependent
variable such as horse cow and sheep and
the last one is ordinal in ordinal
logistic regression there can be three
or more possible ordered ways of
dependent variable such as small medium
or large moving forward let's see
decision trees in
detail a decision tree is a tree
structured classifier that could be used
for classification and regression a
decision tree is a tree in which each
non-leaf node is assigned to an
attribute additionally each are contain
one of the available values for its
parent node which is associated with
each Leaf node that is the node from
where the arc is directed let's see some
decision tree
terminology first one is root that
contains the entire data set the next
one is node attach for the data of a
certain attribute and the third one is
branch which connect the node to
internal node or the internal node to
Leaf node and the fourth one is leaf
node the terminal node that predicts the
outcome let's move forward and see
decision Tre algorithms the first one is
select the best attribute to use the
current node in the tree the second one
is for each possible values select the
attributes the third one is partition
the examples using the possible values
of this attribute and assign these joint
subset of the example to the appropriate
child node recursively generate each
child node until ially all examples for
a node have the same label like class
moving forward let's understand the
Deion Tre for building a decision tree
step one is Select an attribute then
split the data into its children in a
tree continue splitting with available
attributes and keep splitting until Leaf
node are pure like only one class
remains a maximum depth is reached a
performance metric is achieved let's
move forward and see svm algorithm
support Vector machine
algorithms a support Vector machine is a
well-known supervised machine learning
model it is utilized for both
information classification and
regression it is regularly utilized for
the grouping issues we can involve it in
different life care system and we can
involve it in typically happy or side
look Arrangements we can involve it in
filters if we make specific looks it
would add the particular filter
according to the expression the scope of
articulation lies between happy and sad
support Vector machine helps him to
recognize handr return characters use yd
like checks continue to be the
significant part of the majority of
non-cash transaction and are frequently
return by the pupil the current check
processing system in many developing
Nations involves a bank employer to read
and manually enter the information in a
check while also verifying the data like
signature and
date a handwritten tax recognition
system can reduce expenses and labor
hours because a bank must handle several
checks each day moving forward let's see
the algorithm of
svm the objective of support Vector
machine is to make the best line or
choice limit that can isolate n
dimensional space into classes so we can
undoubtly put the new data of interest
in the right category later on this best
decision boundary is known as a
hyperplan let's move forward and see
types of support Vector machine support
Vector machine can be of two types first
one is linear sbm second one is
nonlinear sbm let's move forward and see
linear SPM linear SPM is utilized for
linearly detachable information
which implies if a data set can be
ordered into two classes by utilizing a
straight line then such information a
named linearly separable information and
a classifier is utilized called linear
SPM classifier moving forward let's see
nonlinear
sbm nonlinear sbm is utilized for
non-directly isolated information and
that implies in the event that a data
set can't be categorized by utilizing a
straight line such information is named
non-directed information and the
classifier utilized is called a
nonlinear SPM classifier moving forward
let's see KNN algorithm in
detail KNN is a supervised learning
technique Canon classifies new data into
our targeted classes depending on the
features of its neighboring points and
also be used for the regression problems
it is an instance-based learning
algorithm and a bit lazy learning
algorithm Canon calculation stores every
one of its accessible information and
orders another information Point based
on the likeliness this means that when
new data information appears it usually
tends to be successfully categorized
into a good suit classes using the Canon
algorithm let's imagine we have an image
of animal that resembles a cow or Ox
however here we are not sure if it is a
cow or Ops SN method is based on a
likeus Matrix it will identify the
properties of new data that are related
to the image of cow or ox and based on
those quality it will classify the data
is belonging to either cow or o group
moving forward let's see how does scn
work the steps to implement KNN
algorithms are step one decide on the
neighbors SK numbers step two calculate
the ukan distance between K Neighbors in
step two third third one is based on the
determined ukle and distance select the
K closest neighbors step four is count
the numbers of data points in each
category between these SK neighbors step
five assign the fresh data points in the
category where the highest neighbors
count and then KNN model is ready let's
say we need to add a new data point to
the vital category at first we will
decide on the numbers of neighbors
therefore we will pick K = to 5
then the ukan distance between the data
points and then can be determined the
distance between two points known as the
uclean distance can be determined by
under root of X2 - X1 sare + Y2 - y1
whole squ then we determine the closest
neighbors by calculating the ukine
distance there are three closest
Neighbors in category a and two closest
neighbor in category B this new data
point Must Fall with with category a
because as we can see its three closest
neighbors are also from group a after
understanding KL algorithm let's move
forward and see K means algorithms in
detail the K means is a cluster false
under that is an unsupervised learning
algorithm it is used to address machine
learning clustering problems and
utilized to tackle the grouping issues
in machine learning it permits us to
Bunch the information into various
Gatherings it is a helpful method for
finding the classification of groups in
the unlabeled data set without the
requirement of any training this K means
algorithm groups the data into similar
classes let's see some application of K
means clustering let's see some
applications of K means clustering
diagnostic system the medical profession
uses K means crusting in creating a
smarter medical decision support system
especially in the treatment of lever
alignments the second one is search
engines clustering forms a backbone of
search engine when a search engine is
performed the search result need to be
grouped and the search engines very
often use clustering to do this moving
forward let's see how K means algorithm
works the steps to implement K means
algorithms are step one select the
number K to set the number of clusters
step two select a random K points or
centroid step three assign each data
point the closest centroid dat forms to
predefined K cluster step four determine
the variance and a set a new Gravity
points for each cluster step five repeat
the third step this means reallocating
each data point to the new closest
centroid cluster step six if a
reassignment occurs go to step four
otherwise go to exit step seven the
model is ready to use so now we have an
clear understanding of how K means
algorithm work let's move forward to see
the graphical represent presentation of
K means
algorithm consider that there are two
variables M1 and M2 this is a scatter
plot of these two variables along the X
and Y AIS we should accept the number of
K of bunches that is K = to 2 to
recognize the data set and to place them
into various groups it implies here we
will attempt to Bunch these data set
into two unique groups we will really
want to pick an irregular keyo or
centroid to frame this group these
centroids can be either the focus of the
data set or some of other points thus
here we are choosing under two points as
SK points which are not the piece of our
data set we will assign every data of
interest in the scatter plot to the
nearest K point or centroid we will
register it by applying some ma that we
consider to find the distance between
two points that is ukan distance thus we
will draw a median between both the
centroids from the graph the left half
of the line are close points to the
right and the K1 centroid green is near
the orange centroid we should veriy them
as green and orange for Clear
representation as the need might arise
to track down the nearest group we will
repeat the cycle by picking another
centroid to pick the new centroid we
will figure out the center point of
gravity of these centroids and we'll
track down new centroids then we will
reassign every piece of information to
highlight new croid for this we will
will repeat a similar course of tracking
down a middle line the middle will be
like as seen in the picture one orange
point is on the left half of the line
and two green points are on the right
thus these three points will be
appointed to the new centroids as
reassignment has occurred we will again
go to step four tracking down new
centroids or k points we will repeat the
cycle by tracking down the center point
of gravity of centroids so the new
centroids will be displayed as like this
we now have new Android so once more
Define the middle boundary and reassign
the data of in by this graph there are
no unique pieces of information on one
of the other side of the line implying
our model is shaped by the previous
graph there are no unique pieces of
information on one or the other line
implying our model is shaped as our K
means model is ready and the two last
groups will be displayed as like these
now we have an clear understanding of
how K means clustering algorithm works
now let's move forward to understand
random Forest
algorithm random Forest is an adaptable
simple to utilize machine learning
algorithm that produces even without the
hyper boundary tuning an extraordinary
outcome more often that not it is
likewise quite possibly the most
utilized algorithm because of its effort
and variety like it tend to be the
utilized for both grouping and
classification task random Forest is a
classifier that contains various Choice
trees on different subset of the given
data set and takes the normal to work on
the present exactness of the data set
instead of depending on the choice tree
the random Forest takes the forecast
from each tree and in light of the
larger part of vs of expectation it
predicts the final result now let's move
forward and see how does random Forest
work
we should see the random forest in order
since the arrangement is now and again
thought to be the structured block of
machine learning this is what a random
Forest would look like with two trees
the random Forest has a similar
hypermeter to a decision tree or a
badging classifier luckily there is a
compelling reason need to consolidate a
decision tree with a badging classifier
since you can undoubtly utilize the
classifier classes of random Forest with
random Forest you can likewise manage
task using the algorithm regression
random Forest add extra AB bidness to
the model while deing the trees rather
than looking for the M element while
parting a node it looks to the best
component among an irregular subset of
highlights these outcomes in a wide
variety often result in a superior model
subsequently in a random Forest just a
random subset of the element is T about
the algorithms you might make trees more
random by involving random edges for
each component instead of looking for
the most ideal limits like a typical
Choice tree does let's move forward and
see some application of random Forest
algorithms random Forest is involved at
work by researchers in numerous Ventures
including banking stock exchanging
medication and many more it is utilized
to predict things which assist these
businesses with running productively
like client activity patient history and
safety in banking random Forest is used
to identify clients who are more likely
to pay back their debts on schedule
additionally it is utilized to forecast
who will make more frequent use of Bank
Services even fraud detection uses it
the Robin Hood of algorithms indeed
random Forest is a tool used by stock
traders to forecast future stock
Behavior retail businesses utilize it to
make product recommendation and forecast
client satisfaction random Forest can be
used in healthcare industry to examine a
patient medical history and detect
disorders random Forest is a tool used
by pharmaceutical expert to determine
the ideal mix of ingredients in
treatment or to forecast drug
sensitivity by seeing application of
random Forest algorithm let's move
forward and see some difference between
decision trees and random Forest
let's see the difference between random
forest and decision tree the first one
is while building a random Forest the
number of rows is selected randomly in
decision trees it builds several
decision trees and find out the output
the second one is it combines two or
more decision trees together in decision
trees whereas the decision is a
collection of variables or data set or
attributes the third one is it gives
accurate results whereas it gives less
accurate results the fourth one is by
using random Forest it reduces the
chance of overl whereas decision trees
it has the possibility of over lifting
the fifth one is random Forest is more
complicated to interpreter whereas the
decision tree is simple it is easy to
read and understand after seeing what is
zom Forest how it works let's move
forward to see ariary algorithms in
detail the AI algorithm utilize standard
item sets to create affiliation rules
and is intended to chip away the
information basis containing exchanges
with the assistance of these affiliation
rules it decide how firmly or feebly two
objects are associated this algorithm
utiliz a breath for search and history
to work out the item set Association
effectively it is the iterative
interaction for finding out the
successive item set from the huge data
ass said let's move forward and see
steps for AI algorithms the steps for AI
algorithms are Step One is establish
minimal support and confidence for item
set in the transactional database the
second one is take all transaction
supports with a greater support value
the minimum or choosen support value in
step two the third one is track down all
the rules in these subsets with
confidence value greater than the
threshold value the fourth one is
arrange the rules to lower the lift at
last we will see some advantages and
disadvantages of a PRI algorithm the
advantages of AI algorithms are easy to
understand an algorithm and the second
one is the join and prune steps of the
algorithms can be easily implemented on
the large data set the disadvantages of
AI algorithms are the AI algorithms work
slowly as compared to the other
algorithm and the second one is the a
PRI algorithms times and space complex
it are o of 2D which is very low
compared to the other ones let's move
forward and see some handson lab demo so
we will see a hands on lab demo on
linear regression as we know linear
regression is a way to find or to
predict the relationship between two
variables generally we use X and Y so
first we will open command prompt to
write command to open jupyter notebook
so we will here write
Jupiter notebook and then press
enter so this is the landing page of
jupyter notebook and select open new
python
file so this is how jupyter notebook UI
looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in mathematical functioning
so the first one is
numpy numpy is a python Library used for
working with arrays it also has
functions for working in domains like
linear algebra and matrices it is an
open source project and you can use it
freely numi stand for numerical python
so we will write like
import numpy s NP here NP is used for
denoting npire so we will import the
next libraries pandas pandas is a
software Library written for Python
programming for like data manipulation
and Analysis in particular it offers
data structures and operation for
manipulating numerical labels and time
series so we will write import
Hondas as PD here PD is used for
denoting pandas so our next library is
matplot lip mat plot lip is a graph
plotting library in Python that serves
as a visualization utility M BL is a
open source so we can use it freely and
it is most WR in Python a few segments
in C and JavaScript for platform
compatibility for importing M plot Li
you have to write import Mt plot
Li blot Li do pip
plot s PLT so after importing the
libraries we will move ahead and import
data set so for importing data set we
have to write data
set
equals to PD do
read CSV and here we have to give the
path of the file data
set.
CSV here PD is for Panda's labrary and
read is used for reading the data set
from the machine and CSV CSV is used for
the type of file which you want to read
so after reading let's see our data so
we will write data set
dot
head and press enter here head is used
for retrieving the first five lines from
the data so our data is coming properly
so moving ahead now let's first Define X
and Y axis for X we have to write X = to
data set do
iock bracket colum comma colum again
minus
one dot values for x-axis and for y axis
we have to write yals to data
set do
iog bracket column comma
1 dot
values so if we will use data set. iog
for minus one values for x-axis it will
select till the second last column of
the data frame instead of the last
column and I know this is as the second
last column value and the last column
value for the row is different whereas
if you use for the y- axis values WR a
series Vector a vector does not have a
column size so moving ahead let's see
the value for x and y axis first we will
see the value for x like just you have
to write X and press enter
so these are the arrays value for x and
for y axis you have to type Y and then
enter so these are arrays value for y
axis so after this now let's split the
data set into training and test testing
separating data into training and
testing set is an important part for
evaluating data mining models typically
when you separate a data set into a
training set and a testing set most of
the data set is used for training and a
similar portion of data set is used for
testing so we will split it into 70 and
30 ratio so for splitting we need to
import some more libraries for this
process so we will write
from
skar Dot model underscore
selection
import
train underscore test underscore
split psyched learn like SK learn is
most useful and robust library for
machine learning in Python it provides a
selection of efficient tools for machine
learning and statical modeling including
classification regression and clustering
so after importing let's write code for
the splitting data so we will write
here
xcore
train comma xcore test comma Yore
train comma
Yore
test equals
to P underscore test underscore split
in Brackets we have to write X comma
y comma
test
uncore
size equals to
0.3
comma
random _
State equals to
random with random State equals to 0 we
get the same train and test sets across
different execution so after this let's
see the values together so we will write
xcore
train comma
test comma
Yore
train comma
test so these are the values of array X
and array y to together moving ahead now
let's work with regression first we need
to import the library for regression so
we will use
from
skon do
linear
underscore
model model
import
linear
regression we already discussed escalan
is used for machine learning and linear
regression is a major part of machine
learning so after this let's make a
function for regression as R for easy
use so we will write
R equals
to
linear
regression and brackets first we try to
train and then test and compare so we
will write here
r
dot
bit bracket xcore
train comma
Yore
train now let's predict values but
prediction values are always different
so we will predict values for y first so
we will write y underscore
predict = to
r dot
predict sorry predict
or xcore
test so like
Yore
predict then enter this is when the
predict functions come into the picture
python predict function enables us to
predict the labels of the data values on
the basis of training model the predict
function accept only a single argument
which is xor test here usually the data
to be tested so when you will check the
value for y test you will see the
different values like
Yore
test so you can see there are totally
different values from x-axis now let's
display on graph for training data set
so we have to write PLT do
scatter xcore
train comma Yore
train comma color
equals to you can choose by yourself I
will choose
red and then
PLT do
plot xcore
drain comma regression point for
predicting
values for
xcore
train
comma color equals to
Blue so this color is called the
regression line and the PLT do
title
linear
regression okay
regression
salary versus
experience
and I will prefer this size would be uh
180 so let's set the labels for x and y
axis so X
label year of
employee of employee comma size will be
I will prefer size be
50 then for y axis we will
write
here like
salaries of
emplo I will prefer this same size
15 let's show the plot by writing PLT do
show
then hopefully we are for everything is
going to be fine perfect so you can see
we have linear regression line fitting
through our data set so this is how the
linear regression work for training data
set let's see how it will work for
testing data
set now let's predict for test data set
you can copy for the same and like you
can change it so we can copy
here so we can paste here so we have to
just change here
train to test data
set test here then
again test
here then
here everything everything we will
reduce some
size to 16 let's see then it will 12 and
so perfect so you can see we have linear
regression line fitting through our data
set so this is how the linear regression
works for testing data set if you're
looking for a course that covers
everything from the fundamentals to
Advanced Techniques then accelerate your
career in Ai and machine learning with a
comprehensive post-graduate program in
Ai and machine learning boost your
career with this Ai and ml course
delivered in collaboration with the puru
university and IBM learn in demand
skills such as machine learning deep
learning NLP computer vision
reinforcement learning generative AI
prompt engineering chat GPT and many
more you'll receive a prestigious
certificate and ask me anything sessions
by IBM with five capstones in different
domains using real data sets you will
gain practical experience master classes
by PD faculty and IBM experts ensure
top-notch education simply learns job
assist help you get noticed by Leading
companies this program covers statistics
python supervised and unsupervised
learning NLP neural networks computer
vision G scas tensorflow and many more
such skills admission to this
post-graduate programm in Ai and machine
learning requires a bachelor's degree
with an average of 50% or higher marks
along with the basic understanding of
programming Concepts and Mathematics and
candidates with two plus years of work
experience are preferred to enroll in
this school so enroll now and unlock
exciting Ai and machine learning
opportunities the link is mentioned in
the description box below let's first
understand what text mining is text
mining is the technique of exploring
large amounts of unstructured Text data
and analyzing it in order to extract
patterns from the text Data it is aided
by software that can identify Concepts
patterns topics keywords and other
attributes in the data it utilizes
computational techniques to extract and
summarize the high quality information
from unstructured textual resources
let's understand the flow of text mining
there are five techniques used in text
mining system information extraction or
text
pre-processing this is used to examine
the unstructured text by searching out
the important words and finding the
relationships between them
categorization or text transformation
attribute generation categorization
technique labels the text document under
one or more categories classification of
Text data is done based on input output
examples with
categorization clustering or attribute
selection clustering method is used to
group text documents that have similar
content clusters are the partitions and
each cluster will have a number of
documents with similar content
clustering makes sure that no document
will be omitted from the search and and
it deres all the documents that have
similar content visualization technique
the process of finding relevant
information is simplified by
visualization technique this technique
uses text Flags to represent a group of
documents or a single document and
compactness is indicated using colors
visualization technique helps to display
textual information in a more attractive
way summarization or interpretation or
evaluation
summarization technique will help to
reduce the length of the document and
summarize the details of the documents
it makes the document easy to read for
users and understand the content at the
moment let's understand the significance
of text
mining document clustering document
clustering is an important part of text
mining it has many applications in
Knowledge Management and information
retrieval clustering makes it easy to
group simil ilar documents into
meaningful groups such as in newspapers
where sections are often grouped as
business Sports politics and so on
pattern identification text mining is
the process of automatically searching
large amount of text for text patterns
and recognition of features features
such as telephone numbers and email
addresses can be extracted using pattern
matches product insights text mining
helps to extract large amounts of text
for example customer review about the
products mining consumer reviews can
reveal insights like most loved feature
most hated feature improvements required
and reviews of competitor's products
security monitoring text mining helps in
monitoring and extracting information
from news articles and reports for
national security purposes text mining
makes sure to use all of your available
information it is a more effective and
productive knowledge discovery that
allows you to make better informed
decisions automate information intensive
processes gather business critical
insights and mitigate operational
risk let's look at the applications of
text
mining speech recognition speech
recognition is the recognition and
translation of spoken language into text
and vice versa speech often provides
valuable information about the topics
subjects and concepts of multimedia
content information extraction from
speech is less complicated yet more
accurate and precise than multimedia
content this fact motivates
content-based speech analysis for
multimedia Data Mining and retrieval
where audio and speech processing is a
key enabling
technology spam filtering spam detection
is an important method in which textual
information contained in an email is
extracted and used for
discrimination text mining is useful an
automatic detection of spam emails based
on the filtering content using text
mining an email service provider such as
Gmail or Yahoo mail checks the content
of an email and if some malicious text
is found in the mail then that email is
marked as spam and sent to the spam
folder sentiment analysis it is done in
order to determine if a given sentence
expresses positive neutral or negative
sentiments sentiment analysis is one of
the most popular applications of text
analytics the primary aspect of
sentiment analysis includes data
analysis of the body of the text for
understanding the opinion expressed by
it and other key factors comprising
modality and mood usually the process of
sentiment analysis works best on text
that has a subjective context than on
that with only in objective context
e-commerce
personalization text mining is used to
suggest products that fit into a user's
profile text mining is increasingly
being used by e-commerce retailers to
learn more about the consumers as it is
the process of analyzing textual
information in order to identify
patterns and gain insights e-commerce
retailers can Target specific
individuals or segments with
personalized offers and discounts to
boost sales and increase Customer
Loyalty by identifying customer purchase
patterns and opinions on particular
products let's look at natural language
toolkit library in
detail natural language toolkit is a set
of open-source python models that are
used to apply statistical natural
language processing on human language
data let's see how you can do
environment setup of
nltk go to Windows start and launch
python interpreter from Anaconda prompt
and enter the following command commands
enter command python to check the
version of python installed on your
system enter import nltk to link you to
the nltk library available to download
then enter nltk doownload function that
will open the nltk download window check
the download directory select all
packages and click on download this will
download nltk onto your python once you
have downloaded the NL TK you must check
the working and functionality of it in
order to test the setup enter the
following command in Python Idol from
nltk Doc Corpus import Brown brown. word
parenthesis
parenthesis the brown is an nltk Corpus
that shows the systematic difference
between different genres available words
function will give you the list
available words in the genre the given
output put shows that we have
successfully tested the nltk installed
on
python let's Now understand how you can
read a specific module from nltk corpora
if you want to import an entire module
from nltk corpora use asterisk symbol
with that module name import command
enter the command from nltk book import
asterisk it will load all the items
available in NLT K's book module
now in order to explore Brown Corpus
enter the command nltk do Corpus import
Brown this will import Brown Corpus on
the python enter brown. categories
function to load the different genres
available select a genre and assign that
genre to a variable using the following
syntax variable name is equal to brown.
wordss categories is equal to genre name
now in order to see the available words
inside the selected genre just enter the
defined variable name as a
command let's understand text extraction
and pre-processing in
detail so let's first understand the
concept of
tokenization tokenization is the process
of removing sensitive data and placing
unique symbols of identification in that
place in order to retain all the
essential information concerned with the
data by itself security it is a process
of breaking running streams of text into
words and sentences it works by
segregating words using punctuation and
spaces text extraction and
pre-processing
engrams now let's look at what engram is
and how it is helpful in text mining
engram is the simplest model that
assigns these probabilities to sequences
of words or sentences engrams are
combination of adjacent words or letters
of length n in the source text so engram
is very helpful in text mining when it
is required to extract patterns from the
text as in the given example this is a
sentence all of these words are
considered individual words and thus
represent unigrams a two gr or Byram is
a two- word sequence of words like this
is is a or a sentence and a three GR or
trigram is a three-word sequence of
words like this is a or is a
sentence let's Now understand what stop
words are and how you can remove
them stop words are natural language
words that have negligible meanings such
as a n and or the and other similar
words these words also will take up
space in the database or increase the
processing time so it is better to
remove such words by storing a list of
stop words you can find the list of stop
words in the nltk data directory that is
stored in 16 different languages use the
following command to list the stop words
of English language defined in nltk
Corpus importing nltk will import the
nltk Corpus for that instance enter from
nltk Doc Corpus import Stop wordss will
import Stop wordss from nltk Corpus
Now set the language as English so use
set function as set under braces stop
wordswords set genre as English stop
words are filtered out before processing
of natural language data as they don't
reveal much information so as you can
see in the given example before
filtering the sentence the tokenization
of stop word is processed in order to
remove these stop words and the
filtering is applied in order to filter
the sentence based on some
criteria text extraction and
pre-processing
stemming stemming is used to reduce a
word to stem or base word by removing
suffixes such as helps helping helped
and helper to the root word help the
stemming process or algorithm is
generally called a stemmer there are
various stemming algorithms such as
Porter stemmer Lancaster stemmer
snowball stemmer Etc use any the stemmer
defined under nltk stem Corpus in order
to perform stemming as shown in the
example here we have used Porter stemmer
When You observe the output you will see
that all of the words given have been
reduced to their root word or
stem text extraction and pre-processing
lemmatization lemmatization is the
method of grouping the various inflected
types of a word in order that they can
be analyzed as one item it uses
vocabulary list or a morphological
analysis to get the root word it uses
word net database that has English words
linked together by their semantic
relationship as you can observe the
given example the different words have
been extracted to their relevant
morphological word using
lemmatization text extraction and
preprocessing POS
tagging let's now look at different part
of speech tags of ailable in the
national language toolkit Library a POS
tag is a special label assigned to each
token or word in a Text corpus to
indicate the part of speech and often
also other grammatical categories such
as tense number either plural or
singular case Etc POS tags are used in
text analysis tools and algorithms and
also in Corpus searches so look at the
given example here Alice wrote a program
is the source text given the POS tags
given are Alice is a noun wrote is a
verb a is an article and program is an
adjective look at the given example to
understand how posos tags are defined so
the given sentence or paragraph contains
different words that represent different
parts of speech we will first use
tokenization and removal of stop words
and then allocate the different POS tags
these are shown with different words in
the given sentence p s tags are useful
for lemmatization in building named
entity recognition and extracting
relationships between
words text extraction and pre-processing
named entity recognition now let's
understand what named entity recognition
is all about Neer seeks to extract a
real world entity from the text and
sorts it into predefined categories such
as names of people organizations
locations Etc many real world questions
can be answered with the help of name
entity recognition were specified
products mentioned in complaints or
reviews does the Tweet contain the name
of a person does the Tweet contain the
person's address as you can see in the
given example Google America Larry Page
Etc are the names of a person place or
an organization so these are considered
named entities and have different tags
such as person organization GP e or
geopolitical entity
Etc NLP process
workflow now you have an understanding
of all nltk tools so now let's
understand the natural language
processing workflow step one
tokenization it splits text into pieces
tokens or words and removes punctuation
step two stop word removal it removes
commonly used words such as the is r Etc
which are not relevant to the analysis
step three stemming and litiz it reduces
words to base form in order to be
analyzed as a single item step four POS
tagging it tags words to be part of
speech such as noun verb adjective Etc
based on the definition and context step
five information retrieval it extracts
relevant information from the
source M1 Brown Corpus
problem statement the Brown University
standard Corpus of present-day American
English also known popularly as brown
Corpus was compiled in the 1960s as a
general Corpus in the field of Corpus
Linguistics it contains 500 samples of
English language text totaling roughly 1
million words compiled from Works
published in the United States in
1961 we will be working on one of the
subset data set and performed text
processing tasks let us import the nltk
library and read the
ca10 Corpus import
nltk we will have to make sure that
there are no slashes in between hence we
will use the replace function within
pandas for the
same
let's have a look at the data
once
tokenization after performing sentence
tokenization on the data we
obtain similarly after applying sentence
tokenizer the resulting output shows all
individual words
tokens stop word removal let's import
the stopword library from nltk Doc
Corpus import
stopwords we also need to ensure that
the text is in the same case nltk has
its own list of stop wordss we can check
the list of stop wordss using stopwords
do wordss and English inside the
parenthesis map the lowercase string
with our list of word
tokens
let's remove the stop wordss using the
English stop wordss list in
nltk we will be using set checking as it
is faster in Python than a
list by removing all stop wordss from
the text we
obtain
often we want to remove the punctuations
from the documents too since python
comes with batteries included we have
string. punctuation from string import
punctuation
combining the punctuation with the stop
words from
nltk removing stop wordss with
punctuation
stemming and
lemmatization we will be using stemming
and lemmatization to reduce words to
their root form for example walks
walking walked will be reduced to their
root word walk importing Porter stemmer
as the stemming library from nltk do
stem import Porter
stemmer printing the stem
words import the wordnet litier from
nltk do
stem
printing the root
words we also need to evaluate the POS
tags for each
token
create a new word list and store the
list of word tokens against each of the
sentence tokens in data 2 for I and
tokenized also we will check if there
were any stop words in the recently
created word
list
we will now tag the word tokens
accordingly using the POS tags and print
the tagged
output for our final text processing
task we will be applying named entity
recognition to classify named entities
in text into predefined categories such
as the names of persons organizations
locations expressions of times
quantities monetary values percentages
Etc
now press the tagged sentences under the
chunk parser if we set the parameter
binary equals true then named entities
are just tagged as NE otherwise the
classif fire adds category labels such
as person organization and
gpe create a function named as extract
entity names along with an empty list
named as entity
names we will now extract named entities
from a nltk chunked expression and store
them in the empty created
above
again we will set the entity names list
as an empty list and we'll extract The
Entity names by iterating over each tree
in chunked
sentences
great we have seen how to explore and
examine the Corpus using text processing
techniques let's quickly recap the steps
we've covered so far One Import the nltk
library two perform tokenization three
perform stemming and lemmatization four
remove stop words five perform named
entity
recognition structuring sentences
syntax let's first understand what
syntax is syntax is the grammatical
structure of sentences in the given
example this can be interpreted as
syntax and it is similar to the ones you
use while writing codes knowing a
language includes the power to construct
phrases and sentences out of morphemes
and words the part of the grammar that
represents a speaker's knowledge of
these structures and their formation is
called syntax phrase structure rules are
rules that determine what goes into a
phrase that is constituents of a phrase
and how the constituents are ordered
constituent is a word or group of words
that operate as a unit and can be used
to frame larger grammatical units the
given diagram represents that a noun
phrase is determined when a noun is
combined with a determiner and the
determiner can be optional a sentence is
determined when a noun phrase is
combined with a verb phrase a verb
phrase is determined when a verb is
combined optionally with the noun phrase
and prepositional phrase and a
prepositional phrase is determined when
a preposition is combined with a noun
phrase a tree is a representation of
syntactics structure of formulation of
sentences or strings consider the given
sentence the factory employs 12.8% of
Bradford County what can be the Syntax
for pairing this statement let's
understand this a tree is produced that
might help you understand that the
subject of the sentence is the factory
the predicate is employ and the target
is
12.8% which in turn is modified by
Bradford County syntax parses are often
a first step toward deep information
extraction or semantic understanding of
text rendering syntax tree
download the corresponding exe file to
install the ghost script rendering
engine based on your system
configuration in order to render syntax
trees in your notebook let's understand
how you can set up the environment
variable once you have downloaded and
installed the file go to the folder
where it is installed and copy the path
of the file now go to system properties
and under Advanced properties you will
find the environment variable button
click on that to open the popup box tab
of the environment now open the bin
folder and add the path to the bin
folder in your environment
variables now you will have to modify
the path of the environment variable use
the given code to test the working of
syntax tree after the setup is
successfully
installed structuring sentences chunking
and chunk
parsing the process of extraction of
phrases from unstructured text is called
chunking instead of using just simple
tokens which may not represent the
actual meaning of the text it is
advisable to use phrases such as Indian
team as a single word instead of Indian
and team as separate words the chunking
segmentation refers to identifying
tokens and labeling refers to
identifying the correct tag these chunks
correspond to mixed patterns in some way
to extract patterns from chunks we need
chunk parsing the chunk parsing segment
refers to identifying strings of tokens
and labeling refers to identifying the
correct chunk type let's look at the
given example you can see here that
yellow is an adjective dog is a noun and
the' is the determiner which are chunked
together into a noun phrase similarly
chunk parsing is used to extract
patterns and to process such patterns
from multiple chunks while using
different
parsers let's take an example and try to
understand how chunking is performed in
Python let's consider the sentence the
little mouse ate the fresh cheese
assigned to a variable named scent using
the word tokenize function under nltk
corpora you can find out the different
tags associated with the sentence
provided so as you can see in the output
different tags have been allocated
against each of the words from the given
sentence using chunk
in NP chunk and
parser you will now create grammar from
a noun phrase and will mention the tags
you want in your chunk phrase within the
function here you have created a regular
expression matching the string the given
regular expression indicates optional
determiner followed by optional number
of adjective followed by a noun you will
now have to parse the chunk therefore
you will create a chunk parser and pass
your noun phrase string to it the parser
is now ready you will use the parse
parenthesis parenthesis within your
chunk parser to parse your sentence the
sentence provided is the little mouse at
the fresh cheese this sentence has been
parsed and the tokens that match the
regular expressions are chunked together
into noun phrases
NP create a verb phrase chunk using
regular Expressions the regular
expression has been defined as optional
personal pronoun followed by by zero or
more verbs with any of its type followed
by any type of adverb you'll now create
another chunk parser and pass the verb
phrase string to it create another
sentence and tokenize it add POS tags to
it so the new sentence is she is walking
quickly to the mall and the POS tag has
been allocated from nltk corpor now use
the new verb phrase parser to parse the
tokens and run the result
you can look at the given tree diagram
which shows a verb parser where a
pronoun followed by two verbs and an
adverb are chunk together into a verb
parse structuring sentences
chinking chinking is the process of
removing a sequence of tokens from a
chunk how does chunking work the whole
chunk is removed when the sequence of
tokens spans an entire chunk if the
sequence is at the start or the end of
the chunk the tokens are removed moved
from the start and end and a smaller
chunk is retained if the sequence of
tokens appears in the middle of the
chunk these tokens are removed leaving
two chunks where there was only one
before consider you create a chinking
grammar string containing three things
chunk name the regular expression
sequence of a chunk the regular
expression sequence of your here
in the given code we have the chunk
regular expression as optional person
pronoun followed by zero or more
occurrences of any type of the verb type
followed by zero or more occurrences of
any of the adverb types the
regular expression says that it needs to
check for the adverb in the extracted
chunk and remove it from the chunk
inside the chinking block with open
curly braces and closing curly braces
you have created one or more
adverbs you will now create a parser
from NLT k.
regex parser and pass the grammar
to it now use the new parser to
parse the tokens sent three and run the
results as you can see the parse tree is
generated while comparing the syntax
tree of the parser with that of
the original chunk you can see that the
token is quickly adverb chin out of the
chunk let's understand how to use
context free
grammar a context free grammar is a four
Tuple sum ntrs where sum is an alphabet
and each character in sum is called a
terminal NT is a set and each element in
NT is called a non-terminal r the set of
rules is a subset of NT times the set of
sum u n t s the start symbol is one of
the symbols in NT a context free grammar
generates a language L capturing con
constituency and ordering in CFG the
start symbol is used to derive the
string you can derive the string by
repeatedly replacing a non-terminal on
the right hand side of the production
until all non-terminals have been
replaced by terminal symbols let's
understand the representation of context
free grammar through an example in
context free grammar a sentence can be
represented as a noun phrase followed by
a verb phrase noun phrase can be a
determiner nominal a nominal can be a
noun VP represents the verb phrase a can
be called a determiner flight can be
called a noun consider the string below
where you have certain rules when you
look at the given context free grammar a
sentence should have a noun phrase
followed by a verb phrase a verb phrase
is a verb followed by a noun a verb can
either be Saul or met noun phrases can
either be John or Jim and a noun can
either be a dog or a cat check the
possible list of sentences that can be
generated using the rules use the join
function to create the possible list of
sentences you can check the different
rules of grammar for sentence formation
using the production function it will
show you the different tags used and the
defined context free grammar for the
given
sentence demo two structuring sentences
problem statement a company wants to
perform text analysis for one of its
data sets you are provided with this
data set named tweets. CSV which has
tweets of six US Airlines along with
their sentiments positive negative and
neutral the tweets are present in the
text column and sentiments in Airline
unor sentiment column we will be
retrieving all tags starting with at the
rate in the data set and save the output
in a file called references. txt let us
first import the pandas library and read
the twe twet data
set
extract the features text and Airline
sentiment
we will iterate through the data set
using reg X find the relevant
tweets now we will import the iter tools
module it returns efficient
iterators
the result is stored in a file named
references.
txt
let's extract all noun phrases and save
them in a file named noun phrases for
left karro Airline sentiment right Carro
review.
txt
here left carrot Airline uncore
sentiment right carrot has three
different values positive negative and
neutral so three files will be
created
now we will iterate all the leaf nodes
and assign them to noun phrases
variable
this means that the functions in iter
tools operate on iterators to produce
more complex
iterators
using the map function we will get all
the noun phrases from the
text putting it into
list
creating a file name in the name of
review.
txt
in a world where email is crucial spam
messages plag our inboxes disrupting our
digital lives but fear not a hero
emerges the email spam classifier this
intelligent system learns from past
encounters uncovering the tricks
employed by spammers deceitful subject
lines promising riches unreasonable low
prices it sports signs like excessive
capital letters misspellings and
suspicious URLs yet the battle doesn't
end here spammers constantly evolve
their tactics but the email spam
classifier doesn't Flinch it adapts
refining its knowledge and staying up to
date with the latest tricks every new
spam email it encounters it provides
insights enhancing its accuracy and
ensuring our protection thanks to
Dedicated minds and Ai and ml power the
fight against email spam continues the
email spam classifier stands as a
faithful Guardian a symbol of
Technology's victory over digital
adversaries it reclaims our inboxes and
restores order to our virtual world
according to recent studies Ai and
machine learning related job postings
have increased by staggering 344 in the
past 5 years companies across the global
actively seeking professionals who can
harness the power of data and build
intelligent systems the average salary
is
$150,000 in the US and 15 lakhs perom in
India accelerate your career in Ai and
machine learning with a comprehensive
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning gain expertise in machine
learning deep learning NLP computer
vision and reinforcement learning you
will receive a prestigious certificate
exclusive alumni membership and
hackathon and ask me anything sessions
by IBM with three capstones and 25 plus
industry projects using real data sets
from Twitter Uber and more you will gain
practical experience master classes by
Purdue faculty and IBM experts andure
topnotch education simply Larn job
assist help you notice by Leading
companies live sessions on AI trends
like chat jpt generative Ai and
explainable AI this program C statistics
python supervised and unsupervised
learning NLP neural networks computer
Vision G caras tens of flow and many
more skills enroll now and unlock
exciting Ai and ml opportunities the
link is mentioned in the description box
below let's take a minute to hear from
our Learners who have experienced
massive success in their careers you
need to keep updating your skills on a
regular basis no matter what level you
at I recently completed the professional
certificate program in Ai and machine
learning from Simply learn in
partnership with P University the course
material was comprehensive and the
faculty was extremely experienced uh The
Faculty was able to adjust their
teaching style in order to cater to the
overall skill set of the class in the
rapidly evolving world of technology
it's important to keep up Skilling for
every working professional stay relevant
with that having said hey everyone
welcome to Simply LS YouTube channel but
before we dive into that don't forget to
like subscribe and share and now over to
our training expert
so hello and welcome to this new video
by simply learn email spam classifier
okay so first we will change this name
to
email spam
classifier okay let's rename
it so first what we going to do so first
what we going to do we will import some
libraries then the main main libraries
like n
skill and logistic regression algorithm
and then we will move on to this
importing of data set of spam mail and
ham mail ham is known as like which is
not a Spam okay so we will do some
categorization of smam email and hem
email then we will split into the
training test and the testing of the
data set okay then we will transform the
text data to Fe feature vectors that can
be used as input to the logistic
regression and then we will convert the
Y train and the Y test values as
integers and then moving forward we will
some see the features the model
extractions and then we will train the
model using logistic
regression and after that we will
predict the accuracy how much the
training data is giving how much the
testing data is giving and at the end we
will build a predictive system which
will tell whether a particular email is
Spam or not spam Okay cool so let's move
on to the coding part then okay so first
I will import some major libraries like
import
numai as
NP okay then numpy so numpy is a
powerful python library for numerical
Computing so it stands for numerical
Python and provide support for efficient
array operations and mathematical
function L algebra random number
generation and more with numai you can
work with multi-dimensional array known
as ND arrays and these arrays are highly
optimized for performance and allow you
to perform mathematical and logical
operations on large data set efficiently
so numai provides a wide range of
function and methods to manipulate and
analyze these
arrays and the second one
is import
pandas as
PD okay this PD and NP is nothing we
don't want to write again and again
pandas and
napai so what is
pandas so pandas is a powerful python
Library used for data
manipulation and Analysis it provides
easy to use data structure and data
analysis tool making it essential tool
for working with structure data so the
third third one is psychic
learn okay so I will write here
from okay I will write here
from
skar do
model
selection
Bo
train test
split okay
so what is escalar model selection and
the train test
split so escalar or psychic learn is a
popular python library for machine
learning it provides a wide range of
tools and algorithms for various machine
learning tasks including classification
regression and the clustering
dimensionally reduction and the model
evaluation okay and this train test
split this one so the train test split
function is a utility in psychic learn
that helps in splitting the data set
into training and the testing subset
later we will split the data into
training and the testing so this
function is commonly used in machine
learning task to assess the performance
of a model on unseen data okay so move
on to the next algorithm we will write
from we will write
here
from
Escalon do
feature
extraction dot text
import
tfid
vectorizer okay so what is TF ID
vectorizer so tfid vectorizer is nothing
is a feature of extraction technique
commonly used in natural language
processing NLP and text mining task so
it is a part of psychic learn library in
Python so tfid vectorizer transform a
collection of text documents into a
numerical representation that machine
learning algorithm can work
with Okay so move on to we
will import from
Escalon
dot linear
model
support
logistic
regression okay so what is logistic
regression so logistic regression is a
popular classification algorithm used in
machine learning it is a part of the
psychic learn library in Python logistic
learn and the regression is suitable for
binary classification problems where the
target variable has the two classes okay
and the last we will import accuracy
score
okay so here I will write
from escalan do
Matrix
import
accuracy score okay so let me tell you
first what is accuracy score the
accuracy score function is a performance
matric provided by the psy learn library
in Python it is commonly used to
evaluate the performance of a
classification model by measuring the
accuracy of the predictions okay so let
me run
it okay okay there is some
error maybe the spelling
mistake okay what I will do I will write
it again
running it
again yeah it's working so now what I
will do I will import the data set so I
will write here DF equals to data frame
= pd.
read uncore
CSV mail _
data.
CSV you can find this data Link in the
description box below okay I'll run it
yeah so let's
see the data frame what's in it for us
so as you can see here is category then
message so these are the you know the
males ham means not spam and spam is
Spam okay those males which are not spam
known as
ham so there are two columns 557 to
rows so moving forward what I will do I
will convert this male data okay to Nal
so I will write
here data equals to
Raw raw data equals to DF dot
where PD do not
null not null
is
DF okay then some
space okay let me give you some spaces
for the better visual yeah so now I will
print data do
head so what is the meaning of head here
head means if you want to print the top
five lines of the particular data set it
is you can use the head and if you want
to put the last five rows of the data
set so you can use the tail instead if
you will write here
10 instead of giving it blank then run
it so it will give you the top 10 rows
of the particular data set okay so these
are the spam mail this ham mails so
later on what we will do we will train
this data set using this particular data
set okay
so let's move on
to and see the
info okay of the data set so data do
info so info you can see there are
columns this null null count this data
type so there are two columns like
category and the message and the
particular rows are the 5572 on the Bo
and the data type is object okay see the
memory usage and you can see
everything and there is one more you can
see the DAT
shape is 5572 comma 2 the these are the
rows and these are the columns two
columns and 5572 rows okay so now what I
will do I will assign the category to
spam M and ham mail okay so what I will
do
here I will write here data dot
Lo then and
data vers this
category equals to equals
to
spam
comma
category okay
comma equals to zero so if the zero will
show it is known as the spam and if one
will show it is known as as the Hamil
okay I will write here data
dot lo location and
data
then
category equals to
ham
then
category will
be
one okay then let me run it okay it's
running smoothly so I will write here x
equals to
data
then
message
okay and the Y value will
Beals to main s not main
data then
category okay then let
me run
it so now what I will do
first so now what I will do I will write
here
print
X okay so these are only the messages
and
category
print
y so now as you can see 1 1 0 1 1 0 so
here zero means what is the zero means
zero means
spam and the one means it's Hamil
okay so moving forward what I will do I
will split this data set into testing
and the training okay so I will write
here x
train this is the most important part
and the X
test
okay then y
train then y
test okay equals to
train test
split X comma y
comma test
size equals to
0.2
then
random okay random
State equals
to
three okay I will write
it
so this is
X train for the training set and X test
is the testing okay then the same y you
know that what is the X and Y here and
here we are splitting using train test
split then XA y test size equal to
0.2 okay 0.2 means it will be 80 and 20%
and 80% will be draining and the testing
will be 20% okay we will train data 80%
of data using this data set will be
trained and the for the test the 20%
will
okay the random State equals to three
and the random state is a
hyperparameters used to control any such
Randomness involved in machine learning
model to get consistent result okay when
splitting a data set splitting a node in
a decision tree or you know logistic
regression initializing centroids in
clustering takes place so that is why we
use random stet okay so let me run it
it's working fine
so now I will show
print x.
shape okay then
print
xcore
train.
ship I will show you about the I'm
talking about the test size now
print
xcore test.
ship now see
carefully okay this x will be
Capital so as you can see total rows are
5572 total row of 80% is 4457 or else
you can calculate and the 20% is for the
testing is
the15 same goes for the Y so moving
forward
okay let me show you for the Y also so I
will copy paste it here so
let's
y
y see same goes for the Y
also okay so now what I will do here I
will transform the text data to feature
vectors that can be used as input to the
logistic
regression so
feature
extraction equals to T
FID
vectorizer where the minimum difference
will
be one comma stop
words okay stop
words equals
to
English and the lower
case okay here I'm transforming the test
data to the feature
vector and okay so here
x okay let me tell you so this is the
feature extraction we are using TF Dev
vectorizer okay we have import here as
you can see for the feature extraction
of the
text and this is the minimum difference
equal to one and then what is the stop
word stop words are the English words
which does not add much meaning to the
sentence they can safely be ignored
without sacrificing the meaning of the
sentence okay like for example you can
see the words like the he have such
words already computerized and the
capture this is a corpus name and the
Corpus okay and this lower case equals
to true true so here I will write X
Trin
features to
Features
feature
extraction
fit
transform xcope
G
xcore
test
features
feature
extraction do
transform to the X
test
okay yeah so moving forward I will
convert y train and Y test values as an
integers okay y train because they are 0
1 0 1 0 train equals to Y
train. as
style
in okay then y
testal to Y t. as
type
in so
okay there is spelling
mistake we'll copy from
here paste it
here okay I will run
it okay why test it
is yeah it's rning so now what I will do
I will
print the X
train
train as you can see the X
train so these are the messages and if I
will
print
exrain
features we created here now see extra
features okay then you can
see so these are the features accuracy
okay say 0 0 0 means spam 1 one means
ham okay so moving forward what I will
do I will now the Train the model OKAY
logistic regession so I will write here
model equals
to okay
logistic
regression so now we will you know train
the model so here I will write
model equals to
logistic
regression okay so we don't want to
write again and again again and again
logistic regession so I'm here assigning
model to it so let me run it so here I
will train the logistic regression model
with the training data so here I will
write model.
fit
extr
features comma white
train okay here we are training the
logistic regression model with the
training
data let me run it yeah fine it's
running
fine so moving forward we will uh do the
evaluating of the training model train
model and the prediction of the training
data so for that I will write here
prediction on
training data equals to model dot
predict
extrem
features okay then I will write here
accuracy
on training data equal to accuracy
score y
train comma prediction okay I will write
from
here PR the training
data okay let me run
it so now we will see the prediction so
I will write here
prediction or simply I will write
print accuracy on
training
data
comma okay I will copy it leave it
accuracy
on
training data okay let me run this so as
you can see accuracy on training data is
0 .96 means almost 97% which is not bad
very very good okay we will see print
okay now we have to do for the testing
data this is for the training data and
let's see the accuracy for the testing
data so for that I will write same
prediction on test data equals to model
do
predict
X
test
features okay then
accuracy
on test
data to
accuracy
score then y
test comma
prediction prediction
on test
data
okay okay accuracy
score so here I will write
print the accuracy on test
data
okay comma then I will write
accuracy
on test
data okay so as you can see the accuracy
on test data is almost same as the
training data okay almost 95% 97% sorry
so now what we will do we will build a
predictive system now okay
so I will write here like input
okay you have to input the mail
here
then okay we will input later and we
will now write the line for the convert
text to feature Vector so for that I
will write here
input
data
features
to
feature
extraction do
transform
input
okay okay this is a function so I will
write here
input
inut
your
main me
okay so here we will make the
prediction okay I will write the
prediction model do
predict
input
data
teachers okay so I have some spam
mails with myself so I will try to copy
them and let's see
see okay I have some mail so I will copy
it
okay and I will paste it
here okay this is the second time we
have tried to contact you you have want
this this this these type of Mals are
spam
actually like you also know so I will
try to run it
let me run
it okay I forgot to write print
print
predictions okay so zero so here as you
can
see already zero means
spam okay so this is a spam mail
actually this is a spam so okay wait let
me write here
if prediction
is showing zero equal to equals to
true
then
print print it
to
H
and
as
then
print
[Music]
spam spam me okay the prediction will be
zero it's not equals to one okay so it
will show the ham mail or else the spam
mail simple pretty simple see Zero spam
okay I will try to put it put here what
one
Hamil
okay
okay let me copy it paste it
here okay let me delete this
quickly okay let me run this so it is
showing ham mail means not spam so
quickly let me run one more spam mail
okay
okay copy this and paste it
here you can try with your own like own
email with your
got okay so let me run this so it is
spam mail okay see you can see you have
been selected to stay like marketing
okay see in so these type of males are
like you know deals and the vouchers
this type of males are the known as the
spam mail see holiday value this dial
this and this okay so here we are we
have done with our email spam
classifier as you can see if you want
this code so so you
can comment down below if you're looking
for a course that covers everything from
the fundamentals to Advanced Techniques
then accelerate your career in Ai and
machine learning with a comprehensive
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning boost your career with this Ai
and ml course delivered in collaboration
with the Peru University and IBM learn
in demand skills such as machine
learning deep learning NLP computer
vision reinforcement learning generative
AI prompt engineering chat GPT and many
more you'll receive a prestigious
certificate and ask me anything sessions
by IBM with five capstones in different
domains using real data sets you will
gain practical experience master classes
by perdu faculty and IBM experts ensure
topnotch education simply learns job
assist help you get noticed by Leading
companies this program covers statistics
python supervised and unsupervised
learning NLP neural networks computer
vision G SC class tensorflow and many
more suchar skills admission to this
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning requires a bachelor's degree
with an average of 50% or higher marks
along with the basic understanding of
programming Concepts and Mathematics and
candidates with two plus years of work
experience are preferred to enroll in
this school so enroll now and unlock
exciting Ai and machine learning
opportunities the link is mentioned in
the description box below we will take
you through the Hands-On lab demo of how
you can do the sentimental analysis of
Amazon customer reviews before we start
I hope the screen is clearly visible and
the audio is fine if yes please type in
yes if there are any issues do let us
know in the chat section so that we can
resolve
them let's wait for some more minutes to
let other people
join let's wait for some more minutes to
join let me tell you guys that we have
regular updates on multiple Technologies
if you are a tech gig on a continuous
hun for the latest technological Trends
then consider subscribing to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
great I think we can get started so in
today's session we will go through the
what is sentimental analysis after that
we will see types of sentimental
analysis we will see some application of
sentiment analysis and at the end we
will see Hands-On lab demo like how to
implement sentiment analysis using
python in detail we already have Amazon
Customer data set with us we will
perform different function and analyze
data for sentiment analysis using python
you can download data set from the
description box below so before we move
on the programming part let's discuss
what a sentiment analysis actually is
and proceed further for the
same sentiment analysis sometime known
as opinion mining is a technique used in
natural language processing NLP to
determine the emotional undertone of a
document this is a common method used by
organization to identify and group ideas
regarding a certain good service or
concept text is mined for sentiment and
subjective information using data mining
machine learning and artificial
intelligence tools for sentiment
analysis assist businesses in extracting
information from unstructured un
organized language found in online
sources like emails blog post support
tickets web chats forums and comments
algorithm use rule based automatic or
hybrid technology to replace manual data
processing while automatic system use
machine learning to learn from their
data rule-based system execute sentiment
analysis using predetermined lexicon
based rules combining the two method
result in hybrid sentiment analysis
sentiment analysis or opinion mining can
extract the subject opinion holder and
polarity or the degree of positivity and
negativity from the text and identify
sentiment additionally other Scopes
including document paragraph sentence
and Subs sentence level can be used for
sentiment analysis after seeing what is
sentiment analysis let's discuss some
types of sentiment analysis so the first
one is find grain s sentiment analysis
by segmenting sentiment each phrase or
clause in a sentence is broken down and
examined in relationship to the others
simply said you can tell who review a
product and what topics a person
specifically discuss in their feedback
and the second one is emotion detection
instead of identifying positivity and
negativity emotion detection recognize
particular emotions example could
include shock rage grief frustration and
happiness and the third one is intent
based analysis in addition to identify
opinions in a text the intent based
analysis also identifies behaviors for
instance a frustrated online command
about changing a battery can motivate
customer care to get in touch to address
that particular problem and the last one
is expect based analysis collects the
precise component that is being
mentioned either favorably or
unfavorably for instance a client May
write in a product review that the
battery life is too short the system
will then respond that the battery life
is the main complaint and not the
product as a whole so after seeing types
of sentiment analysis let's see some
application of sentiment
analysis organization can employ
sentiment analysis Technologies for a
number of purpose such as determining
brand popularity reputation and
awareness at a particular period or
overtime customer service requests into
categories and the next one is
monitoring consumer response to new
improvements or products and the fourth
one is identifying the demographics or
Target market and the fifth one is
determining the effectiveness of a
marketing
effort so here is one question for you
guys I will give you one minute for this
you can comment or you can give answers
in chat section so I can see if the
answers given by you are right or wrong
so the question is is text analytics
also refers to as text mining I'm
repeating again is text analytics also
refers to as text mining the options are
true or
false so let us know your answer in
comment section below or in chat section
so I'm starting timer of 1 minute just
type your answer in comment section or
in chat section
do let me know your answers so I'm
starting timer of 1
minute I kindly ask that everyone take
part in this to make this live session
exciting so the question is is txt
analytics also refers to as text
mining 35 seconds are
left do let me know your answers I
kindly ask that everyone take part in
this to make the live session
exciting two
one 20 seconds
left you can comment or you can give
your answer in chat section so I can see
if the answers given by you are right or
wrong so time up guys so after the
allotted time has passed Those Who
provided the correct response will
receive a response and those Who
provided the incorrect response will
receive one okay now let's move to our
programming part to perform sentiment
analysis using Amazon customer data set
so first we will open command prom to
write command to open Jupiter notebook
so here we will write
Jupiter
notebook press
enter okay it's Jupiter
notebook
so this is the landing page of jupyter
notebook and here you can
select new python
file it's
loading so this is how the jupyter UI
looks like so at first we will import
some bunch of major libraries of python
which will help us in mathematical fun
functioning so the first one is numpy so
first I will write numpy import
numpy s
NP NP is a python Library used for
working with arrays it also has
functions for working in the domain of
linear algebra and matrices it is an
open- source project and you can use it
freely numai stand for numerical
python so
the next one is
pandas I will write here
import
pandas s
PD so pandas is a software Library
written for a Python programming
language for data manipulation and
Analysis in particular it offers data
structures and operation for
manipulating numerical tables and Time
series after that we will
import
nltk so the natural language toolkit
nltk is a Python Programming environment
for creating application for statical
natural language processing NLP for
parsing classification stemming tagging
and semantic reasoning it includes text
processing
libraries so after that we will
import from
nltk dot
sentiment do
Vader
import
sentiment
density
analyzer
okay there is no colum yeah so the
Lexicon and Rule based sentiment
analysis tool Vader verer means Valance
aware dictionary and essential reasoning
is a customized precisely to Sentiments
expressed on social media Vader makes
use of variety of a sentiment lexicon is
a collection of Lex elements such as
words that are often classified as
either positive or negative depending on
their santic
orientation Vader not only informs us of
the positivity and negativity scores but
also of the sentimentally of each
score so the next one is
import
re python re module fully supports
regular expression similar to those for
in Pearl if a regular expression
compilation or use error occurs the re
modules raises the expression
re two key functions that are used to
manage regular expression will be
covered so re means regular
Expressions so the next one is
from X
blob
import blob
okay so a python 2 or three package
called text blob is used to process
textual data it offers a straightforward
API to explore typical natural language
processing NLP tasks like part of speech
tagging noun phrase extraction sentiment
analysis classification translation and
more so the next one is
import
words
from word
cloud a word cloud commonly refers to as
a tag cloud is an image of words popular
words and phrases are highlighted using
Cloud creators depending on their
frequency and importance they give you
immediate straightforward visual
insights that can Inspire more through
analysis and the next one is
import
cbor
as
SNS
yeah so like an open- Source python
Library based on mat plot Li is called
cbon it is utilized for data exploration
and data visualization where data frames
and the Panda's Library cbon function
with
ease so the next one is import matplot
lip dot P
plot as
PLT okay yeah seems good for Python and
its numerical expression numpy met plot
lib is a crossplatform data visual Iz
ation and graphical charting package as
a result it presents a strong open-
Source substitute for matlb the API for
M plot lib allow programmers to
incorporate graphs into GUI
applications and the next one is
import pu links cuff L KS as
CF perfect another pyth module called
cuff link links plotly with panda so
that charts can be easily created on
data frames in essence it function like
a
plug-in so next in
line at blot
lip at blot
lip so you can enable inline plotting by
using the magic function percentage M
plot Li inline which causes the plots
and graphs to appear below the cell
where you plotting commands are entered
similar to a jupyter notebook it offers
backend interactivity in front ends the
next we will
import what you can like we can import
okay
from shortly do
offline
import init uncore notebook
underscore
mode comma I
plot okay in it uncore
notebook
mode get through yeah
cf.
goore
offline
so yeah in order to display the plot
inside the notebook you need to initiate
plotly notebook mode as follows like
this
keep rest of the script as it is like it
and run the notebook cell by pressing
you can shift plus enter graph will be
displayed offline inside the notebook so
basically it is used for the offline
graphing you can see okay so next we
will
import
from
plotly do subplots subplots are
important
import make underscore
subplot okay yeah the non-leaf nodes in
this figure schema are represented by a
hierarchy of python classes that was
automatically constructed and is found
in the plot do graph objects which is
normally imported as go these class
instance are refers to as graph object
the plotly defined fundamental
classes
okay so here we will import some like uh
warnings you can
[Music]
say like to get not
error so we will import let me give a
line space
import
warning warnings yeah
warnings dot
filter
warning
ignore
warnings.
one and
this uh like will not
show and let me add something
PD do
set
option display do
maxcore
Lums
okay import import words from
wordcloud okay there's an error let me
check what's the
error okay
import
this
wordcloud from
wordcloud
it's
capital and W is also
Capital here will be
Capital let it put is small
only from
wordcloud
okay my bad here from
wordcloud from
wordcloud import
wordcloud
okay yeah seems
good so where were
we yeah in warnings despite the
notification the software continues to
execute to display warning messages
utilize the warn found in the warning
module the python built-in class
expection is a subass of the warning
module which is used to display warning
messages import warnings okay for seeing
full data every single columns like okay
there is error C Bor no module as C
so s will be
small got it okay
line this only
like something like that in
line okay any errors
no I guess no error
okay yeah for seeing full data like
every single Columns of PD so here we
are using this pd. set off option so we
can use for it so moving forward let's
import data set so for importing data
set we will write
here
uh like DF equals to PD do
read
CSV
Okay add data set
name
yeah
so so you can download data set from the
description box below so no worries of
for
that let me run
this
okay so like here is PD is for Panda's
Library read is used for reading the
data set from the machine and CSV is
used for the type of file which you want
to read so let's see our
data so here I will write DF
dot
yeah so if you want to like if you want
to see top five rows of your data set
you can use head and if you want to uh
like see five rows of your data set you
can use tail in instead of head this one
okay so this is our data set with only
five rows if you want to see full data
set you
can like from starting from zero and
ending it 4914 rows okay 4915 rows and
columns
right so let me give something like this
for the better
visual
yeah okay so moving ah ahead let's sort
this Wilson bound column to ascending
order for better analysis so I'm talking
about this Wilson lower bound column
this one for it's not 0 0 0 like in all
the rows so let me show
you so here you have to write like DF
equals to DF do
sort
values
Wilson spelling should be
correct
lower
pound I make it to ascending
order
ascending sorry descending order
so BF do
drop
named
okay
un
name colum
zero okay in
place in equals to
True comma
XIs = to
1 okay so let's see of
data
so here you can see the data is sorted
in
as in as ascending order
okay so the provided row or column is
eliminated via the drop function the
drop method eliminates the specified
column when the column AIS is specified
the drop method eliminates the
designated row when the row AIS is
supplied okay so I hope you guys
understand till here if if you have any
queries or like any queries regarding
any code or there is something question
till here just put as in comments our
team will shortly provide you the
correct
solution
okay so moving forward let's make a
function for missing
values so
okay so I will write here like
DF
missing
values
analysis
analysis okay it's DF for function we
use
DF
yeah
EF columns
to co for
columns
for or Co n DF dot
columns if
DF
column is null
sum great than
zero underscore
missals to
DF n underscore
columns
score is null
sum dot sort values sortore
values like in ascending
ascending ascending equals to
true
okay like
some like this and
this that's fine I
guess yeah so here I will write
ratio underscore equals
to
DF
nacore columns
underscore dot
isnull same thing that
sum divided
by F do
shape
sort
values
standing to
True
fine okay
okay th is okay and the DF
part that sort value is equals to
sending to True fine
so here we will write
missing underscore DF = to
PD Dot
conat
dot
round
ratio underscore comma
two
perfect their XIs will be
one
okay
is equals
to that will give
like total
where I will write missing values
missing
values okay comma
ratio thing underscore DF equals to
PD dot data
frame
SC
DF okay so let me
return
DF let me create one more function for
like check data frame so
DF Che underscore data
frame okay
okay equals to
5 comma
tail equals to
5 so here I will write
print
okay
okay dot
center2
comma again for row
Sprint
r
craes
dot
format what
format do
shape
Z
so for columns
print do
shape
PR and types like of types of
data
Dot
Center same as like that
[Music]
882a
in DF do D
types
Center just printing this this like you
will see don't
worry just stay with me you will see the
beautiful
result okay
print
values print missing values uh
analysises like
DF
okay then M
again get
it
values like there many how many
duplicated values are there so dot same
for the
center
D again this
one
print have dot
duplicated don't worry I will explain
you like line by line just stay with me
let me write the whole code first
print
tiles like I'm printing multiple of
things so just be with me
dot
ENT
comma EF
Dot
onti
comma
one
okay
check data
frame hoping like there will be no
error
yeah so you can see now like
multiple information regarding data set
is
printed so this shape is for like how
many rows and columns present in the
data set like in types you can say like
every column type like object in 64
float 64 and many more are like present
so like you can see review text is like
object and dat difference is N64 and
wisell lower bound is float
64 okay so total missing
values so total missing values are like
uh one from here and one from here like
one in from reviewer name and other is
from reviewer
text and like there is no duplicated
values in our data
set and here you can see so like after
that quantiles a quantile defines a
particular part of the data set that is
a quantile determines how many values in
the distribution are above or below a
certain limit special quantiles are the
like quartile quarter and you can say
quintile that the fifth one and the
percentile which is from 100 okay so
quantile is for like
quarter or the you can say the fifth one
so why I wrote this 83 82 and this for
this purpose for making this something
look cool that is
why okay
and
yeah so moving
forward let's see unique values and in
each
column okay so I will write
Dev
check
CL dat
frame
unique FAL to PD dot
data
frame
variable
frame columns
comma
classes
colon data
frame
I I will write like an
unique
U
or I
in data
frame
columns okay like n
unique
[Music]
Q DF equals
to
sort
values
classes
ascending equals
to
false
okay n
unique underscore dfal to n
unique EF do
reset
index drop equals to
true return
and
unique qu and
unique go
BF check underscore class which one
DF so let me run this
first yeah it's running you can see
here okay there is an error classes
okay Jack class
DF is saying
that this
is okay C is capital c is
small let me run
now
yeah so here you can see the every
column having unique values are sorted
in descending order like review text
have like more unique values so it come
first and then reviewer name reviewer
time day difference Wilson lower bound
score average then goes to
overall okay moving forward let's do
some categorical variable analysis for
overall yes so this will be like a
amazing something amazing is going to be
happen
so constants equals to so I'm giving
here like some color values
so B3
4 d
22 e b 00 C okay so you can change you
can like write whatever you want
color hash oh I didn't write hashtag
here
hashtag three come
on
C 992
EB
z
c and then D you like five
right okay so DF let's make function
Okay small
DF
categorical
variable B okay DF
comma
column okay categorical variable summary
yeah perfect so let make some figures so
make
subplots
dos
rows equals
to
1 comma
calls = to
2 let me write from here like subplot
metals
to count
plot like one for
percentage
okay so specs
space equals
to okay like
type
colon
colon It's
why okay
same
type colon here
domain figure.
add and then
[Music]
Trace
dot
bar that one bar and one that P chart
okay y = to
DF
columns
name
value values do to list
forx you can L
string yeah St
Str
I or
I
in column
name do
value
counts
index
TT equals to
DF colum
name
value counts and then
bracket dot
values dot to
list
okay go for
text
font
the size should
be 14 is enough I
guess so
column M go
name
position so I'm doing for like making
chart
so stay with me to see that amazing
chart okay so show
Legend
color go to
constants so these are the like colors
so I'm giving here value like VAR
variable name
con
strs
line equals
to
it's
hashtag
DB
e 6
EC
just
one okay
small
okay let me just like go over
through everything is correct or not for
the column
name value count index yeah it's fine
text equals to DF column
name do value counts do values to to
list okay text font equals to T size
then okay for size is enough next name
equals to column name and text position
equals to
Auto and show Legend false and
Mark dict like color equals to constant
okay F line equals to color and this
yeah this okay
cool row = to 1 comma column equals to
one seems
good for pie chart we will make figure
do
add so this is done for the like line
chart not line chart that bar chart and
this I'm doing for the py chart okay
Trace go Dot
by y
columns column
name
value
is
use to
DF again that column
name
value
count
counts and Dot
values
text
font
T
size I will prefer 18 is
enough
exposition
like Auto is
fine so
Legend to no need of Legend
false m equals to column
name column name
let's do like d then
colorss to
constants
one one column = to two like in second
okay you will see and you will get to
know don't worry so figure dot
update
layout equals
to
colum
n
five
comma
X should be on
Center
then y
anchor be on
top let equals
to
shortly
okay I
plot
figure let me run this okay like call
equals to
two now let's see the chart of like
column overall one so we will write here
category
okay
variable
summary and then data frame name DF
comma
overall okay let's run
this okay it's loading here it's
loading
yeah you can see this is this is our bar
plot and this is our pie
chart
so like this is
overall uh from overall you can say that
column so like
percentage bar and that bar plot so this
is how our like pie chart and bar chart
looks like I hope you guys understand
till here if you have any questions or
any query regarding adding any code okay
like any code any sort of code so just
put as in comments our team will shortly
provide you the correct
solution so moving forward our goal is
to rank the com comments by the
sentiment analysis so we don't get hung
up on the other details I have sorted
this data set according to certain rules
before so moving forward we want to
clean our data so let's see the sample
data for cleaning so DF
dot
review
text okay dot
head let me run this so so this is how
sample data looks likees so let's see
like data full data for this okay let me
see
for what this I guess okay
or like any particular row you can say I
can take okay so I will write
review underscore
example
example equals to
DF
dot VI
view text uh I will take a random 2031
my
guys okay
so
review underscore
example so this is like at
2031 there is one review text okay so in
that the whole data is here like uh like
so my lovely wife bought me a Samsung
Galaxy Tab for father this this this
this like to find the exact model number
this is is a long you know comment I got
the this this this it works like a charm
okay
so after seeing this data what we going
to do is like we will clean it from
punctuation and numbers using Rex Rex
what regular expression okay so here I
will write review underscore
example example
okay
equals to R do
sub and what I will do
is okay I will explain don't worry small
L to capital
A A to Z okay comma then
space
comma review underscore
example
exam
but add
sorry
yeah give
you so here we used re for regular
expression
okay and so all the punctuation and
numbers are removed from particular
data so let me check
first okay this A to Z then A to Z okay
fine so like all the punctuation and
numbers are removed from particular data
I will now convert the text to all lower
case our machine learning algorithm
recognize words that start with the
capital letters as a different word and
we will convert them to lower case so
thus our machine learning algorithm will
not perceive words that start with a
capital letter as a different word so
what I will do is here I will write
review
sample
sample equals to G View
again
example
lower I will split
it
split
okay
example so here you can see we have
converted all the words in the lowercase
letter by using lower function and why
they are coming in new lines because we
are splitting them using split
function okay if you see only did lower
case for single row like we did for the
like 20 I guess 2 3 1 okay yeah so let's
make all row same in lower case so I
will write here RT equals to
Lambda
X
St
Str X
TF
view
text E capital
text
DF
view
text
text okay equals to
DF
view yeah do
lower we have do
head see all the data is in like lower
case so I printed just top 10 rows and
in like in reviews text column all the
are in the lower case now so I hope you
guys understand till here if you have
any question or any query regarding any
code or question till here like any code
just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
and if you need this full code you can
comment down below
okay so now the time is come to do
sentiment analysis because all the data
is
sorted so what will I write
here let me do it little bit up
yeah so I will write
from yeah from
Vader
sentiment
do
Vader
both
sentiment
intensity
analyzer
okay
have
polarity
subjectivity
subjectivity to
DF view
text
apply
PD do
Series yeah here you WR text
blob then again
text
Dot like
sentiment let me run for Loop for index
comma
Row in
DF G VI
text but
it
items
sentiment
density
analyzer
polarity
scores
row
netive
score
or neutral I will write
score if for
positive
if this is something crazy if negative
is greater than
positive then DF do
location
index
comma
sentiment equals
to
negative
netive okay
then
El
if positive is greater than
negative then in this case DF
DOT
log
index
comma
sentiment to
positive B
capital
else EF dot
LC
X
timent to
neutral
okay so like this is for sentimental
analysis and text
blob this thing like text blob this blob
okay it's
blob text blob will return polarity and
subjectivity polarity indicates your
mood that is whether it is positive or
negative or neutral it returns a value
between 0 and one the closer to one the
more positive and the closer to zero is
more negative okay let me run this it
will take a little bit time because this
sentiment okay it is getting error like
module Panda has no attribute series
okay which
One
texx
X
sentiment okay here what is the thing s
is
capital let me run
now it is
executing like fit for a while
wait so it will take time to run because
like because of this sentiment intensity
analyzer it take
times G sentiment
intensity analyzer okay spelling mistake
again why index index is not
defined
sorry
again
index it will run I guess because
everything seems
good negative positive and this
else
loading so I have to wait like for like
2 minutes more I
guess still loading
guys it take
time sentiment intensity
analyzer
so let me tell you again sentiment
analysis like this text
blob text blob will return polarity and
subjectivity so polarity indicates your
mood that is whether it is positive it
is negative or it is it will be neutral
it returns a value between 0 and 1 the
closer to one the more positive the
closer to Z more negative okay I guess
is
still
running so it will take time so let me
write code for that uh 20 interpretation
I repeat moving forward let's identify
the 20 interpretation now we can include
the positive negative and neutral status
of the command okay then
DF
sentiment equals to
positive
thought
lose
lower
sending equals to
false
okay dot
head it's
five if I will run it
may give errors to me because it's still
running still running here it's still
loading
so let let let me write code for that
unbalanced data problem so like we will
category that data into positive
negative and
neutral okay
so
categorical
variable
summary DF
ENT yeah it came like this because of
this wait I will tell
you yeah so here you can see the pie
chart distributed in negative positive
and neutral emotions okay or you can say
ratings and here you can see the bar
chart also
so and you can see the percentage
distributed in each like in positive
negative and neutral one so I hope you
guys must understood the concept of
sentiment analysis how we can implement
it using python if you're looking for a
course that covers everything from the
fundamentals to Advanced Techniques then
accelerate your career in Ai and machine
learning with a comprehensive
post-graduate programming Ai and machine
learning boost your career with this Ai
and ml course delivered in collaboration
with the Peru University and IBM learn
in demand skills such as machine
learning deep learning NLP computer
vision reinforcement learning generative
AI prompt engineering chat GPT and many
more you'll receive a prestigious
certificate and ask me anything sessions
by IBM with five cap stones in different
domains using real data sets you will
gain practical experience master classes
by PD faculty and IBM experts ensure
top-notch education simply learns job
assist help you get noticed by Leading
companies this program covers statistics
python supervised and unsupervised
learning NLP neural networks computer
vision G scas tensor flow and many more
such skills admission to this
post-graduate program in Ai and machine
learning requires a bachelor's degree
with an average of 50% or higher marks
along with the basic understanding of
programming Concepts and Mathematics and
candidates with two plus years of work
experience are preferred to enroll in
this scho so enroll now and unlock
exciting Ai and machine learning
opportunities the link is mentioned in
the description box below
Jupiter
notebook and press
enter this is the landing page of
jupyter notebook and it select open new
python file here we will go new python
file this is how the python G look
likees Jupiter python going to look like
so here first we will change the
name
WhatsApp
group okay
yes here first we will import some major
libraries first we will
import import R regular expression and
then
import
projects I will explain one by
one so don't worry
import
Hondas report
numai as
NP and the fifth one is
import
Express as
PX okay then from
collection
import
counter
okay and
import M
Li dot P
plot as
PLT okay this is for the
graph and
from
OS
import okay and the next one is from
p
import then this is the major One
Import
date
time and this one is the
important word
cloud
Port what
M top
wordss upwards and then
image
coloror okay then
person M plot
[Music]
Li
then press enter let's
see uh
collection should be
[Music]
collections from wordcloud import
wordcloud Stop words image color
generator yeah so cannot import name but
cloud
okay
sorry it should be
small okay so rest is fine so numai is a
python Library used for this one lpai is
a python Library used for working with
arrays it also has a functions for
working in the domain of Lan algebra and
matrices it is an open source project
and you can use it freely numai stand
for numerical Python and the panda panda
is a software Library written for the
Python programming language for data
manipulation and Analysis in particular
it offers data structure and operations
for manipulating numerical tables and
time
series this m plot lip P
plot so for Python and its numerical
extension number by met plot lip is a
crossplatform data visualization and
graphical charting package as a result
it represent
a strong open source substitute for
MPL the API application programming
interface format probably allow
programmers to incorporate graphs into
giu application okay then this re
regular
expression so a regular expression
specify a set of string that matches it
the function in this module let you
check if a particular string matches a
given regular expression or not or you
can say if if a given regular expression
matches a particular string which come
down to the same
thing okay then rex rex or regular
expression is a sequence of character
that forms a search platform okay or you
can say search pattern reg can be used
to check if a string contains the
specified search pattern or
not and this
PX okay plotly Express this plotly
Express module uses imported as PX
contains functions that can create
entire figure at once okay and is refers
to as a plotly Express or PX blly
Express is a built-in part of the daily
library
and it is recommended starting point for
creating the most common figures okay
then there is one more this counter
Library so the counter is a dict subass
for counting hashable objects it is a
collection where elements are stored as
a
directory keys and their counts are
stored as a dictionary values okay
counts are allowed to be any integer
value including zero or negative
counts okay then there is one more this
word cloud okay this is the kind of
major one to visualize
so not major one but it looks good at
the end you will see so word cloud is a
data visualization technique used for
representing Text data in the which size
of each word IND at its frequency or
importance significant tal data points
can be highlighted using wordcloud
wordclouds are widely used for analyzing
data from social network websites okay
then stop wordss a stop word is a
commonly used word such as the uh n in
that a search engine has been programmed
to ignore both indexing entries for
searching and when retrieving them as a
result in a search quer Okay so so let's
proceed further and create the various
function for the author for the date and
time for the get data time for the you
know data point for the Android and for
the iOS like things like that okay so
here I will addite
DF
starts
with
it
and
time
okay it starts with data and time
okay I will write here
pattern right pattern equal
to give
this I will write
here
okay 0 to 9
plus
right here
again these are for the numbers
okay
plus
M
okay or
M okay so result equals to R do
match if
result
done or else
okay let me give some space for the
better
visual
yeah so now we will find the author okay
we'll create function for the author
def
find
auor
okay then here I will write s equals to
dot
it
then of s was equals
okay uh
else
return
fals now what we we'll create a function
to get data point for the Android line
okay so here I will write
def
get data
point
right
9 and
date time equals to
split
line and date
comma time
= to date time do
split okay then
message equals
to dot join to like split line
wa
line
col
find
auor
which
let
message
split go to
split
Mage question
do
join
with
message
order
and 8
comma
comma so this is the uh for the getting
data point for the Android okay line
with
line this for the uh I will
like copy pasted and this is for the the
this one iOS okay so in this we are
doing the same like split line the same
we did for the you know Android
okay so moving forward we'll create a
function for the split
count
okay so for that to WR text here
that I can like
emoji
Lambda then
y then
again
English do
Keys okay
X to r
dot
compile I can write
join I Dot
Escape
em or
em
okay
emoji
xcore set dot find
all okay Enter
yeah so now we will import our data okay
so we will make a list to keep a track
of data so it can be used for the you
know Panda's data frame
and we we'll create a separate column
for the date Time author and messages
okay so the major thing is okay let's
import data first then I will tell
you okay so this is the list to keep a
track of data so it can be used for the
data frame Panda's data frame okay so I
will WR
Converse conversation
path so my file name is
WhatsApp
chat is
Captain get
B and placed
student
22 this is my
file so how you can export your chat
from your WhatsApp group okay so this is
the data this is my personal data so I
can't give you so how you can import
your text your chat okay so open any
group just click on the top right corner
okay three dots then you can go into
more and then you have can explore chat
including media and excluding media your
wish okay so you can download you can
send to the mail you can upload in the
drive then you can use in your machine
learning project okay so I will write
these all the steps in the description
box below so don't worry moving
forward let's
do open
conversation
coding equs to
UTF
eight then
device
question and
first to FP do
readline
print
first
if
or
else
Dev
to
and P dot read
line
message date comma time comma
author
n
message contain four things dat Time
author message okay so for the message
this is the message buffer and for
the there the DAT time and author okay
so
while
dot read
line
not
devices device equal to
iOS
strip it
and time iOS
F start with date time iOS line so here
I will
as
data
Dot okay so this is the
long it
here
so so what we did uh we created if devic
is IOS so the line history will come and
the function starts with date time and
iOS this one we created
already okay it will capture the date
Time author and message
okay then at the end the message buffer
will append okay for the
both okay this past data is for the we
created for the data frame Panda data
frame okay list so let's move and see
okay while
TR
okay start with pattern is not
defined Ern
pattern
so
okay data point Android line maybe the
spelling mistake as you can
see Point get data point Android a is
Capal
and this
is what line get data point
right me copy it from
here
copy and
P okay then let me run it
split line
okay split line split line is not
def okay let me get back to
you so as you can see everything is
sorted
so here you can see this is the group
name okay B and play
2022 and this is date and this is time
and this is the guy who created the
group
okay
okay so here I will write
if device plus equal to
[Music]
Android and dfal to
PD
dot data
frame
as
data columns equals
to
eight
[Music]
then
DF
dat I'm creating the columns PD do
to dat
time we
have
okay then
URL
are then
https
plus okay
so again I have ADD DF equals to for the
URL
count
pattern okay U should be
Capital comma
X erl
string
length
so is find then
else here we are like initializing the
data frame P data frame so DF equals to
PD
dot data
frame
data
[Music]
comma
columns
date
comma
time
my
yeah so this is the Pand data frame we
have
analized that DF = to DF do drop
menu
DF
date
and
apply
it
time
comma
format is year okay percentage
year
then okay and
url url pattern equals to
yes canot assign to
l
copy it and paste
it
running so now let's see the data set so
DF do head
20 okay first 20 rows of the data
frame as you can
see see uh this guy doctor uh something
read so uh he sent the message greetings
of all the DAT from this this this and
in this there is one
URL okay and this is the date and this
is time when he sent or when she sent
Okay so
this there are three links in this two
links okay is this related to placement
this guy send okay so these are the top
20 the number of links you can see in
the particular message 2 three and in
the 0 0 this is the media okay so I
downloaded uh the chat without media
okay you can chat can come using media
yeah let's see the
information
data so this is you can see we have five
column name date Time author message URL
account okay
soal count date time this is object and
this is object and URL count as
N64
okay let's see all the author names only
author names so here I will write DF
dot author dot
unique my
bad these are the authors all the
authors number of members you can say in
particular uh
group
okay the all are the unique authors so
moving forward let's see the you know
like let's drop all the null values so
for that we have to write DF do equals
to DF do drop
n
so top end is done then so these are the
some basic you can say the function of
machine learning and
python okay and moving forward let's see
the total messages
total
this to
DF do
shape to
print 87 total messages okay then media
messages
yeah
which
zero
print media
why this is zero I already told you like
I export chat without media okay so you
can export with media too
okay
so write here
URL
done
okay so this is the you can say the
reject pattern this one okay this is the
reject
pattern and with the start with the STD
https and the second one this this URL
count return URL which matches with
pattern and counts it through the all
the Lambda function okay now I will
write one more
thing to NP do
sum yeah
what uh this will do this is sum up all
the links okay so
print
links as you can see there are 47 links
in the group
chat okay so moving forward let's uh let
us separate and media messages and the
text message okay so this is
the is the code for that so link message
go to URL account
okay deleted messages and this message
was deleted okay both the statement and
this media omitted this image okay this
video for the video and the stickers you
send we send okay then the drop and
deleted message and the link message
okay so for that let's press enter
and
message d
F
dot okay so now you can see we deleted
dropped all the you can say the deleted
messages or the link messages okay as
you can see 87 now 56 only okay so
let's calculate words and letters
okay for that I have WR messages _
DF
then
account that
account equals to
messages
BF
and
message
can
okay I will write here
messages DF then word count
isore
DF
which
Dot
okay
messages EF
then message
count
one
okay so here you can see I wrote here
split so word count will be count as
like the space you can see space between
the words okay splitting sentence with
the white space you can say
okay let's
see Sage
DF
dot P 10 press
enter here I have to write
messages
yeah so now you can see this author send
this letter count 25 and the word count
is this and the message count is one
only so this package test dot things and
this is things this doctor Argent Hing
work from home kind of things and the
word letter count is 2011 then one count
31 okay and this is sometime hex of you
things and
okay so these are the words and letters
we
calculate okay now we will see the stats
of like author wise okay for that I will
write the code and we'll get back to you
after
that so this is the code for the you can
say
stats okay there's an error word
count where where where where
where
what message what
count okay so these are the all the
stats per user per author you can say
message sent and words per message and
media media sent is zero because like I
haven't you know included media in my
chat so that's why okay word per message
this and these all the stats you can see
and let me explain you the
code so this is for the like filtering
you know filtering out the message for
the particular
user this message DF message DF other
friends and for
this like rdf will contain messages of
only one particular user so we are
printing that okay
and this shape this one so uh shell will
print the number of rows which IND
thatly mean the number of
messages okay so this word count this
word count so word count contains all
the total words in one messages sum of
all the words divided by total message
will yield words words per message okay
so and this is for the media messages
this is zero and this is for the link
consist of the total links okay so this
is all the data so now moving forward
times of the day let's see the times of
the day so in which time the most
messages gone like this so
messages for
DF that
is
time dot
value
do paragraph Okay
horizontal okay then PLT do text
label
and pl.
yel 10 times of the day at which the
most number of message
sent okay this a top 10 uh uh okay so
because
of okay let me do like this now it's
good time a number of messages okay this
is
it what I can do
this number of messages and the top 10
times most number of message now the
time is came to see the word cloud
okay now we'll make the word cloud so
for that I will let me
give
text
join join you can say
review
print this much
words all
the
okay dot
format be
length and then stop
wordss one of my
favorite
set stop
words then we'll generate the world
Cloud this is to generate the World
Cloud okay sorry word
cloud
upwards
backround
white
do so we'll display the generated image
and the pl uh using the You Know M
plotly way so pl.
figure
SI
equals
to set it
bilinear by linear and then L do
XIs
lt.
show stop words and
rate can see there are 9 to 35 words in
all the messages so these are the sums
like Gmail password pressure and this
ready test email and this is
student and see something like this
these are the world Cloud okay so what
if I want to see the particular author
name World cloud like how many messes he
sent and all like this so this is the
doctor okay I took from
here see Dr Reda and this Shand do
something and this you can take the
number also no
issues so let's
see this is author Dr Rapa he sent
hiring job gen fresher student and this
is Anusha ready join and same the Chand
ready join okay so this is how you can
analyze and you can
see data uh you can analyze your
whatsappp data okay I will add all the
you know steps how to you how you can
explore the chat if you're looking for a
course that covers everything from the
fundamentals to Advanced Techniques then
accelerate your career in Ai and machine
learning with a comprehensive
post-graduate program in Ai and machine
learning boost your career with this Ai
and ml course delivered in collaboration
with the perdu university and IBM learn
in demand skills such as machine
learning deep learning NLP computer
vision reinforcement learning generative
AI prompt engineering chat GPD and many
more you'll receive a prestigious
certificate and ask me anything sessions
by IBM with five capstones in different
domains using real data sets you will
gain practical experience master classes
by P faculty and IBM experts ensure
top-notch education simply learns job
assist help you get noticed by Leading
companies this program covers statistics
python supervised and unsupervised
learning NLP neural networks computer
vision G scas tensorflow and many more
suchar skills admission to this
post-graduate program in Ai and machine
learning requires a bachelor's degree
with an average of 50% or higher marks
along with the basic understanding of
programming Concepts and Mathematics and
candidates with two plus years of work
experience are preferred to enroll in
this school so enroll now and unlock
exciting Ai and machine learning
opportunities the link is mentioned in
the description box below hello everyone
welcome to the session I'm Mohan from
Simply learn and today we'll talk about
interview questions for machine learning
now this video will probably help you
when you're attending interviews for
machine learning positions and the
attempt here is to probably consolidate
30 most commonly asked uh questions and
to help you in answering these questions
we tried our best to give you the best
possible answers but of course what is
more important here is rather than the
theoretical knowledge you need to kind
of add to the answers or supplement your
answers with your own experience so the
responses that we put here are a bit
more generic in nature so that if there
are some Concepts that you are not clear
this video will help you in kind of
getting those Concepts cleared up as
well but what is more important is that
you need to supplement these responses
resp es with your own practical
experience okay so with that let's get
started so one of the first questions
that you may face is what are the
different types of machine learning now
what is the best way to respond to this
there are three types of machine
learning if you read any material you
will always be told there are three
types of machine learning but what is
important is you would probably be
better of emphasizing that there are
actually two main types of learning
which is supervised and unsupervised and
then there is a third type which is
reinforcement learning so supervised
learning is where you have some
historical data and then you feed that
data to your model to learn now you need
to be aware of a keyword that they will
be looking for which is labeled data
right so if you just say pass data or
historical data the impact may not be so
much you need to emphasize on labeled
data so what is labeled data basically
let's say if you're trying to do train
your model for classification you need
to be aware of for your existing data
which class each of the observations
belong to right so that is what is
labeling so it is nothing but a fancy
name you must be already aware but just
make it a point to throw in that keyword
labeled so that will have the right
impact okay so that is what is
supervised learning when you have
existing labeled data which you then use
to train your model that is known as
supervised learning and unsupervised
learning is when you don't have this
labeled data so you have data it is not
labeled so the system has to figure out
a way to do some analysis on this okay
so that is unsupervised learning and you
can then add a few things like what what
are the ways of Performing uh supervised
learning and unsupervised learning or
what are some of the techniques so
supervised learning we we perform we do
uh regression and classification and
unsupervised learning uh we do
clustering okay and clustering can be of
different types similarly regression can
be of different types but you don't have
to probably elaborate so much if they
are asking uh for uh just the different
types you can just mention these and
just at a very high level you can but if
they want you to elaborate give examples
then of course I think there is a
different question for that we will see
that later then the third so we have
supervised and we have supervised and
then reinforcement you need to provide a
little bit of information around that as
well because it is sometimes a little
difficult to come up with a good
definition for reinforcement learning so
you may have to little bit elaborate on
how reinforcement learning works right
so reinforcement learning works in in
such a way that it basically has two
parts to it one is the agent and the
environment and the agent basically is
working inside of this environment and
it is given a Target that it has to
achieve and and uh every time it is
moving in the direction of the target so
the agent basically has to take some
action and every time it takes an action
which is moving uh the agent towards the
Target right towards a goal a Target is
nothing but a goal okay then it is
rewarded and every time it is going in a
direction where it is away from the goal
then it is punished so that is the way
you can a little bit explain and uh this
is used Prim or very very impactful for
teaching the system to learn games and
so on examples of this are basically
used in alphao you can throw that as an
example where alphao used reinforcement
learning to actually learn to play the
game of Go and finally it defeated the
co world champion all right this much of
information that would be good enough
okay then there could be a question on
overfitting uh so the question could be
what is overfitting and how can you
avoid it so what is overfitting so let's
first try to understand the concept
because sometimes overfitting may be a
little difficult to understand
overfitting is a situation where the
model has kind of memorized the data so
this is an equivalent of memorizing the
data so we can draw an analogy so that
it becomes easy to explain this now
let's say you're teaching a child about
some recognizing some fruits or
something like that okay and you're
teaching this child about recognizing
let's say three fruits apples oranges
and pineapples okay so this is a a small
child and for the first time you're
teaching the child to recognize fruits
then so what will happen so this is very
much like that is your training data set
so what you will do is you'll take a
basket of fruits which consists of
apples oranges and pineapples okay and
you take this basket to this child and
uh there may be let let's say hundreds
of these fruits so you take this basket
to this child and keep showing each of
this fruit and then first time obviously
the child will not know what it is so
you show an apple and you say hey this
is Apple then you show maybe an orange
and say this is orange and so on and so
and then again you keep repeating that
right so till the basket is over this is
basically how training work in machine
learning also that's how training works
so till the basket is completed maybe
100 fruits you keep showing this child
and then the process has happened the
child has pretty much memorized these so
even before you finish that basket right
by the time you are halfway through the
child has learned about recognizing the
Apple orange and pineapple now what will
happen after halfway through initially
you remember it made mistakes in
recognizing but halfway through now it
has learned so every time you show a
fruit it will exactly 100% accurately it
will identify it will say the child will
say this is an apple this is an orange
and if you show a pineapple it will say
this is a pineapple right so that means
it has kind of memorized this data now
let's say you bring another basket of
fruits and it will have a mix of maybe
apples which were already there in the
previous set but it will also have in
addition to Apple it will probably have
a banana or maybe another fruit like a
jack fruit right so this is an
equivalent of your test data set which
the child has not seen before some parts
of it it probably has seen like apples
it has seen but this banana and jack
fruit it has not seen so then what will
happen in the first round which is an
equivalent of your training data set
towards the end it has 100% it was
telling you what the fruits are right
Apple was accurately recognized orange
were was accurately recognized and
pineapples were accurately recognized
right so that is like a 100% accuracy
but now when you get another a fresh set
which were not a part of the original
one what will happen all the apples
Maybe it will be able to recognize
correctly but all the others like the
jack fruit or the banana will not be
recognized by the child right so this is
an analogy this is an equivalent of
overfitting so what has happened during
the training process it is able to
recognize or reach 100% accuracy maybe
very high accuracy okay and we call that
as very low loss right so that is the
technical term so the loss is pretty
much zero and accuracy is pretty much
100% whereas when you use testing the
will be a huge error which means the
loss will be pretty high and therefore
the accuracy will be also low okay this
is known as overfitting this is
basically a process where training is
done training process is it goes very
well almost reaching 100% accuracy but
while testing it really drops down now
how can you avoid it so that is a
extension of this question there are
multiple ways of avoiding overfitting
there are techniques like what do you
call regularization that is the most
most common technique that is used uh
for avoiding overfitting and within
regularization there can be a few other
subtypes like Dropout in case of neural
networks and a few other examples but I
think if you give example or if you give
regularization as the technique probably
that should be sufficient so so there
will be some questions where the
interviewer will try to test your
fundamentals and your knowledge and
depth of knowledge knowled and so on and
so forth and then there will be some
questions which are more like trick
questions that will be more to stump you
okay then the next question is around
the methodology so when we are
performing machine learning training we
split the data into training and test
right so this question is around that so
the question is what is training set and
test set in machine learning model and
how is the split done so the question
can be like that so in machine learning
when we are trying to train the model so
we have a three-step process we train
the model and then we test the model and
then once we are satisfied with the test
only then we deploy the model so what
happens in the train and test is that
you remember the labeled data so let's
say you have thousand records with
labeling information now one way of
doing it is you use all the Thousand
records for training and then maybe
right which means that you have exposed
all this thousand records during the
training process and then you take a
small set of the same data and then you
say okay I will test it with this okay
and then you probably what will happen
you may get some good results all right
but there is a flaw there what is the
flaw this is very similar to human
beings it is like you are showing this
model the entire data as a part of
training okay so obviously it has become
familiar with the entire data so when
you're taking a part of that again and
you're saying that I want to test it
obviously you will get good results so
that is not a very accurate way of
testing so that is the reason what we do
is we have the label data of this
thousand records or whatever we set
aside before starting the training
process we set aside a portion of that
data and we call that test set and the
remaining we call as training set and we
use only this for training our model now
the training process remember is not
just about passing one round of this
data set so let's say now your training
set has 800 records it is not just one
time you pass this 800 records what you
normally do is you actually as a part of
the training you may pass this data
through the model multiple times so this
thousand records may go through the
model maybe 10 15 20 times till the
training is perfect till the accuracy is
high till the errors are minimized okay
now so which is fine which means that
here that is what is is known as the
model has seen your data and gets
familiar with your data and now when you
bring your test data what will happen is
this is like some new data because that
is where the real test is now you have
trained the model and now you are
testing the model with some data which
is kind of new that is like a situation
like like a realistic situation because
when the model is deployed that is what
will happen it will receive some new
data not the data that it has already
seen right so this is a realistic test
so you put some new data so this dat
which you have set aside is for the
model it is new and if it is able to
accurately predict the values that means
your training has worked okay the model
got drained properly but let's say while
you're testing this with this test data
you're getting a lot of errors that
means you need to probably either change
your model or retrain with more data and
things like that now coming back to the
question of how do you split this what
should be the ratio there is no fixed uh
number again this is like individual
preference
some people split it into 50/50 50% test
and 50% training Some people prefer to
have a larger amount for training and a
smaller amount for test so they can go
by either 6040 or 7030 or some people
even go with some odd numbers like
6535 or uh 6333 and 33 which is like 1/3
and 2/3 so there is no fixed rule that
it has to be something the ratio has to
be this you can go by your individual
preferences all right then you may have
questions around uh data handling data
manipulation or what do you call data
management or Preparation so these are
all some questions around that area
there is again no one answer one single
good answer to this it really varies
from situation to situation and
depending on what exactly is the problem
what kind of data it is how critical it
is what kind of data is missing and what
is the type of corruption so there a
whole lot of things this is a very
generic question and therefore you need
to be little careful about responding to
this as well so probably have to
illustrate this again if you have
experience in doing this kind of work in
handling data you can illustrate with
example saying that I was on one project
where I received this kind of data these
were the columns where data was not
filled or these were the this many rows
where the data was missing that would be
in fact a perfect way to respond to this
question but if if you don't have that
obviously you have to provide some good
answer I think it really depends on what
exactly the situation is and there are
multiple ways of handling the missing
data or corrupt data now let's take a
few examples now let's say you have data
where some values in some of the columns
are missing and you have pretty much
half of your data having these missing
values in terms of number of rows okay
that could be one situation another
situation could be that you have records
or data missing but uh when you do some
initial calculation how many records are
corrupt or how many rows or observations
as we call it has this missing data
let's assume it is very minimal like 10%
okay now between these two cases how do
you so let's assume that this is not a
mission critical situation and in order
to fix this 10% of the data the effort
that is required is much higher and
obviously effort means also time and
money right so it is not so Mission
critical and it is okay to let's say get
rid of these records so obviously one of
the easiest ways of handling the data
part or missing data is remove those
records or remove those observations
from your analysis so that is the
easiest way to do but then the downside
is as I said in as in the first case if
let's say 50% of your data is like that
because some column of the other is
missing so it is not like every in every
place in every Row the same column is
missing but you have in maybe 10% of the
records column one is missing and
another 10% column two is missing
another 10% column 3 is missing and so
on and so forth so it adds up to maybe
half of your data set so you cannot
completely remove half of your data set
then the whole purpose is lost okay so
then how do you handle then you need to
come up with ways of filling up this
data with some meaningful value right
that is one way of handling so when we
say meaningful value what is that
meaningful value let's say for a
particular column you might want to take
a mean value for that column and fill
wherever the data is missing fill up
with that mean value so that when you're
doing the calculations your analysis is
not completely we off so you have values
which are not missing first of all so
your system will work number two these
values are not so completely out of
whack that your whole analysis goes for
a toss right there may be situations
where if the missing values instead of
putting mean maybe a good idea to fill
it up with the minimum value or with a
zero so or with the maximum value again
as I said there are so many
possibilities so there is no like one
correct answer for this you need to
basically talk around this and
illustrate with your experience as I
said that would be the best otherwise
this is how you need to handle this
question okay so then the next question
can be how can you choose a classifier
based on a training set data size so
again this is one of those questions uh
where you probably do not have like one
size fits all on first of all you may
not let's say decide your classifier
based on the training set size maybe not
the best way to decide the type of the
classifier and uh even if you have to
there are probably some thumb rules
which we can use but then again every
time so in my opinion the best way to
respond to this question is you need to
try out few classifiers irrespective of
the size of the data and you need need
to then decide on your particular
situation which of these classifiers are
the right ones this is a very generic
issue so you will never be able to just
by if somebody defines a a problem to
you and somebody even if if they show
the data to you or tell you what is the
data or even the size of the data I
don't think there is a way to really say
that yes this is the classifier that
will work here no that's not the right
way so you need to still uh you know
test it out get the data try out a
couple of classifiers and then only you
will be in a position to decide which
classifier to use you try out multiple
classifiers see which one gives the best
accuracy and only then you can decide
then you can have a question around
confusion Matrix so the question can be
explain confusion Matrix right so
confusion Matrix I think the best way to
explain it is by taking an example and
drawing like a small diagram otherwise
it can really become tricky so my
suggestion is to take a piece of pen and
paper and uh explain it by drawing a
small Matrix and confusion Matrix is
about to find out this is used
especially in classification uh learning
process and when you get the results
when the our model predicts the results
you compare it with the actual value and
try to find out what is the accuracy
okay so in this case let's say this is
an example of a confusion Matrix and uh
it is a binary Matrix so you have the
actual values which is the labeled data
right and which is so you have how many
yes and how many no so you have that
information and you have the predicted
values how many yes and how many no
right so the total actual values the
total yes is 12 + 1 13 and they are
shown here and the actual value NOS are
9 + 3 12 okay so that is what this
information here is so this is about the
actual and this is is about the
predicted similarly the predicted values
there are yes are 12 + 3 15 yeses and no
are 1 + 9 10 NOS okay so this is the way
to look at this confusion Matrix okay
and out of this what is the meaning
conveyed so there are two or three
things that needs to be explained
outright the first thing is for a model
to be accurate the values across the
diagonal should be high like in this
case right that is one number two the
the total sum of these values is equal
to the total observations in the test
data set so in this case for example you
have 12 + 3 15 + 10 25 so that means we
have 25 observations in our test data
set okay so these are the two things you
need to First explain that the total sum
in this Matrix the numbers is equal to
the size of the test data set and the
diagonal values indicate the accuracy so
by just by looking at it you can
probably have a idea about is this uh an
accurate model is the model being
accurate if they're all spread out
equally in all these four boxes that
means probably the accuracy is not very
good okay now how do you calculate the
accuracy itself right how do you
calculate the accuracy itself so it is a
very simple mathematical calculation you
take some of the diagonals right so in
this case it is 9 + 12 21 and divide it
by the total so in this case what will
it be let's me uh take a so your your
diagonal values is equal to if I say d
is equal to 12 + 9 so that is 21 right
and the total data set is equal to right
we just calculated it is 25 so what is
your accuracy it is 21 by your accuracy
is equal to 21 by 25 and this turns out
to be about
85% right so this is 85% so that is our
accuracy okay so this this is the way
you need to explain draw a diagram Give
an example and maybe it may be a good
idea to be prepared with an example so
that it becomes easy for you don't have
to calculate those numbers on the fly
right so couple of uh hints are that you
take some numbers which are with which
add up to 100 that is always a good idea
so you don't have to really do this
complex calculations so the total value
will be 100 and then diagonal values you
divide once you find the diagonal values
that is equal to your percentage okay
all right so the next question can be a
related question about false positive
and false negative so what is false
positive and what is false negative now
once again the best way to explain this
is using a piece of paper and Pen
otherwise it will be pretty difficult to
to explain this so we use the same
example of the confusion Matrix and uh
we can explain that so A confusion
Matrix looks somewhat like this and um
when we just take yeah it look somewhat
like this and we continue with the
previous example where this is the
actual value this is the predicted value
and uh in the actual value we have 12 +
1 13 yeses and 3 + 9 12 Nos and the
predicted values there are 12 + 3 15
yeses and uh 1 + 9 10 NOS okay now this
particular case which is the false
positive what is a false positive first
of all the second word which is positive
okay is referring to the predicted value
so that means the system has predicted
it as a positive but the real value so
this is what the false comes from but
the real value is not positive okay that
is the way you should understand this
term false positive or even false
negative so false positive so positive
is what your system has predicted so
where is that system predicted this is
the one positive is what yes so you
basically consider this row okay now if
you consider this row so this is this is
all positive values this entire row is
positive values okay now the false
positive is the one which where the
value actual value is negative predicted
value is positive but the actual value
is negative so this is a false positive
right and here is a true positive so the
predicted value is positive and the
actual value is also positive okay I
hope this is making sense now let's take
a look at what is false negative false
negative so negative is the second term
that means that is the predicted value
that we need to look for so which are
the predicted negative values this row
corresponds to predicted negative values
all right so this row corresponds to
predicted negative values and what they
are asking for false so this is the row
for predicted negative values and the
actual value is this one right this is
predicted negative and the actual value
is also negative therefore this is a
true negative so the false negative is
this one predicted is negative but
actual is positive right so this is the
false negative so this is the way to
explain and this is a way to look at
false positive and false negative same
way there can be true positive and true
negative as well so again positive the
second term you will need to use to
identify the predicted row right so if
we say true positive positive you need
to take for the predicted part so
predicted positive is here okay and then
the first term is for the actual so true
positive so true in case of actual is
yes right so true positive is this one
okay and then in case of actual the
negative now we are talking about let's
say true negative true negative negative
is this one and the true comes from here
so this is true negative right nine is
true negative the actual value is also
negative and the predicted value is also
negative okay so that is the way you
need to explain this the terms false
positive false negative and true
positive true negative then uh you might
have a question like what are the steps
involved in the machine learning process
or what are the three steps in the
process of developing uh machine
learning model right so it is around the
methodology that is applied so basically
the way you can probably answer in your
own words but the way the model
development of the machine learning
model happens is like this so first of
all you try to understand the problem
and try to figure out whether it is a
classification problem or a regression
problem based on that you select a few
algorithms and then you start the
process of training these models okay so
you can either do that or you can after
due diligence you can probably decide
that there is one particular algorithm
that which is most suitable usually it
happens through trial and error process
but at some point you will decide that
okay this is the model we are going to
use okay okay so in that case we have
the model algorithm and the model
decided and then you need to do the
process of training the model and
testing the model and this is where if
it is supervised learning you split your
data the label data into training data
set and test data set and you use the
training data set to train your model
and then you use the test data set to
check the accuracy whether it is working
fine or not so you test the model before
you actually put it into production
right so once you test the model you're
satisfied it's working fine then you go
to the next level which is putting it
for production and then in production
obviously new data will come and uh the
inference happens so the model is
readily available and only thing that
happens is new data comes and the model
predicts the values whether it is
regression or classification now so this
can be an iterative process so it is not
a straightforward process where you do
the training do the testing and then you
move it to production now so during the
training and test process process there
may be a situation where because of
either overfitting or or things like
that the test doesn't go through which
means that you need to put that back
into the training process so that can be
an iterative process not only that even
if the training and test goes through
properly and you deploy the model in
production there can be a situation that
the data that actually comes the real
data that comes with that this model is
failing so in which case you may have to
once again go back to the drawing board
or initially it will be working fine but
over a period of time maybe due to the
change in the nature of the data once
again the accuracy will deteriorate so
that is again a recursive process so
once in a while you need to keep
checking whether the model is working
fine or not and if required you need to
tweak it and modify it and so on and so
forth so net net this is a continuous
process of um tweaking the model and
testing it and making sure it is up to
dat then you might have question around
deep learning so because deep learning
is now asso assciated with AI artificial
intelligence and so on so can be as
simple as what is deep learning so I
think the best way to respond to this
could be deep learning is a part of
machine learning and then then obviously
the the question would be then what is
the difference right so deep learning
you need to mention there are two key
parts that interviewer will be looking
for when you're defining deep learning
so first is of course deep learning is a
subset of machine learning so machine
learning is still the bigger let's say
say uh scope and deep learning is one
one part of it so then what exactly is
the difference deep learning is
primarily when we are implementing these
our algorithms or when we are using
neural networks for doing our training
and classification and regression and
all that right so when we use neural
network then it is considered as deep
learning and the term deep comes from
the fact that you can have several
layers of neural networks and these are
called deep neural networks and
therefore the term deep you know deep
learning uh the other difference between
machine learning and deep learning which
the interviewer may be wanting to hear
is that in case of machine learning the
feature engineering is done manually
what do we mean by feature engineering
basically when we are trying to train
our model we have our training data
right so we have our training label data
and uh this data has several let's say
if it is a regular table it has several
columns now each of these columns
actually has information about a feature
right so if we are trying to predict the
height weight and so on and so forth so
these are all features of human beings
let's say we have sensus data and we
have all these so those are the features
now there may be probably 50 or 100 in
some cases there may be 100 such
features now all of them do not
contribute to our model right so we as a
data scientist we have to decide whether
we should take all of them all the
features or we should throw away some of
them because again if we take all of
them number one of course your accuracy
will probably get affected but also
there is a computational part so if you
have so many features and then you have
so much data it becomes very tricky so
in case of machine learning we manually
take care of identifying the features
that do not contribute to the learning
process and thereby we eliminate those
features and so on right so this is
known as feature engineering and in
machine learning we do that manually
whereas in deep learning where we use
neural networks the model will
automatically determine which features
to use and which to not use and
therefore feature engineering is also
done automatically so this is a
explanation these are two key things
probably will add value to your response
all right so the next question is what
is the difference between or what are
the differences between machine learning
and deep learning so here this is a a
quick comparison table between machine
learning and deep learning and in
machine learning learning enables
machines to take decisions on their own
based on past data so here we are
talking primity of supervised learning
and um it needs only a small amount of
data for training and then works well on
lowend system so you don't need large
machines and most features need to be
identified in advance and manually coded
so basically the feature engineering
part is done manually and uh the problem
is divided into parts and solved
individually and then combined so that
is about the machine learning part in
deep learning deep learning basically
enables machines to take decisions with
the help of artificial neural network so
here in deep learning we use neural so
that is the key differentiator between
machine learning and deep learning and
usually deep learning involves a large
amount of data and therefore the
training also requires usually the
training process requires high-end
machines uh because it needs a lot of
computing power and and the Machine
learning features are or the feature
engineering is done automatically so the
neural networks takes care of doing the
feature engineering as well and in case
of deep learning therefore it is said
that the problem is handled end to end
so this is a quick comparison between
machine learning and deep learning in
case you have that kind of a question
then you might get a question around the
uses of machine learning or some real
life applications of machine learning in
modern business the question May be
worded in different ways but the the
meaning is how exactly is machine
learning used or actually supervised
machine learning it could be a very
specific question around supervised
machine learning so this is like give
examples of supervised machine learning
use of supervised machine learning in
modern business so that could be the
next question so there are quite a few
examples or quite a few use cases if you
will for supervised machine learning the
very common one is email spam detection
so you want to train your application or
your system to detect between spam and
non-spam so this is a very common
business application of supervised
machine learning so how does this work
the way it works is that you obviously
have historical data of your emails and
they are categorized as spam and not
spam so that is what is the labeled
information and then you feed this
information or the all the these emails
as an input to your model right and the
model will then get trained to detect
which of the emails are to detect which
is Spam and which is not spam so that is
the training process and this is
supervised machine learning because you
have label data you already have emails
which are tagged as spam or not spam and
then you use that to train your model
right so this is one example now there
are a few industry specific applications
for supervised machine learning one of
the very common ones is in healthcare
Diagnostics in healthcare Diagnostics
you have these images and you want to
train models to detect whether from a
particular image whether it can find out
if the person is sick or not whether a
person has cancer or not right so this
is a very good example of supervised
machine learning here the way it works
is that existing images it could be
x-ray images it be MRI or any of these
images are available and they are tacked
saying that okay this x-ray image is
defective of the person has an illness
or it could be cancer whichever illness
right so it is tacked as defective or
clear or good image and defective
something like that so we come up with
the binary or it could be multiclass as
well saying that this is defective to
10% this is 25% and so on but let's keep
it simple you can give an example of
just a binary classification that would
be good enough so you can say that in
healthcare Diagnostics using image we
need to detect whether a person is ill
or whether a person is having cancer or
not so here the way it works is you feed
labeled images and you allow the model
to learn from that so that when New
Image is fed it will be able to predict
whether this person is having that
illness or not having cancer or not
right so I think this would be a very
good example for supervised machine
learning in modern business all right
then we can have a question like so
we've been talking about supervised and
um unsupervised then so there can be a
question around semi-supervised machine
learning so what is semi-supervised
machine learning now semi-supervised
learning as the name suggests it falls
between supervised learning and
unsupervised learning but for all
practical purposes it is considered as a
part of supervised learning and the
reason this has come into existence is
that in supervised learning you need
labeled data so all your data for
training your model has to be labeled
now this is a big problem in many
Industries or in many under many
situations getting the label data is not
that easy because there's a lot of
effort in labeling this data let's take
an example of the diagnostic images we
can just let's say take X-ray images now
there are actually millions of x-ray
images available all over the world but
the problem is they are not labeled so
the images are there but whether it is
effective or whether it is good that
information is not available along with
it right in a form that it can be used
by a machine which means that somebody
has to take a look at these images and
usually it should be like a doctor and
uh then say that okay yes this image is
clean and this image is cancerous and so
on and so forth now that is a huge
effort by itself so this is where
semi-supervised learning comes into play
so what happens is there is a large
amount of data maybe a part of it is
labeled then we try some techniques to
label the remaining part of the data so
that we get completely labeled data and
then we train our model so I know this a
little long winding explanation but
unfortunately there is no a quick and
easy definition for semi-supervised
machine learning this is the only way
probably to explain this concept we may
have another question as um what are
unsupervised machine learning techniques
or what are some of the techniques used
for performing unsupervised machine
learning so it can be worded in
different ways so how do we answer this
question so unsupervised learning you
can say that there are two types
clustering and Association and
clustering is a technique where similar
objects are put together and there are
different ways of finding similar
objects so their characteristics can be
measured and if they have in most of the
characteristics if they are similar then
they can be put together this is
clustering then Association you can I
think the best way to explain
Association is with an example in case
of Association you try to find out how
the items are linked to each other so
for example if somebody bought a maybe a
laptop the person has also purchased a
mouse so this is more in an e-commerce
scenario for example so you can give
this as an example so people who are
buying laptops are also buying the mouse
so that means there is an association
between laptops and mouse or maybe
people who are buying bread are also
buying butter so that is a Association
that can be created so this is
unsupervised learning one of the
techniques okay all right then we have
very fundamental question question what
is the difference between supervised and
unsupervised machine learning so machine
learning these are the two main types of
machine learning supervised and unised
and in case of supervised and again here
probably the keyword that the person may
be wanting to hear is labeled data now
very often people say yeah we have
historical data and if we run it it is
supervised and if we don't have
historical data yes but you may have
historical data but if it is not labeled
then you cannot use it for supervised
Lear so it is it's very key to
understand that we put in that keyword
labeled okay so when we have labeled
data for training our model then we can
use supervised learning and if we do not
have labeled data then we use
unsupervised learning and there are
different algorithms available to
perform both of these types of uh
trainings so there can be another
question a little bit more theoretical
and conceptual in nature this is this is
about inductive machine learning and
deductive machine learning so the
question can be what is the difference
between inductive machine learning and
deductive machine learning or somewhat
in that manner so that the exact phrase
or exact question can vary they can ask
for examples and things like that but
that could be the question so let's
first understand what is inductive and
deductive training inductive training is
induced by somebody and you can
illustrate that with a small example I
think that always helps so whenever
you're doing some explanation try as
much as possible as I said to give
examples from your work experience or
give some analogies and that will also
help a lot in explaining as well and for
the interviewer also to understand so
here we'll take an example or rather we
will use an analogy so inductive
training is when we induce some
knowledge or the learning process into a
person without the person actually
experiencing it okay what can be an
example so we can probably probably tell
the person or show a person a video that
fire can burn the fing burn his finger
or fire can cause damage so what is
happening here this person has never
probably seen a fire or never seen
anything getting damaged by fire but
just because he has seen this video he
knows that okay fire is dangerous and if
fire can cause damage right so this is
inductive learning compared to that what
is deductive itive learning so here you
draw conclusion or the person draws
conclusion out of experience so we will
stick to the analogy so compared to the
showing a video Let's assume a person is
allowed to play with fire right and then
he figures out that if he puts his
finger it's burning or if throws
something into the fire it burns so he
is learning through experience so this
is known as deductive learning okay so
you can have applications or models that
can be trained using inductive learning
or deductive learning all right I think
uh probably that explanation will be
sufficient the next question is are KNN
and K means clustering similar to one
another or are they same right because
that the letter K is kind of common
between them okay so let us take a
little while to understand what these
two are one is KNN and another is kin K
stands for K nearest neighbors and K
means of course is the cluster mechanism
now these two are completely different
except for the letter K being common
between them K andn is completely
different K means clustering is
completely different K&N is a
classification process and therefore it
comes under supervised learning whereas
K means clustering is actually a
unsupervised okay when you have K andn
when you want to implement KN andn which
is basically K nearest neighbors the
value of K is a number so so you can say
k is equal to 3 you want to implement KN
andn with K is equal to 3 so which means
that it performs the classification in
such a way that how does it perform the
classification so it will take three
nearest objects and that's why it's
called nearest neighbor so basically
based on the distance it will try to
find out its nearest objects that are
let's say three of the nearest objects
and then it will check whether the class
they belong to which class right so if
all three belong to one particular class
obviously this new object is also
classified as that particular class but
it is possible that they may be from two
or three different classes okay so let's
say they are from two classes and then
if they are from two classes now usually
you take a odd number you assign odd
number to so if there are three of them
and two of them belong to one class and
then one belongs to another class so
this new object is assigned to the class
to which the two of them belong now the
value of K is sometimes tricky whether
should you use three should you use five
should you use seven that can be tricky
because the ultimate classification can
also vary so it's possible that if
you're taking K as three the object is
probably in one particular class but if
you take K is equal to five maybe the
object will belong to a different class
because when you're taking three of them
probably two of them belong to class one
and one belong to class two whereas when
you take five of them it is possible
that only two of them belong to class
one and three of them belong to class
two so which means that this object will
belong to class two right so you see
that so is the class allocation can vary
depending on the value of K now K means
on the other hand is a clustering
process and it is unsupervised where
what it does is the system will
basically identify how the objects are
how close the objects are with respect
to some of their features okay and but
the similarity of course is the the
letter K and in case of K means also we
specify its value and it could be three
or five or seven there is no technical
limit as such but it can be any number
of clusters that uh you can create okay
so based on the value that you provide
the system will create that many
clusters of similar objects so there is
a similarity to that extent that K is a
number in both the cases but actually
these two are completely different
processes we have what is known as KN
based classifier and and people often
get confused thinking that knive base is
the name of the person who found this uh
classifier or who developed this
classifier which is not 100% true base
is the name of the person b y s is the
name of the person but naive is not the
name of the person right so naive is
basically an English word and that has
been added here because of the nature of
this particular classifier na based
classifier is a probability based
classifier and uh it it makes some
assumptions that presence of one feature
of a class is not related to the
presence of any other feature of maybe
other classes right so which is not a
very strong or not a very what do you
say accurate assumption because these
features can be related and so on but
even if you go with this assumption this
whole algorithm works very well even
with this assumption and uh that is the
good side of it but the term comes from
there so that is the explanation that
you can give then there can be question
around reinforcement learning it can be
paraphrased in multiple ways one could
be can you explain how a system can play
a game of chess using reinforcement
learning or it can be any game so the
best way to explain this is again to
talk a little bit about what
reinforcement learning is about and then
elaborate on that to explain the process
so first of all reinforcement learning
as an environment and an agent and the
agent is basically performing some
action in order to achieve a certain
goal and these goals can be anything
either if it is related to game then the
goal could be that you have to score
very high score a high value High number
or it could be that your uh number of
lives should be as high as possible
don't lose lives so these could be some
of them more advanced examples could be
for driving in the automotive industry
self-driving cars they actually also
make use of reinforcement learning to
teach teach the car how to navigate
through the roads and so on and so forth
that is also another example now how
does it work so if the system is
basically there is an agent and
environment and every time the agent
takes a step or performs a task which is
taking it towards the goal the final
goal let's say to maximize the score or
to minimize the number of lives and so
on or minimize the deaths for example it
is rewarded and every time it takes a
step which goes against that goal right
contrary or in the reverse Direction it
is penalized okay so it is like a carrot
and stick system now how do you use this
to create a game of chess or to create a
system to play a game of chess now the
way this works is and this could
probably go back to this alphago example
where alphago defeated a human Champion
so the way it works is in reinforcement
learning the system is allowed for
example if in this case we're talking
about Chess so we allow the system to
first of all watch playing a game of
chess so it could be with a human being
or it could be the system itself there
are computer games of Chess right so
either this new learning system has to
watch that game or watch uh human being
play the game because this is
reinforcement uh learning is pretty much
all visual so when you're teaching the
system to play a game the system will
not actually go behind the scenes to
understand the logic of your software of
this game or anything like that it is
just visually watching the screen and
then it learns okay so reinforcement
learning to a large extent it works on
that so you need to create a mechanism
whereby your model will be able to watch
somebody playing the game and then you
allow the system also to start playing
the game so it pretty much starts from
scratch okay and as it moves forward it
it it's at right at the beginning the
system really knows nothing about the
game of chess okay so initially it is a
clean slate it just starts by observing
how you're playing so it will make some
random moves and keep losing badly but
then what happens is over a period of
time so you need to now allow the system
or you need to play with the system not
just 1 2 3 4 or five times but hundreds
of times thousands of times maybe even
hundreds of thousands of times and
that's exactly how alpha go has done it
played millions of games between itself
and the system right so for the game of
chess also you need to do something like
that you need to allow the system to
play chess and then learn on its own
over a period of reputation so I think
you can probably explain it to this much
to this extent and it should be uh
sufficient now this is another question
which is again somewhat similar but here
the size is not coming into picture so
the question is how will you know which
machine learning algorithm to choose for
your classification problem now this is
not only classification problem it could
be a regression problem I would like to
generalize this question so if somebody
asks you how will you choose how will
you know which algorithm to use the
simple answer is there is no way you can
decide exactly saying that this is the
algorithm I'm going to use in a variety
of situations there are some guidelines
like for example you will obviously
depending on the problem you can say
whether it is a classification problem
or a regression problem and then in that
sense you are kind of restricting
yourself to if it is a classification
problem there are you can only apply a
classification algorithm right to that
extent you can probably let's say limit
the number of algorithms but now within
the classification algorithms you have
decision trees you have svm you have
logistic regression is it possible to
outright say yes so for this particular
problem since you have EXP this now this
is the exact algorithm that you can use
that is not possible okay so we have to
try out a bunch of algorithms see which
one gives us the best performance and
best accuracy and then decide to go with
that particular algorithm so in machine
learning a lot of it happens through
trial and error there is uh no real
possibility that anybody can just by
looking at the problem or understanding
the problem tell you that okay in this
particular situation this is exactly the
algorithm that you you should use then
the questions may be around application
of machine learning and this question is
specifically around how Amazon is able
to recommend other things to buy so this
is around recommendation engine how does
it work how does the recommendation
engine work so this is basically the
question is all about so the
recommendation engine again Works based
on various inputs that are provided
obviously something like uh you know
Amazon website or e-commerce site like
Amazon collects a lot of data around the
customer Behavior who is purchasing what
and if somebody is buying a particular
thing they're also buying something else
so this kind of Association right so
this is the unsupervised learning we
talked about they use this to associate
and Link or relate items and that is one
part of it so they kind of build
association between items saying that
somebody buying this is also buying this
that is one part of it then they also
profile the users right based on their
age their gender their geographic
location they will do some profiling and
then when somebody is logging in and
when somebody is shopping kind of the
mapping of these two things are done
they try to identify obviously if you
have logged in then they know who you
are and your information is available
like for example your age maybe your
gender and where you're located what you
purchased earlier right so all this is
taken and the recommendation engine
basic basically uses all this
information and comes up with
recommendations for a particular user so
that is how the recommendation engine
work all right then the question can be
uh something very basic like when will
you go for classification versus
regression right when do you do
classification instead of regression or
when do you use classification instead
of regression now yes so so this is
basically going back to the
understanding of the basics of
classification and regression so
classification is used used when you
have to identify or categorize things
into discrete classes so the best way to
respond to this question is to take up
some examples and use it otherwise it
can become a little tricky the question
may sound very simple but explaining it
can sometimes be very tricky in case of
regression we use of course there will
be some keywords that they will be
looking for so just you need to make
sure you use those keywords one is the
discrete values and other is the
continuous values so for regression if
you are trying to find some continuous
values you use regression whereas if
you're trying to find some discrete
values you use classification and then
you need to illustrate what are some of
the examples so classification is like
let's say there are images and you need
to put them into classes like cat dog
elephant tiger something like that so
that is a classification problem or it
can be that is a multiclass
classification problem it could be
binary classification problem like for
example example whether a customer will
buy or he will not buy that is a
classification binary classification it
can be in the weather forecast area now
weather forecast is again combination of
regression and classification because on
the one hand you want to predict whether
it's going to rain or not that's a
classification problem that's a binary
classification right whether it's going
to rain or not rain however you also
have to predict what is going to be the
temperature tomorrow right now
temperature is a continuous value you
can't answer the temperature in a yes or
no kind of a response right so what will
be the temperature tomorrow so you need
to give a number which can be like 20°
30° or whatever right so that is where
you use regression one more example is
stock price prediction so that is where
again you will use regression so these
are the various examples so you need to
illustrate with examples and make sure
you include those keywords like discrete
and continuous so the next question is
more about a little bit of a design
related question to understand your
Concepts and things like that so it is
how will you design a spam filter so how
do you basically design or develop a
spam filter so I think the main thing
here is he is looking at probably
understanding your Concepts in terms of
uh what is the algorithm you will use or
what is your understanding about
difference between classification and
regression uh and things like that right
and the process of course the
methodology and the process so the best
way to go about responding to this is we
say that okay this is a classification
problem because we want to find out
whether an email is a spam or not spam
so that we can apply the filter
accordingly so first thing is to
identify what type of a problem it is so
we have identified that it is a
classification then the second step may
be to find out what kind of algorithm to
use now since this is a binary
classification problem logistic
regression is a very common very common
algorithm but however right as I said
earlier earlier also we can never say
that okay for this particular problem
this is exactly the algorithm that we
can use so we can also probably try
decision trees or even support Vector
meins for example svm so we will kind of
list down a few of these algorithms and
we will say okay we want to we would
like to try out these algorithms and
then we go about taking your historical
data which is the labeled data which are
marked so you will have a bunch of
emails and uh then you split that into
training and test data sets you use your
training data set to train your model
that or your algorithm that you have
used rather the model actually so and
you actually will have three models
let's say you are trying to test out
three algorithms so you will obviously
have three models so you need to try all
three models and test them out as well
see which one gives the best accuracy
and then you decide that you will go
with that model okay so training and
test will be done and then you zero in
on one particular model and then you say
okay this is the model will we use we
will use and then go ahead and Implement
that or put that in production so that
is the way you design a Spam fi the next
question is about random Forest so what
is random Forest this is a very
straightforward question however the
response you need to be again a little
careful while we all know what is random
Forest explaining this can sometimes be
tricky so one thing is random Forest is
kind of in one way it is an extension of
decision trees because it is basically
nothing but you have multiple decision
trees and uh trees will basically you
will use for doing if it is
classification mostly it is
classification you will use the the
trees for classification and then you
use voting for finding the the final
class so that is the underlyings but how
will you explain this how will you
respond to this so first thing obviously
we will say that random Forest is one of
the algorithms and the more important
thing that you need to probably the
interviewer is is waiting to hear is
Ensemble learner right so this is one
type of Ensemble learner what is
Ensemble learner Ensemble learner is
like a combination of algorithms so it
is a learner which consists of more than
one algorithm or more than one maybe
models okay so in case of random Forest
the algorithm is the same but instead of
using one instance of it we use multiple
instances of it and we use so in a way
that is a a random Forest is an ensemble
learner there are other types of
Ensemble Learners where we have like we
use different algorithms itself so you
have one maybe logistic regression and a
decision tree combined together and so
on and so forth or there are other ways
like for example splitting the data in a
certain way and so on so that's all
about Ensemble we will not go into that
but random Forest itself I think the
interviewer will be happy to hear this
word Ensemble Learners and so then you
go and explain how the random Forest
works so if the random Forest for is
used for classification then we use what
is known as a voting mechanism so
basically how does it work let's say
your random Forest consists of 100 trees
okay and each observation you pass
through this forest and each observation
let's say it is a classification problem
binary classification zero or one and
you have 100 trees now if 90 trees say
that it is a zero and 10 of the trees
say it is a one you take the majority
you may take a vote and since 90 of them
are saying zero you classify this as
zero then you take the next observation
and so on so that is the way random
Forest works for classification if it is
a regression problem it's somewhat
similar but only thing is instead of vot
what we will do is so in regression
remember what happens you actually
calculate a value right so for example
you're using regression to predict the
temperature and you have 100 trees and
each tree obviously will probably
predict a different value of the
temperature they may be close to each
other but they may not be exactly the
same value so these 100 trees so how do
you now find the actual value the output
for the entire Forest right so you have
outputs of individual trees which are a
part of this Forest but then you need to
find the final output of the forest
itself so how do you do that so in case
of regression you take like an average
or the mean of all the 100 trees right
so this is also a way of reducing the
error so maybe if you have only one tree
and if that one tree makes a error it is
basically 100% wrong or 100% right right
but if you have on the other hand if you
have a bunch of trees you are basically
mitigating that error or reducing that
error okay so that is the way random
Forest works so the next question is
considering the long list of machine
learning algorithms how will you decide
on which one to use so once again here
there is no way to outright say that
this is the algorithm that we will use
for a given data set this is a very good
question but then the rest response has
to be like again there will not be a one
size fits all so we need to first of all
you can probably shorten the list in
terms of by saying okay whether it is a
classification problem or it is a
regression problem to that extent you
can probably uh shorten the list because
you don't have to use all of them if it
is a classification problem you only can
pick from the classification algorithms
right so for example if it's a
classification you cannot use linear
regression algorithm there if it is a
regression problem you cannot use svm or
maybe no you can use svm but maybe a
logistic regression right so to that
extent you can probably shorten the list
but still you will not be able to 100%
decide on saying that this is the exact
algorithm that I'm going to use so the
way to go about is you choose a few
algorithms based on what the problem is
you try out your data you train some
models of these algorithms check which
one gives you the lowest error or the
highest accurac
and based on that you choose that
particular algorithm okay all right then
there can be questions around bias and
variance so the question can be what is
bias and variance in machine learning uh
so you just need to give out a
definition for each of these for example
bias in machine learning it occurs when
the predicted values are far away from
the actual value so that is a bias okay
and whereas they are all all the values
are probably they are far off but they
are very near to each other though the
predicted values are close to each other
right while they are far off from the
actual value but they are close to each
other you see the difference so that is
bias and then the other part is your
variance now variance is when the
predicted values are all over the place
right so the variance is high that means
it may be close to the Target but it is
kind of very scattered so the point the
predicted values are not close to each
other right in case of bias the
predicted values are close to each other
but they are not close to the Target but
here they may be close to the Target but
they may not be close to each other so
they are a little bit more scattered so
that is what in case of a variance okay
then the next question is about again
related to bias and variance what is the
tradeoff between bias and variance yes I
think this is a interesting question
because these two are heading in
different directions so for example if
you try to minimize the bias variance
will keep going high and if you try to
minimize the variance buys will keep
going high and there is no way you can
minimize both of them so you need to
have a tradeoff saying that okay this is
the level at which I will have my bias
and this is the level at which I will
have variance so the trade-off is that
pretty much uh that you you decide what
is the level you will tolerate for your
buyers and what is the level you will
tolerate for variance and a combination
of these two in such a way that your
final results are not we off and having
a tradeoff will ensure that the results
are consistent right so that is
basically the output is consistent and
which means that they are close to each
other and they are also accurate that
means they are as close to the Target as
possible right so if either of these is
high then one of them will go off the
track define precision and Recall now
again here I think uh it would be best
to draw a diagram and take a the conf
ution Matrix and it is very simple the
definition is like a formula your
Precision is true positive by true
positive plus false positive and your
recall is true positive by true positive
plus false negative okay so that's you
can just show it in a mathematical way
that's pretty much uh you know that can
be shown that's the easiest way to
define so the next question can be about
decision tree what is decision tree
proof Runing and why is it so basically
decision trees are really simple to
implement and understand but one of the
drawbacks of decision trees is that it
can become highly complicated as it
grows right and the rules and the
conditions can become very complicated
and this can also lead to overfitting
which is basically that during training
you will get 100% accuracy but when
you're doing testing you'll get a lot of
Errors so that is the reason pruning
needs to be done so the purpose or the
reason for doing decision tree pruning
is to reduce overfitting or to cut down
on overfitting and what is decision tree
pruning it is basically that you reduce
the number of branches because as you
may be aware a tree consists of the root
node and then there are several internal
nodes and then you have the leaf nodes
now if there are too many of these
internal nodes that is when you face the
problem of overfitting and pruning is
the process of reducing those internal
nodes all right so the next question can
be what is logistic regression uh so
basically logistic regression is um one
of the techniques used for performing
classification especially binary
classification now there is something
special about logistic regression and
there are a couple of things you need to
be careful about first of all the name
is a little confusing it is called
logistic regression but it is used for
classification so this can be sometimes
confusing so you need to probably
clarify that to the interviewer if if
it's really you know if it is required
and they can also ask this like a trick
question right so that is one part
second thing is the term logistic has
nothing to do with the usual Logistics
that we talk about but it is derived
from log so that the mathematical
derivation involves log and therefore
the name logistic regression so what is
logistic regression and how is it used
so logistic regression is used for
binary classification and the output of
a logistic regression is either a zero
or a one and it varies so it's basically
it calculates a probability between zero
and one and we can set a threshold that
can vary typically it is 0.5 so any
value above 0.5 is considered as one and
if the probability is below 0.5 it is
considered as zero so that is the way we
calculate the probability or the system
calculates the probability and based on
the threshold it sets a value of zero or
one which is like a binary
classification Z or one okay then we
have a question around K nearest
neighbor algorithm so explain K nearest
neighbor algorithm so first of all what
is a k nearest neighbor algorithm this
is a classification algorithm so that is
the first thing we need to mention and
we also need to mention mention that the
K is a number it is an integer and this
is variable and we can Define what the
value of K should be it can be 2 3 5 7
and usually it is an odd number so that
is something we need to mention
technically it can be even number also
but then typically it would be odd
number and we will see why that is okay
so based on that we need to classify
objects okay we need to classify objects
so again it will be very helpful to draw
a diagram you know if you're explaining
I think that will be the best way so
draw some diagram like this and let's
say we have three clusters or three
classes existing and now you want to
find for a new item that has come you
want to find out which class this
belongs to right so you go about as the
name suggests you go about finding the
nearest neighbors right the points which
are closest to this and how many of them
you will find that is what is defined by
K now let's say our initial value of K K
was five okay so you will find the K the
five nearest data points so in this case
as it is Illustrated these are the five
nearest data points but then all five do
not belong to the same class or cluster
so there are one belonging to this
cluster one the second one belonging to
this cluster two three of them belonging
to this third cluster okay so how do you
decide that's exactly the reason we
should as much as possible try to assign
a odd number so that it becomes easier
to assign this so in this case you see
that the majority actually if there are
multiple classes then you go with the
majority so since three of these items
belong to this class we assign which is
basically the in in this case the green
or the tennis or the third cluster as I
was talking about right so we assign it
to this third class so in this case it
is uh that's how it is decided okay so K
nearest neighbor so first thing is to
identify the number of of neighbors that
are mentioned as K so in this case it is
K is equal to five so we find the five
nearest points and then find out out of
these five which class has the maximum
number in that okay and and then the uh
new data point is assigned to that class
okay and with that we have come to the
end of this NLP full course I hope you
found it valuable and entertaining
please ask any questions about the
topics covered in the video in the
comment box below and our team of
experts will assist you in addressing
your problems as as soon as possible so
thank you so much for being here today
we'll see you next time until then keep
learning and stay tuned to Simply learn
for more amazing updates staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe subcribe to the simply learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to ner up and get
certified click
here